ALRIGHT GOOD MORNING WELCOME TO
THE FAMILY BUDGET COMMITTEE.
NUMBER TWO ON EDUCATION FINANCE
TODAY IS OUR K. TWELVE HEARING
SPECIFICALLY ON THE L. C. F. F. --
SPENDING PROPOSAL IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET --
AS WELL AS OUR STATE
ACCOUNTABILITY SYSTEM WILL ALSO
HEAR ABOUT THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL TO HELP PROVIDE PENSION
RELIEF FOR SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
AND LASTLY WE'LL HEAR FROM MIKE
FINE WITH THICK MATS ON THE
FISCAL STATUS OF OUR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND FOR THE LAST THREE
YEARS I THINK THIS IS SOMETHING
WE KINDA.
UNFORTUNATELY GLOSSED OVER YOUR
YOUR WORK --
MIKE FIND IT FAKE MATT BUT AS WE
KNOW.
SACRAMENTO LA AND THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA THIS IS AN ISSUE OF
GREAT IMPORTANCE EVERY YEAR BUT
ESPECIALLY THIS YEAR.
AND OF COURSE WE WENT --
TO I KNOW MISTER MARTZ WHICH IS
GOING TO BE A LITTLE BIT AND THE
PROPOSAL WE ALSO WANT TO MAKE
SURE WE TALK ABOUT.
THE OVERALL FISCAL HEALTH OF OUR
SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND WHAT'S
NEEDED TO ADEQUATELY SUPPORT OUR
PUBLIC EDUCATION SYSTEM HERE IN
CALIFORNIA.
AS A WITH THAT WE'RE GOING TO
BEGIN WITH ISSUE NUMBER ONE THE
GOVERNOR'S NINETEEN TWENTY
BUDGET PROPOSAL RELATED TO THE
LOCAL CONTROL.
FUNDING FORMULA AND WOOD WHEN A
CALL OF TERMINA FINANCE DELEO.
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION AND IF
YOU COULD PRESENT IN THAT ORDER
THANK YOU
.
LOOK AT THE END.
I'M THANK YOU AGAIN THANK YOU.
DâN HAND OUR DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET FOR TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY INCLUDES A TWO
BILLION DOLLAR PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT GENERAL FUND
INCREASE FOR THE LOCAL CONTROL
FUNDING FORMULA.
THIS INCREASE REFLECTS A THREE
POINT 46% COST OF LIVING
ADJUSTMENT.
AND A POINT 12% DECLINE IN
AVERAGE DAILY ATTENDANCE.
OVERALL THIS BUDGET BRINGS TOTAL
LCF FUNDING.
OCTOBER I'LL SEE IF OF FUNDING
TO SIXTY THREE BILLION.
TO TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY AND
BRINGS THE TOTAL OF NEW ON GOING
FUNDING SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND
CHARTER SCHOOLS HAVE RECEIVED.
SINCE TWENTY THIRTEEN FOURTEEN
TO TWENTY THREE BILLION.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET ALSO
INCLUDES AN ADDITIONAL NINE
MILLION PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GENERAL FUND FOR COUNTY OFFICES
OF EDUCATION TO REFLECT A THREE
POINT 46% COST OF LIVING
ADJUSTMENT.
AN AVERAGE DAILY ATTENDANCE
CHANGES UNDER THE LOCAL CONTROL
FUNDING FORMULA.
INCLUDING THE MINIMUM STATE AID
THIS BRINGS TOTAL I'LL SEE ABOUT
FUNDING FOR COUNTY OFFICES OF
EDUCATION TO APPROXIMATELY ONE
BILLION.
LASTLY THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROPOSES TO ESTABLISH A
MECHANISM WHEREBY THE
ADMINISTRATION CAN ASSESS THE
AFFORDABILITY OF THE COLA ON THE
ALSO.
ON THE CFF IN THE BUDGET YEAR
WITHIN THE PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT MINIMUM GUARANTEE.
IN ALL OTHER SPENDING PRIORITIES
AN AUTOMATIC ALTERNATIVE CALL
THE TO THE FORMULA IF NECESSARY
WITH THAT I'D BE A HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE.
THANK YOU HELLO.
GOOD MORNING RYAN ANDERSON WITH
THE LA NOW.
THE COUPLE COMMENTS ON THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSALS.
WE CONTINUE TO THANK THE LC FF
HAS A NUMBER OF ADVANTAGES OVER
ALTERNATIVE FINANCE SYSTEMS BUT
SPECIFICALLY THE GOVERNOR
PROPOSES --
NEW FORMULA THAT WOULD
AUTOMATICALLY CAP --
THE COST OF LIVING ADJUSTMENT
FOR L. C. F. F..
AND WE'RE RECOMMENDING THAT THE
LEGISLATURE REJECT THIS PROPOSAL
BUT WE THINK THE FACT THAT THIS
PROPOSALS BEING PUT FORWARD IS
AN ACKNOWLEDGEMENT THAT THE
CHANGE WE MADE LAST YEAR WHICH
CONTINUOUSLY APPROPRIATES
THEY'LL SEE IF OF COLA.
IS NOT GONNA BE ACTIONABLE AND
ALL BUT SHOULD YEARS IN SOME
CASES YOU'RE NOT GOING TO HAVE
THE RESOURCES NECESSARY TO FUND
THE FULL STATUTORY COLA.
WE THINK THE APPROPRIATE WAY TO
OF RECOGNIZE THAT REALITY IS
JUST TO RETURN TO THE PREVIOUS
SYSTEM OF PROVIDING THESE
AUGMENTATIONS ON A DISCRETIONARY
BASIS RATHER THAN.
ESTABLISHING YET ANOTHER FORMULA
THAT MAKES THE BUDGET PROCESS
LESS TRANSPARENT AND HARDER --
FOR FOLKS TO FOLLOW TING FORMULA
AND SPECIFICALLY THE MINIMUM
STATE AID PROVISION.
I'M JUST REAL BRIEFLY HERE PRIOR
TO A TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN
FOURTEEN ONE PROPERTY TAX
COLLECTIONS INCREASED FOR COUNTY
OFFICES OF EDUCATION THEIR STATE
A DECREASE DOLLAR FOR DOLLAR WE
DON'T ALLOW.
COUNTY OFFICES TO RECEIVE HIGHER
LEVELS OF FUNDING JUST BASED ON
THEIR PROPERTY TAX COLLECTIONS
THE MINIMUM STATE AID PROVISION.
PUTS A CAP ON HOW MUCH WE CAN
REDUCE STATE FUNDING WHEN THOSE
PROPERTY TAX COLLECTIONS
INCREASE CONSEQUENTLY THERE'S
INCREASING DISPARITY BETWEEN --
HOW COUNTIES ARE FUNDED BASED
SOLELY ON HOW MUCH PROPERTY TAX
REVENUE THEY'RE COLLECTING?
OUT WHAT WE'RE CONCERNED ABOUT
THESE INEQUITIES WE ALSO THINK
THERE ARE BETTER USES OF THE NOW
OVER A HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS.
THAT ARE GOING TO THIS FUNCTION
BUT WE ALSO HAVE A CONCERN THAT
THE A GOVERNOR'S BUDGET DOES NOT
RECOGNIZE THE FULL COST OF THIS
PROVISION.
RIGHT NOW THEY THEY DON'T
ACTUALLY PROJECT THE COSTS GOING
FOR THE JUST HOLD THEM FLAT EVEN
THOUGH THE INCREASE YEAR OVER
YEAR WE WE THANK.
WITHIN THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
RIGHT NOW THERE'S FORTY MILLION
DOLLARS OF AS YET UNACCOUNTED
FOR COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH THE
MINIMUM STATE A PROVISION.
AND GIVEN THAT THERE'S VERY
LITTLE ROOM WITHIN THEIR
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT PACKAGE --
FOR THIS ADDITIONAL SPENDING
THIS IS SOMETHING WE THINK THE
LEGISLATURE SHOULD BE THINKING
ABOUT RIGHT NOW.
THANK YOU.
OKAY THANK YOU DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS KIND
JACKSON --
DEPUTY SUPERINTENDENT DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION ON BEHALF OF
SUPERINTENDENT TONY THURMOND.
WE SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
WHICH PROPOSES TO FULLY FUND THE
LC FF STATUTORY COLA.
FOR TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY
TWENTY WE FURTHER APPRECIATE THE
ADMINISTRATION'S ONGOING
COMMITMENT TO THE LC FF AND
EDUCATIONAL AND INVESTMENTS AS
EVIDENCED BY FULLY FUNDING THE
LC A FAT IN. TWENTY EIGHTEEN
TWENTY NINETEEN TWO YEARS AHEAD
OF SCHEDULE.
WITH THAT THIS FULLY FUNDED THIS
YEAR.
WE DO STILL CONSIDER THE
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN TO BE A
TRANSITION YEAR SINCE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ARE STILL RECEIVING
THE FINAL INSTALLMENT.
OF GAP FUNDING.
AS SUCH SOME COMPONENTS OF LCF
AT SUCH AS INSTRUCTIONAL TIME
REQUIREMENTS ARE NOT EFFECTIVE
UNTIL --
NINETEEN TWENTY AND NOW THAT THE
L. SAFE WILL BE FULLY
IMPLEMENTED WE LOOK FORWARD TO
DISCUSSIONS WITH THE LEGISLATURE
ABOUT HOW TO INCREASE FUNDING
BEYOND BASED GRANT RATES.
THANK YOU
OKAY THANK YOU QUESTIONS.
MR DONE I HAVE A COMMENT YEAH --
I WOULD SAY THAT FULLY FUNDING
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT ORPHALI
FUNDING LCF ISN'T FULLY FUNDING
THE CALIFORNIA EDUCATIONAL
SYSTEM.
I THINK WE'RE GETTING CAUGHT UP
IN A HEARING IN THIS ROOM RIGHT
NOW AND HAD.
YOU KNOW I'VE I'VE DONE IT IN IN
IN.
IN TREATING PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT AS THE CEILING.
AND I THINK THIS BODY.
THE OUR GOVERNOR THE LEGISLATURE
NEEDS MAKE A MUCH STRONGER
COMMITMENT.
THE CALIFORNIA STUDENTS BY
FUNDING WELL ABOVE THE
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT LEVEL
SO I JUST I I GET WORRIED WHEN
PEOPLE COME ON THE WE HAD OUR
SELVES LACKS A WHILE WE FULLY
FUNDED NINETY EIGHT THIS YEAR.
AND LOOK WHERE WE ARE IN.
YOU KNOW THE FUNDING LEVELS WILL
MAKE AS COMPARED TO OTHER STATES
AND ASKING HER TO THE COMMITMENT
WE NEED.
AND THE INVESTMENT WE NEED TO
MAKE IN CALIFORNIA STUDENTS SO
THAT A TURN ABOUT GENES YEAH
WELL THAT'S A GREAT COMMENT --
MISTER O'DONNELL AND I WANT TO
TURN THAT INTO SOME QUESTIONS
AND SO.
I I FULLY CONCUR THAT WE'VE DONE
A GOOD JOB THAT.
FULLY FUNDING THE TARGETS THAT
WE LAID OUT IN HOW MUCH MONEY WE
PUT INTO THE ARE PROP NINETY
EIGHT EDUCATION --
BUDGET THE LAST --
FIVE YEARS ESSENTIALLY
INCREASING FUNDING BY ROUGHLY
50% THROUGH DISTRICTS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA BUT AS YOU JUST NOTED --
EDUCATION CHERYL DONALD THAT
WE'RE STILL YOU KNOW WOEFULLY
FUNDING OUR PUBLIC SCHOOLS
COMPARED IT.
STATES ACROSS THE NATION.
AND YOU KNOW WITHOUT GETTING TO
THE NUMBER WE'RE AT WE'RE NOW
WE'RE WE'RE NO WE'RE CLEARS
NUMBER NEAR THE TOP NEAR NO NO
WORK NO NOR ARE WE AT THE MIDDLE.
AND I WANTED TO ASK TO THE
GOVERNOR'S TEAM FOR DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE DO YOU THINK OUR
SCHOOLS ARE ADEQUATELY FUNDED.
AND IF NOT --
WHAT'S THE PLAN --
TO DRAMATICALLY INCREASE PUBLIC
SCHOOL FUNDING TO GET CLOSER TO
THE NATIONAL AVERAGE.
AT THIS POINT THE END WE SUPPORT
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET WE WOULD
NOTE THAT I WASN'T WHEN I ASKED
RECYCLING.
DOESN'T A PROMINENT FINANCE
THINK THAT.
OUR PUBLIC SCHOOL.
IN CALIFORNIA ADEQUATELY FUNDED.
AND IF NOT.
WHAT'S THE PLAN. TO GET THERE.
ERIN AT A AT APARTMENT OF
FINANCE AS MY COLLEAGUE NOTED WE
SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
FIRST AND FOREMOST AND WE WOULD
NOTE -- THAT
THIS BUDGET REALLY MAKES AN
ATTEMPT TO PRIORITIZE BUDGET
RESILIENCY AND FUNDING A WITHIN
THE PROPOSITION MINIMUM
PROPOSITION NINETY MINIMUM
GUARANTEED TO BE ABLE TO GET --
ALL THE RESOURCES THAT WE CAN TO
SCHOOLS --
WITH IN THAT AND WITHIN THE
CERTAINLY THE THE STATE GENERAL
FUND.
REVENUES THE STATE OF CURRENT
STATE OF AFFAIRS THERE --
I WOULD NOTE THAT SINCE THE
TROUGH OF THE RECESSION WE'VE
GONE FROM JUST OVER FORTY SEVEN
BILLION IMPROPER NINETY EIGHT TO
OVER EIGHTY BILLION NOW --
SCHOOLS OF RECEIVE LIKE MY
COLLEAGUES SAID MORE SEE OF
PFAFF --
THEY'RE JUST DISCRETIONARY
FUNDING AS WELL --
IN ALL THE BUDGETS FROM --
FOURTEEN FIFTEEN THROUGH THE
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN BUDGET WERE
SCHOOLS HAVE RECEIVED OVER SEVEN
BILLION DOLLARS OF DISCRETIONARY
FUNDING SO CERTAINLY THE BROWN
ADMINISTRATION AND THIS CURRENT
ADMINISTRATION CONTINUES TO
PRIORITIZE.
OUR FUNDING FOR SCHOOLS --
AND GETTING COULD CERTAINLY
INCREASING THAT RANKING AS WELL
AND THAT WILL BE REFLECTED I GET
ALL THAT AND THAT'S IN A LONGER
VERSION OF WHAT I SAID EARLIER
IN MY STE MY STATEMENT THAT
WE'VE.
COME A LONG WAY AND RESTORED
FUNDING IN THIS.
PLAN BEFORE US DOES I THINK
WITHIN THAT BUDGET CLIMATE.
PUT AS MUCH AS WE CAN.
TO SUPPORT OUR SCHOOLS AND LOOK
FOR ALTERNATIVE WAYS TO HELP
DISTRICTS BACKGROUND TALK ABOUT
THE PENSION BUT DO WE THINK AND
OUT OF THE GOVERNOR IS THAT
STRONG EDUCATION CHAMPION HE RAN
EDUCATION THAT'S THAT'S HIS
THAT'S HIS BIG FOCUS IS PUBLIC
EDUCATION.
DO WE THINK THAT OUR SCHOOLS ARE
ADEQUATELY FUNDED.
I DON'T THINK WE HAVE A POSITION
ON THAT BECAUSE THAT'S A
DIFFICULT --
WORD I THINK TO TO DEFINE I
THINK WE WOULD SAY WE'RE DOING --
WHAT WE CAN TO PRIORITIZE AS
MUCH AS POSSIBLE EDUCATION
FUNDING WITHIN THE BUDGET?
THIS ORDER I THAT AGAIN MISTER
DON NOT HONORABLY GET THIS AND I
THINK.
HE HE APPRECIATE YOUR RESPONSE
IT WAS A TOUGH QUESTION BY WE
HANDLE THAT VERY WELL --
BUT I I THINK YOU KNOW WE CAN WE
CAN BLAME THE GOVERNOR WE
APPOINT THE GOVERNOR AND ON YOUR
BLAME THE GOVERNMENT APPOINT THE
GOVERNOR ALSO THINK THIS BODY
THE LEGISLATURE PLAYS A ROLE IN
THIS EXERCISE.
TO WEAR AND THEY ARE --
YOU KNOW MY COLLEAGUES RUN AND
SAY THEY'RE ALL FOR EDUCATION
FUNDING IN ADEQUATELY YEAH WHEN
IT COMES SO IN TIME. FOR THE
BUDGET YOU KNOW WE NEED TO WE
AND I THINK THAT'S IN ORDER TO
BE PART SO BACK TO THAT BUT BUT
AGAIN WROTE YEAH.
I DON'T SPEAK FOR THE GOVERNOR --
BUT HE DID A GOOD JOB AGAIN
FORGET --
BUT YOU KNOW IT IT ALSO SPEAKS
TO OUR PRIORITIES TO IN THIS
LEGISLATURE'S NEEDS TO LOOK IN
THE MIRROR A BIT.
TO SEE WHAT OUR PRIORITIES ARE
BECAUSE OFTEN THEY LIVE WELL
OUTSIDE.
OF THE EDUCATION ARENA.
YET AND SO WHAT WITH THAT AND
WOULD THE ADMINISTRATION BE OPEN
TO OF OF COURSE YOU WERE SAYING
IF WE CAN.
REDIRECT MONIES FROM THE
EXISTING STATE BUDGET FROM OTHER
DEPARTMENTS AND DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS WHAT HAVE YET. TO
POTENTIALLY --
EDUCATION.
IN A WORLD WILL DO AS MUCH AS WE
CAN THERE BUT YOU KNOW IT'S ONLY
SQUEEZING SO MUCH OUT YOU KNOW
OF THE AND REALLOCATING THE THE
PIE THERE.
AS FAR AS GROWING THE PIPE HE
WITH THE MINISTRATION BE OPENED
ITS SETTING MORE.
ROBUST OUT YEAR TARGETS FOR L.
C. F. F. LIKE WE DID WITH THE
FIRST ROUND.
KIND OF LIKE AND AND ASPIRATE.
BECAUSE I THINK RIGHT NOW WITH
THEIR WORDS FEW NOW THAT.
LOWER EXPECTATIONS AS FAR AS
FUNDING OUR OUR PUBLIC SCHOOLS
IMMERSING IT.
I THINK GIVEN THAT THEIR WE
HAVEN'T SEEN A YOU KNOW A
FINALIZED RIPPLES ON THAT YET I
I WOULDN'T BE ABLE TO GIVE A
POSITION FROM THE ADMINISTRATION --
BUT CERTAINLY THAT CAN BE PART
OF THE CONVERSATION MOVING
FORWARD AS WE GO A CONTINUE TO
GO INTO THE SPRING AND THEN A
REVISION [inaudible]
OKAY.
THANK YOU AND NOW THAT CERTAINLY
AT A PRIORITY OF THE OF THE
ASSEMBLY AND WE'RE LOOKING AT
REVENUE --
OPTIONS TO ADEQUATELY FUND OUR
PUBLIC SCHOOLS BUT ADDITION.
WHILE WE'RE GETTING THERE I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE SET
A MARKER THE SPARE WEEK AS FAR
AS WHERE WE WANT TO BE IN
FUNDING OUR PUBLIC SCHOOLS IN
CALIFORNIA BECAUSE IT.
HAS A GREAT IMPACT ON OUR
CLASSROOMS AND CONSTRUCTION IN
AND TRYING --
TO ADDRESS OUR ACHIEVEMENT GAP
IN EQUITY ISSUES FOR A SCHOOL
DISTRICT SO AS FAR AS EQUITY.
ISSUES LAST YEAR AS YOU KNOW WE
WE WERE ABLE TO PUT IN THE
BUDGET ONE TIME MONEY FOR THIS --
LOW PERFORMING SUBGROUP FOR L.
C. F. F..
AND THE MONIES ARE RIGHT NOW.
GOING OUT TO DISTRICTS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA AND I WANTED TO ASK
THAT.
TO DEPARTMENT OF FINANCES --
POSITION THAT WAS IN LAST YEAR'S
BUDGET BUT IT'S NOT IN THIS
YEAR'S BUDGET.
GOOD MORNING AMBER ALEXANDER
WITH DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I
MEAN IF YOU'RE REFERRING TO THE
LOW PERFORMING STUDENT BLOCK
GRANT THAT WAS BUILT IN --
AS PART OF THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN
BUDGET ACT --
AGAIN THAT WAS ONE TIME --
WE WILL CONTINUE TO HAVE
CONVERSATIONS THIS YEAR --
ANOTHER IT'S A BILL MOVING
FORWARD --
THAT WOULD WOULD PROVIDE MORE OF
AN ONGOING INVESTMENT AND WE
DON'T HAVE A PROPOSAL ON THAT AT
THIS TIME BUT I I WANTED TO NOT
YOU KNOW PRE JUDGE WHETHER OR
NOT WE HAVE ENOUGH MONEY FORTY
ONE INTO IT AGAIN.
BUT BASED UPON.
WHERE LITTLE OVER --
THREE COURT ALMOST THREE
QUARTERS THROUGH.%
THE THE BUDGET YEAR HOW'S IT
GOING SO FAR AND IS IS THAT --
IT IS A GUY THE MONEY'S GOING
OUT AND DO WE KNOW --
HOW THE EFFORTS ARE GOING ACROSS
I'M IN TERMS OF WHERE WE ARE IN
AND GETTING THE SPENDING OUT I'D
HAVE TO DEFER TO THE DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION?
HIS CONCERN IMPLEMENTING THAT
THAT BLOCK GRANT --
I DO THINK IT IS IMPORTANT TO
EMPHASIZE YOU KNOW OUTSIDE OF
THAT EFFORT THERE ARE A LOT OF
OTHER EFFORTS THAT WE'LL HEAR
ABOUT I THINK IN THE THIRD PANEL
AROUND THE ACCOUNTABILITY
STRUCTURE.
AND THAT ARE SPECIFICALLY
DESIGNED TO HELP DISTRICTS
IMPROVE STUDENT OUTCOMES
PARTICULARLY THOSE TIME STUDENT
GROUPS THAT ARE LOW PERFORMING.
OKAY.
MISTER JACKSON DO YOU WANNA TAKE
A CRACK ABSENCE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SO CURRENTLY THE DEPARTMENT IS --
IMPLEMENTING --
THE LOW PERFORMING STUDENT
STUDENT GRANT --
THERE WERE --
LAST A LOOK TO THERE WERE
APPROXIMATELY.
FIFTEEN HUNDRED SCHOOL DISTRICTS
THAT HAVE BEEN --
OF APPROVED OR HAVE SUBMITTED
THEIR APPLICATION THERE'S LESS
THAN.
A HUNDRED THAT HAVE OPTED OUT OF
THE PROGRAM ALLOW THE DEPARTMENT
IS STILL IN THE IMPLEMENTATION --
PHASE OF THAT WE WE ARE --
FUNDS WILL BE GOING OUT THAT DO
YOU THINK THEY WOULD HAVE ANY.
INFORMATION BACK BEFORE WE CLOSE
OUT THE BUDGET PROCESS.
POTENTIALLY THERE'S A DESIRE TO
RE UP THAT AND DO THAT AGAIN AND
CERTAINLY LIKE TO HAVE SOME.
FEEDBACK ON YOUR ONE
IMPLEMENTATION.
WHAT WITH RESPECT TO DATA IN
TERMS OF HOW MANY DISTRICTS
ACTUALLY SUBMITTED SUBMITTED
THEIR PLAN OR PROVE MET THE
DEADLINES EXCEPT FOR WE COULD --
PROVIDE PROVIDE THAT I WOULD
NEED TO GET BACK WITH OUR STAFF
IN TERMS OF A OF A TIME LINE BUT
WE CAN LOOK AT THAT SIR OKAY.
THANK YOU TO THE LA --
ANYBODY COMMENTS ON THIS ON THIS --
ALSO FROM LAST YEAR --
I I I THINK THAT WE WOULD --
CAUTION AGAINST ADOPTING THE
SAME APPROACH THAT WAS TAKEN
LAST YEAR --
WITH REGARDS TO THE LOW
PERFORMING STUDENT BLOCK GRANT
AS IT WAS INCLUDED IN LAST
YEAR'S BUDGET WE HAD TWO PRIMARY
CONCERNS.
ONE WAS THAT --
WHILE WE THINK THAT THERE'S
MERIT AND THE LC OF SUCH AS
GENERAL APPROACH OF SAYINGS FOR
INSTANCE THE POPULATION HAVE
LARGER EDUCATIONAL DEFICITS AND
ADDRESSING THOSE DEFICITS WILL
REQUIRE.
MORE RESOURCES --
THAT IS AN ACKNOWLEDGEMENT OF AN
ONGOING LONG STANDING PROBLEM
THAT PROBABLY WOULD NOT BE BEST
DRESSED THROUGH ONE TIME FUNDING.
I HAD IF YOU WERE TO MAKE THE
LOW PERFORMING STUDENT BLOCK
GRANT.
ON GOING WE WOULD STILL HAVE A
CONCERN WITH THAT SPECIFIC
CONSTRUCTION OF THAT GRANT.
WAS TIED TO INDIVIDUAL STUDENTS
WHO DID NOT MEET STANDARDS ON
THE STATEWIDE ASSESSMENTS OF
READING AND MATH.
WOULD BE CONCERNED THAT THAT
CREATES A CAN GE THOSE STUDENTS
TO ACTUALLY MEET THOSE STANDARDS
PARTICULARLY IF YOU'RE PROVIDING
A LARGE DOLLAR AMOUNT FOR EVERY
STUDENT WHO'S.
IN ONE OF THESE ELIGIBLE GROUPS
THAT'S NOT MEETING THE STANDARDS
WE WE THINK THAT.
THE INCENTIVE WOULD BE
MISALIGNED WITH THE POLICY A
PROPOSAL SO WE WE WOULD
RECOMMEND MAKING SOME
ADJUSTMENTS TO THAT.
OKAY THANK YOU THIS SECTION WAS
INFORMATIONAL.
AND SO WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO
ISSUE NUMBER.
TWO RELATED.
TO PENSIONS AND THEY EFFORTS.
TO AB SCHOOL DISTRICT BUT
THEY'RE PENSION COSTS
.
RIGHT OKAY THANK YOU RESTART
AGAIN WITH DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
AND LA JOH AND THEN CASTERS.
GOOD MORNING AGAIN MR CHAIR AN
IMMEDIATE APARTMENT OF FINANCE
AND I'M JUST GOING TO GIVE YOU A
BRIEF PRESENTATION ON THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL TO
PROVIDE.
A TOTAL OF THREE BILLION DOLLARS
IN RELIEF FOR K. TWELVE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND ALSO COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT EMPLOYER
CONTRIBUTIONS. TO CAL STARS.
I WOULD JUST LIKE TO AGAIN
REITERATE THE INCREASES THAT
SCHOOLS HAVE RECEIVED OVER THE
LAST HANDFUL OF YEARS SINCE
TWENTY THIRTEEN FOURTEEN UNDER
THE CFF LIKE I MENTIONED TWENTY
THREE BILLION OF NEW ONGOING
MONEY -- NOW
THROUGH TO THE TWENTY NINETEEN
TWENTY PROPOSED BUDGET AND THEN
ALSO THE TWO BILLION DOLLAR COST
OF LIVING ADJUSTMENT TO THE
FORMULA THAT REPRESENTS A THREE
POINT 46% COST OF LIVING
ADJUSTMENT --
ON TOP OF THE MORE THAN THREE
AND A HALF BILLION THAT.
WE PUT INTO THE ELF YOURSELF
LAST YEAR TO REACH FULL
IMPLEMENTATION IN THE LAST YEAR
OF TRANSITION AS THE CD THERE'S
A DEPARTMENT OF ED --
MENTIONED HOWEVER MISTER CHAIR
THAT MANY DISTRICTS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE ARE CONTINUING TO
GRAPPLE WITH THE RISING FIST
COCKED FIX COSTS THAT THEY HAVE.
IN DIFFICULT BUDGET DECISIONS AS
THEY REALLY ALL WORK TOWARDS
IMPROVING OUTCOMES FOR ALL OF
THEIR STUDENTS MATTER WHAT.
THE BACKGROUND MIGHT BE
[inaudible]
ADDITIONALLY.
BASED ON THE CURRENT STATE OF
GENERAL FUND REVENUES IT IS
UNLIKELY THAT SIGNIFICANT
ADDITIONAL MONIES WILL BE
AVAILABLE FOR THE LC A FAST AT
THE MERE VISION BEYOND THE COST
OF LIVING ADJUSTMENT.
ON LIKE IN THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN
BUDGET ACT IN MORE RECENT YEARS
WHEN WE HAD A LARGE SURGES IN
REVENUES --
FROM GOING FROM THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET TO THE MAYOR VISION
TIMELINE --
THAT IS WITHOUT SIGNIFICANTLY
REDUCING OTHER PARTS OF THE
BUDGET TO BE ABLE TO INCREASE
FUNDING.
FIRST SCHOOLS --
IN RECOGNITION.
OF THIS REALITY.
THE ADMINISTRATION IS PROPOSING
TO TAKE AVAILABLE ONE TIME NON
PROPOSITION NINETY RESOURCES
WITHIN THE BUDGET.
AND APPLY THEM IN A WAY THAT WE
FEEL WILL BE THE BEST.
BENEFITS.
OVER A MULTI YEAR PERIOD FOR
SCHOOLS.
A SPECIFICALLY THE BUDGET IS
PROPOSING LIKE I SAID A THREE
BILLION DOLLAR --
INFUSION OF MONIES INTO THE CAL
HALF OF EMPLOYERS TO PROVIDE
RATE REALLY FOR THEM.
APPROXIMATELY SEVEN HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS OF THIS WILL GO
OUT OVER THE NEXT TWO YEARS
WHICH WILL EQUAL ROUGHLY THREE
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS IN
EACH YEAR --
BEING NINETEEN TWENTY AND TWENTY
TWENTY ONE EFFECTIVELY REDUCING
EMPLOYER CONTRIBUTION RATES BY
1% IN EACH YEAR --
IN NINETEEN TWENTY TAKING
EMPLOYERS FROM EIGHTEEN POINT 1%
TO SEVENTEEN POINT 1%.
AND IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE TAKING
THEM FROM NINETEEN POINT 1%
CONTRIBUTION RATE TO EIGHTEEN
POINT 1%.
AFTER THAT THE REMAINING
APPROXIMATELY TWO POINT THREE
BILLION DOLLARS WILL GO TOWARDS
PAYING DOWN THE LONG TERM
UNFUNDED LIABILITY.
AND THAT IS ESTIMATED TO EQUAL
POINT 5% REDUCTION IN EACH
FUTURE YEAR FOR CONTRIBUTION
RATES BEGINNING IN. TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE FOR A TOTAL
ESTIMATED SAVINGS OF
APPROXIMATELY SIX POINT NINE
BILLION THROUGH TWENTY FORTY SIX
THE LIFE OF THE CURRENT CASTERS
FUNDING PLAN --
WITH THAT I WILL CONCLUDE MY
COMMENTS BUT I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS.
OKAY.
THANK YOU LA L..
THANK YOU AND GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIR KENNETH COUPON WITH
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE.
WE HAVE A HAND OUT THAT --
AND I WON'T COVER ALL OF THE
BACK ON IN THE HEARTS BUT
TURNING TO PAGE TWO AND KIND OF
BY WAY OF BACKGROUND.
IS ONE OF THE TOUCH BRIEFLY ON
THE SIGNIFICANCE OF THE
CHARACTERS FUNDING PLAN STATE
ADOPTED IN.
TWENTY FOURTEEN AS YOU PROBABLY
KNOW --
CONTRIBUTIONS TO CHARACTERS FROM
STATES AND SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
I HAVE NOT BEEN SUFFICIENT TO
PAY FOR BENEFITS AS TEACHERS
HAVE EARNED THEM FOR MOST OF
CHARACTERS HISTORY.
AND BY THE EARLY TWENTY TENS
THAT.
UNDER FUNDING HAD REACHED A
CRITICAL POINT WITH THE SYSTEM
PROJECTED TO RUN OUT OF ASSETS
BY THE MID TWENTY FORTY IS --
AND THE LEGISLATURE --
SPENT A LOT OF TIME THINKING
ABOUT THAT ISSUE HAD A LOT OF
HEARINGS TALKED ABOUT.
SOME OF THE PRINCIPLES FOR
ADDRESSING THAT SHORTFALL SHARED
RESPONSIBILITY.
I'M NOT LOTS OF DISCUSSION.
AND THAT ULTIMATELY LED TO THIS.
PLAN THAT WAS INTENDED TO
ELIMINATE THE UNFUNDED
LIABILITIES BY THE MID TWENTY
FORTY IS.
I THINK THE FIGURE ON PAGE TWO
REALLY ILLUSTRATES HOW
SIGNIFICANT THAT PLAN WAS.
IN MOVING CAL STIRS FROM
INTRODUCTORY WHERE IT WAS.
GOING TO RUN OUT OF FUNDING
WITHIN THE NEXT COUPLE DECADES
TO INTRODUCTORY WHERE IT COULD
ACHIEVE FULL FUNDING.
BY THE MID TWENTY FORTY IS --
TURNING TO PAGE THREE AS YOU.
I HEARD OF THE THE PLAN REALLY
IS.
A THIRTY YEAR PLAN AND SO
PERHAPS NOT SURPRISINGLY BEING
ONLY FIVE YEARS INTO IT.
THE UNFUNDED LIABILITY TODAY IS
IT IS STILL LARGE IT'S OVER A
HUNDRED BILLION --
AT AS OF THIS POINT THE PLANET
SO SIX ABOUT ONE THIRD TO THE
STATE THE SIX CHAIRS AND KIND OF
FLUCTUATE OVER TIME --
BUT IT'S STILL YOU KNOW IT'S
STILL A PRETTY SIGNIFICANT
CHALLENGE --
I THINK THE ADMINISTRATION
BETWEEN THE PAGE FOR GIVE YOU A
GOOD OVERVIEW OF THE CURRENT.
WHAT'S HAPPENING WITH RATES AND
COSTS LATELY I DISTRICT COST
SINCE THE INCEPTION OF THE PLAN
HAVE GROWN A LITTLE OVER THREE
BILLION DOLLARS FROM TWO
THOUSAND THIRTEEN FOURTEEN
THROUGH.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN NINETEEN THE
ADMINISTRATION ESTIMATES THE
ADDITIONAL INCREASE OVER THE
NEXT TWO YEARS WILL BE ABOUT ONE
POINT FOUR BILLION --
THAT'S FAIRLY CLOSE TO OUR OWN
ESTIMATES OF HOW MUCH DISTRICT
COSTS WOULD INCREASE --
ONE SORT OF AN IMPORTANT POINT I
MEANT MIGHT MENTION IS THAT EVEN
THOUGH ALL EMPLOYERS ARE PAYING
THE SAME RATE THE COST TO VARY A
LITTLE BIT AROUND THE STATE FROM
DISTRICT TO DISTRICT.
BECAUSE DISTRICTS MAKE DIFFERENT
DECISIONS ABOUT THE LOCAL PAPER
ALL.
DISTRICTS SOME DISTRICTS HAVE
BEEN GRANTING LARGER OR SMALLER
SALARY INCREASES SOME OF AN
INCREASING SALARY MORE OR LESS
THAN OTHER DISTRICTS.
AND SO THOSE DISTRICTS THAT HAVE
HAD THEIR PAYROLL GROW MORE
QUICKLY HAVE ALSO SEEN A PENSION
COSTS GO MORE QUICKLY.
I'M PAGE FIVE I THINK THE
ADMINISTRATION I GIVE YOU A GOOD
OVERVIEW OF THE PROPOSAL.
I THINK.
ONE POINT WE MIGHT EMPHASIZES
THAT ALTHOUGH.
THE TWO PROPOSALS ARE VERY EASY
TO LUMP TOGETHER THE OBJECTIVES
FOR EACH REALLY.
QUITE DIFFERENT THE SEVEN
HUNDRED MILLION REALLY IS ALL
ABOUT DISTRICT BUDGET RELIEF --
KIND OF BY DESIGN IT'S NOT
INTENDED AND IF MAKE MORE OR
LESS PROGRESS TOWARDS A PAYING
DOWN THE UNFUNDED LIABILITY.
OF THE TWO POINT THREE BILLION
THOUGH THAT REALLY IS ABOUT THE
UNFUNDED LIABILITY.
IT LETS THE STATE TAKE ANOTHER
STEP TOWARDS FULL FUNDING OF THE
PLAN.
AND IT DOES HAVE THE POTENTIAL
TO REDUCE RATES DISTRICT RATES
STARTING IN.
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO BUT THE
LIGHT THE LIGHT MOST OF THOSE
SAVINGS ARE REALLY IN THE LONG
TERM IT'S NOT REALLY ABOUT SORT
OF IMMEDIATE.
BUDGET RELIEF UNLIKE THE SEVEN
HUNDRED MILLION.
SO TURNING TO PAGE SIX I THINK
ONE OF THE REASONS THAT
CHARACTERS HAS BEEN THIS SORT OF
DIFFICULT CONVERSATION FOR YOU
THE PAST COUPLE YEARS.
THAT THE DISTRICT RATE IS
ALREADY OUT ABOUT 16% THAT'S
MORE THAN DOUBLE WHERE IT WAS
BEFORE THE START OF THE
HEALTHCARE SPENDING PLAN.
THAT BUT DESPITE THAT INCREASE --
THE DISTRICT RATE STILL.
ISN'T HIGH ENOUGH AT THIS POINT
TO ACHIEVE THE FULL FUNDING
OBJECTIVES THAT YOU SET FORTH
THE SPENDING PLAN.
AND SO I THINK THE QUESTION THAT
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL PUTS
BEFORE YOU ISN'T SO MUCH ABOUT
WHETHER THE DISTRICT GREAT --
SHOULD GO UP OR NOT BUT WINDOW
WHAT THE TIMING OF THAT INCREASE
SHOULD BE AND WHEN THOSE
INCREASES SHOULD OCCUR.
DISTRICTS ARE LIKELY TO SEE RATE
INCREASES AS CHALLENGING IN
VIRTUALLY ANY FISCAL ENVIRONMENT
WE CAN IMAGINE.
BUT AS YOU THINK ABOUT THAT
QUESTION THE STATE RIGHT NOW IS
IN THE MIDST OF A OF A VERY
STRONG ECONOMIC TIES IN THIS
SCHOOL FUNDING HAS GROWN TWENTY
TWO BILLION THE PAST --
SIX YEAR IS THE GOVERNMENT'S
PROPOSED ANOTHER TWO POINT NINE
BILLION INCREASE FOR K. TWELVE
EDUCATION ON A PER PUPIL BASIS
FUNDING IS AT AN ALL TIME HIGH.
AND SO AN ALTERNATIVE WE WANT TO
SKETCH OUT IS TO SET ASIDE THAT
SEVEN HUNDRED MILLION NOW FOR
RELIEF BUT NOT IMMEDIATELY USE
THAT TO LOWER DISTRICT
CONTRIBUTION RATES.
OF THE STATE WOULD INSTEAD LEAVE
THE RATES --
AS INCREASES THAT ARE SCHEDULED
TO OCCUR NOW --
BUT USE THAT --
SORT OF SATISFIED THAT SEVEN
HUNDRED MILLION.
FOR RELIEF DURING THE NEXT
DOWNTURN TO THE NEXT RECESSION.
AND THAT MIGHT HELP DISTRICTS
AVOID THE REALLY TO STRING AN
EXTRA NEXT DURING THE NEXT
RECESSION WHEN THEY MIGHT BE
FACING THE PROSPECT OF FLAT TO
MAYBE DECLINING FUNDING AT THE
SAME TIME THAT COULD BE PRESSURE
FOR THE RATES TO CONTINUE
INCREASING.
THIS ALTERNATIVE WOULD HELP KIND
OF MITIGATE THAT THAT REALLY
DIFFICULT COMBINATION.
THAT'S A FINALLY TRAINING TO BE
A RESERVE JUST FOR POP WENT LIKE
PROBABLY NEED RESERVE.
THAT'S A GOOD QUESTION AND YOU
HAD VARIOUS WAYS YOU COULD
STRUCTURE IT YOU COULD JUST PUT
IT ASIDE AND JUST A RESERVE.
FOR I'M GONNA FUTURE PENSION
COSTS THAT WOULD BE KIND OF WITH.
IN A SIMILAR TO SOME OF THE
OTHER RESERVE SIR YOU CREATED A
YOU COULD ALSO EXPLORE --
PERHAPS GIVING.
THE MONEY TO CAL STAR IS AND
LETTING THEM INVESTED IN SOME
WAY BUT DIRECTING THEM NOT TO
IMMEDIATELY REDUCED RATES BUT TO
REDUCE RATES AT SOME POINT IN
THE FUTURE.
IT'S KIND OF DIFFERENT WAYS TO
STRUCTURE AT AND WE CAN IF
YOU'RE INTERESTED IN THAT OPTION
WE CAN HELP YOU THINK THROUGH.
A THE BEST WAY TO DO THAT.
SO TURNING TO THE TWO POINT
THREE BILLION --
YOU'VE HEARD A LOT ABOUT --
DEBTS AND LIABILITIES AND
HEARINGS ALREADY THIS YEAR AND
WE'VE WRITTEN A WHOLE REPORT
ABOUT THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL SO
I WON'T BELABOR OUR ASSESSMENT
OF IT.
BUT JUST IN BRIEF WE THINK THE
STATE DOES HAVE A BIGGER IN SUCH
A LARGE SURPLUS.
AND TAKING ADVANTAGE OF THAT
OPPORTUNITY TO PAY DOWN
LIABILITIES SEEMS PRUDENT TO US.
AT FIFTY SAVINGS I SIGNIFICANT
WITH THOSE ADDITIONAL PAYMENTS
THAT YOU MAKE TODAY.
UP FOR THE SPECIFIC DOLLAR
AMOUNT THE TWO POINT THREE
BILLION ON BEHALF OF DISTRICTS I
THINK YOUR DECISION ABOUT THAT
WERE REALLY DEPEND ON KIND OF
YOUR WILLINGNESS TO TAKE ON SOME
ADDITIONAL SHARE OF DISTRICT
LIABILITIES.
WHEN THE STATE CONTINUES TO HAVE
SOME OF ITS OWN LARGE UNFUNDED
LIABILITY IS?
BY THE STATE THAT HAS ALREADY
TAKEN ON A PRETTY LARGE SHARE OF
THE UNFUNDED LIABILITY AND CAL
STAR IS --
THIS PROPOSAL BEFORE YOUR FROM
THAT THE GOVERNOR WOULD HAVE A
TAKE ON A BIT MORE.
AND SO THAT'S JUST KIND OF
SOMETHING YOU HAVE TO THINK
ABOUT IN THE CONTEXT OF ALL OF
THE OTHER DEBTS AND LIABILITIES
THAT YOU'VE HEARD ABOUT.
AFTER THE STATE --
AND ITS OWN EMPLOYEES.
SO WITH THAT I'D BE HAPPY TO
TAKE ANY QUESTIONS.
I DON'T HAVE ANY QUESTIONS AT
THAT ARE YES THE WHAT THE ONE
SPECIFIC QUESTION.
AND CUT A LONELY UP HERE TODAY
SO.
MAYES GOING FAST --
YEAH.
SO OF COURSE SCHOOL DISTRICTS
ARE STIRS AND AND PURRS AND SO I
ASSUME PER IS ARE THE CLASSIFIED.
STAFF AND SOME ADMIN.
AND SO WHAT WE THINK ABOUT THE
WITH THIS IS FOCUSED OF COURSE
ON STIRS AND WE DON'T TAKE A
LOOK AT THE PERS ISSUES FOR THE
DISTRICTS.
SURE SO YOU'RE YOU'RE RIGHT
ABOUT THE EMPLOYEE'S SO CAL
STIRS AS ADMINISTERING BENEFITS
FOR OUR TEACHER IS --
COMMUNITY COLLEGE FACULTY KIND
OF PEOPLE WHO HAVE A EMPLOYEES
RUSTIC CREDENTIALS CALPERS IS
ADMINISTERING BENEFITS FOR
EVERYONE ELSE.
BY THE STATE GONNA FOR
HISTORICAL REASONS HAS ALWAYS
HAD A LITTLE BIT OF A TATER
RELATIONSHIP WITH CHARACTERS.
IT'S KIND OF UNIQUE IN ITS THAT
I THINK THE ONLY PENSION SYSTEM
WE CAN THINK OF WHERE THE STATE
IS MAKING A REALLY LARGE
CONTRIBUTION.
ON BEHALF OF LOCAL EMPLOYEES IT
DOESN'T HAVE THAT RELATIONSHIP
WITH -- SAY
CITIES ARE COUNTY IS OR EVEN --
CALPERS --
SCHOOL PAUL THAT SERVE SCHOOLS
AND COMMITTEE CALL A PROPOSAL WE
ANALYZED --
AS FAR AS HOW THE STATE MIGHT
MAKE IT AN ADDITIONAL PAYMENTS --
YOU KNOW IF THAT'S SOMETHING
YOU'RE INTERESTED WE COULD.
CERTAINLY TAKE THAT BACK AND
THINK ABOUT IT BUT NOW AT THIS
POINT THERE JUST WASN'T THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL ON CALPERS I
GUESS THE QUESTION WAS SOMEWHAT
DIRECTED TO THE ADMINISTRATION --
AS YOU SEE ME IN THE AGENDA.
WHAT WAS THAT THOUGHT PROCESS OF
NOT DOING THIS? FOR CALPERS
RIGHT.
I THINK WHEN IT COMES TO THE
THOUGHT PROCESS THE INTENT
BEHIND THE PROPOSAL --
AS I MENTIONED AS THE LA --
POINT OUT REALLY WAS IN THE
SHORT TERM WE WANTED TO BE ABLE
TO PROVIDE SOME IMMEDIATE RELIEF
SOME IMMEDIATE RATE RELIEF AS
UNDER THE COUNTER SPENDING PLAN
RATES OF SEE IT JUST LOOKING AT
THE AT THE PLAN.
COM AND WE WANT TO BE ABLE TO
WRITE SOME SHORT TERM RELIEF
WHILE ALSO BEING ABLE TO
PRIORITIZE SOME LONG TERM
SAVINGS AS SOON AS POSSIBLE FOR
THEM BY PARTISAN THAT REMAINING
TWO POINT THREE BILLION.
I WOULD ALSO POINT OUT THAT THE
CAL STAR SIDE IT'S JUST SO MUCH
LARGER THE UNFUNDED LIABILITIES
ON THE CAL STAR SIDE IS
ESTIMATED AS OF EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN IF I RECALL CORRECTLY
TO BE.
A JUST OVER SEVENTY ONE BILLION
DOLLARS WHILE THE CALPERS SITE
IS -- JUST
ABOUT TWENTY THREE AND A HALF
BILLION SO THERE'S THAT
DISPARITY THAT THE CONCERT'S
PEACHES MAKES UP SUCH A LARGE
SHARE -- AND
I THINK MY COLLEAGUE FROM
CUSTER'S COULD PROBABLY HELP ME
OUT A LITTLE BIT MORE WHEN IT
COMES TO THE DIFFERENCES ON THE
RATES AS WELL THAT SCHOOLS ARE
PAYING -- ON
CAL STIRS VERSUS CALPERS AND HOW
THOSE ARE SET IT CETERA --
AND SO WE JUST FELT WITH ALL OF
THAT --
CONTACTS THAT WE COULD KIND OF
GET THE BEST RETURN ON OUR
INVESTMENT IN THE SHORT AND LONG
TERM MAKING THIS PAYMENT ON THE
CAL STAR SIDE WITHIN.
THE REVENUES THAT WE HAD
AVAILABLE [inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
CASTERS.
YEAH.
YEAH BASICALLY IF THIS FOR
THIRTY I WOULD JUST LIKE TO SET.
UP FIRST MY NAME IS DAVID HAMMER
FROM CAL STAR IS A DEPUTY SYSTEM
ACT REFERS THAT JUST TO GO BACK
ON THE FUNDING PLAN --
JUST WANT TO RESTATE THAT THE NO
DEFINING PLAN WAS KEY TO TELL
STORIES WITH WAS PASSED IN.
TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN INSTEAD OF
BEING PROJECTED OF RUN OUT OF
RUNNING OUT OF ASSETS BY TWO
THOUSAND FORTY SIX ONE NOW
PROJECTED TO BE FOR FUNDING. FOR
FULLY FUNDED BY TWO THOUSAND AND
THIS PROPOSAL TO PROVIDE THE
SOME RATE RELIEF TO EMPLOYERS
AND TO ALSO --
PAID DOWN A PORTION OF THE
EMPLOYER SHARE OF THE UNFUNDED
LIABILITY AS A REPRESENTATIVE OF
FINANCE MENTION.
THE EMPLOYER SHARE OF THE
UNFUNDED LIABILITY IS ESTIMATED
TO BE ABOUT SEVENTY ONE BILLION
DOLLAR.
SAID THE PROPOSED TWO POINT
THREE BILLION DOLLAR WOULD LOWER
IT'S ABOUT SIXTY NINE BILLION
DOLLAR.
AND OUR ESTIMATES ALSO ARE
CONSISTENT WITH THE ONES
PROVIDED BY DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE THAT WE BELIEVE THAT THE
WE ESTIMATE THAT THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL WAS GOING TO SAVE THE
EMPLOYERS.
CLOSE TO SEVEN BILLION DOLLAR
BETWEEN NOW AND TWO THOUSAND AND
FORTY SIX FOR WE FULLY SUPPORT
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL IT WOULD
NOT ONLY PROVIDER RATE RELIEF
BUT FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE IT WILL
MAKE OUR BENEFIT MORE SECURE.
IMPROVE A FUNDING LEVELS AND
REDUCE THE SIZE OF OUR UNFUNDED
LIABILITY.
OKAY THANK YOU.
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS ON THIS ITEM
IS FOR THEM.
MR OKAY THANK YOU.
AGAIN THIS IS AN INFORMATIONAL
ITEM NO ACTION TAKEN TODAY ISSUE
NUMBER THREE ACCOUNTABILITY
UPDATE STATEWIDE SYSTEM OF
SUPPORT
.
PLEASE BEGIN.
GOOD MORNING SERRA CORTEZ AT THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE WE
WERE ASKED TO PROVIDE AN
OVERVIEW OF THE STATE'S
ACCOUNTABILITY SYSTEM INCLUDING
A BRIEF DESCRIPTION OF THE ROLES
OF THE ACTORS IN THE STATE
SYSTEM.
I'LL BE SPEAKING FROM A HANDOUT
THAT'S WAS DISTRIBUTED TO YOU.
SO TO START ON PAGE ONE OF THE
HAND OUT THE CHANGE IN THE
ACCOUNTABILITY SYSTEM BEGAN IN
TWENTY THIRTEEN AS PART OF THE
ADOPTION OF THE LOCAL CONTROL
FUNDING FORMULA LCF BACK.
ATTACHED TO THE LEGISLATION THAT
CREATED LCF WAS A NEW
ACCOUNTABILITY FRAMEWORK THAT'S
BEEN ROLLED OUT OVER THE LAST
SEVERAL YEARS.
AS PART OF THE NEW FRAMEWORK THE
STATE ADOPTED EIGHT STATE
PRIORITIES.
I ALREADY AREAS AND THE STATE
PRIORITY AREAS ARE LISTED IN THE
FIRST BULLET HERE OF THIS
HANDOUT.
AND THESE ARE THE STATUTORILY
DEFINED AREA THE SPECIFIED THE
KEY THINGS THE STATE THINGS ARE
THE MOST IMPORTANT FOR DISTRICTS
AND SCHOOLS TO FOCUS ON AND EACH
PRIORITY PRIORITY AREA IS A LINK
TO A STATUTORILY DEFINED
PERFORMANCE MEASURE.
THAT DETERMINES HOW WELL SCHOOLS
ARE DOING SO PUT IN PLACE LOCAL
CONTROL ACCOUNTABILITY PLANS
WERE DISTRICTS DEVELOP A PLAN
WITH GOALS AND ACTION ON HOW
THEY PLAN TO IMPROVE IN THE
EIGHT STATE PRIORITY AREAS.
AND DISTRICTS HAVE TO GO AND GET
FEEDBACK FROM THEIR COMMUNITIES
AND THEN THE ULTIMATELY HAVE TO
GET THEIR EL CAPS APPROVED BY
COUNTY OFFICES OF EDUCATION.
SO NOW PRIORITY AREAS
PERFORMANCE MEASURES AND EL CAP
THEY ALL WORK TOGETHER --
FOR EXAMPLE FOR A DISTRICT TO
DEVELOP AN L. COP THEY HAVE TO
HAVE A GOAL THAT FOCUSES ON A
PRIORITY AREAS SO LET'S SAY
STUDENT ENGAGEMENT. ONE OF THE
PERFORMANCE AREAS FOR STUDENT
ENGAGEMENT IS GRADUATION RATES.
SO DISTRICT WILL HAVE A GOAL
THAT DETAILS THE STEPS THEY WILL
TAKE ON HOW THEY WANT PROOF
THEIR GRADUATION RATES IN THE EL
CAP.
SO MOVING ON TO PAGE TWO OF THE
HAND OUT WE DISCUSS THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL DASHBOARD.
THE STATE ASSESSES DISTRICT
PERFORMANCE THROUGH STATUTORILY
DEFINED MEASURES AND THOSE
RESULTS ARE DISPLAYED ON THE
DASHBOARD A PUBLICLY AVAILABLE
WEBSITE.
USING THE RESULTS OF THE
DASHBOARD THE STATE IDENTIFIES
DISTRICTS THAT NEED ASSISTANCE.
THE STATE LOOKS AT EVERY STUDENT
GROUP PERFORMANCE FOR EVERY
PRIORITY AREA.
AND IF THE DISTRICT HAS THE
STUDENTS SUB GROUP IN THE LOWEST
PERFORMANCE CATEGORY FOR TWO OR
MORE PRIORITY AREAS THERE
IDENTIFIED AS NEEDING SUPPORT.
IN THE FALL THE STATE IDENTIFIED
THREE HUNDRED AND FORTY THREE
DISTRICTS AND THIRTY ONE COUNTY
OFFICES OF EDUCATION AS NEEDING
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT. 65% OF THE A
DEN OF AS THOSE IDENTIFIED AS
NEEDING SUPPORT WERE BECAUSE OF
PERFORMANCE ISSUES WITH THEIR
STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES.
AND THIS IS THE SECOND YEAR THAT
THE STATE HAS IDENTIFIED
DISTRICT THAT NEED ADDITIONAL
SUPPORT.
IN THIS FUTURE THE STATE WILL
IDENTIFY --
DISTRICTS THAT NEED EVEN MEET AT
EVEN GREATER LEVEL SUPPORT BUT
THAT BUT THAT LEVEL OF SUPPORT
IS FORTHCOMING.
SO -- ON
PAGE THREE I'LL DISCUSS THE
ENTITIES INTENDED TO SUPPORT
THESE -- DID
A SUPPORT DISTRICTS IDENTIFIED.
THE EIGHTEEN NINETEEN BUDGET ACT
FUNDED ENTITIES --
THAT WOULD HAVE A ROLE IN THE
SYSTEM.
PLEASE ENTITIES INCLUDE COUNTY
OFFICES OF EDUCATION WHO SUPPORT
DISTRICTS DIRECTLY.
THE COUNTY OFFICES COULD ALSO
HELP THE THE DISTRICTS FIND A
TEAM OF EXPERTS TO SUPPORT UP TO
PROVIDE SUPPORT.
ON THE DISTRICTS COULD ALSO OPT
OUT OF THEIR SUPPORT --
BY FINDING THEIR OWN.
THERE'S ALSO LEAD AGENCIES THESE
ARE COUNTY OFFICES OF EDUCATION
AND SPECIAL EDUCATION LOCAL PLAN
AREAS --
CALLED SELFIES --
THAT SUPPORT COUNTY OFFICES
DISTRICTS OR SELF IS ALSO
SUPPORT OTHER CELL BUT AS I'M
YOU MAY HEAR THESE LEADS REFER
TO AS GEOGRAPHICALLY THEIR CELL
BELIEVES.
AND THERE'S OTHER LEADS BUT
THESE ARE THE MAIN ONES THAT
HAVE READ OF THAT HAVE ONGOING
FUNDING --
AND THEN THERE'S THE COOK THE
CALIFORNIA COLLABORATIVE FOR
EDUCATIONAL EXCELLENCE A
STATEWIDE AGENCY THAT WAS
ESTABLISHED IN.
TWENTY THIRTEEN FOURTEEN THE C.
C. E. HELP COORDINATE SUPPORT
AMONG LEADING AGENCIES AND MAY
ALSO DIRECTLY SUPPORT DISTRICTS.
ON PAGE FOUR OF YOUR HAND OUT
I'M DESCRIBES THEFUNDING FOR
DISTRICTS SUPPORT AND THIS IS
THE MAJOR ONGOING FUNDING
PROVIDED FOR THESE ENTITIES.
SO COUNTY OFFICES OF EDUCATION
ARE PROVIDED IN THE NINETEEN
TWENTY GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED
BUDGET ARE PROVIDED FOUR HUNDRED
AND EIGHTY NINE MILLION THROUGH
THE COUNTY LOOK --
COUNTY OFFICE WELL THE CONTROL
FUNDING SUPPORT ALL DISTRICTS
NOT JUST THOSE THAT ARE
IDENTIFIED.
AND THEN THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
ALSO INCLUDES SEVENTY FIVE
MILLION FOR COUNTY OFFICES OF
EDUCATION TO SUPPORT IDENTIFIED
DISTRICTS.
AND THEN THIS IS BASED ON THE
NUMBER OF IDENTIFIED DISTRICTS
AND THE SIZE OF THOSE DISTRICTS --
THERE WAS A TWENTY MILLION
DOLLAR INCREASE OVER THE AN
INCREASE FROM THE EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN BUDGET ACT AND THAT'S
BECAUSE THE NUMBER OF IDENTIFIED
DISTRICTS HAS INCREASED.
LEAD AGENCIES ARE ALSO PROVIDED
SOME ONGOING FUNDING THE CELL
BELIEVE AGENCIES ARE PROVIDED --
TEN MILLION DOLLARS AND THE
COUNTY OFFICE REGIONAL THE
GEOGRAPHICALLY IT'S ARE PROVIDED
FOUR MILLION DOLLARS.
AND THE COLLABORATIVE --
C. C. E. IS PROVIDED UP TWELVE
MILLION DOLLARS.
THIS IS THE SYSTEM AS IT RELATES
TO PROVIDING DISTRICT SUPPORT IN
YOUR AGENDA YOU'LL ALSO SEE THAT
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT REQUIRES.
THE STATE TO ALSO IDENTIFY IN
SUPPORT SCHOOLS ON THIS IS THE
FIRST YEAR THAT SCHOOLS ARE
IDENTIFIED IN THE PANEL WILL
PROVIDE AN UPDATE ON THE STATE'S
PROGRESS.
AND THIS CONCLUDES MY PREPARED
REMARKS I'M HAPPY TO TAKE
QUESTIONS.
LARA FINANCES NEXT LEVEL
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
DAN HAD OR DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE --
THE ADMINISTRATION RECOGNIZES
THE INCREASE WILL ACCOUNTABILITY
AND CALIFORNIA EDUCATION.
WITH THE BUDGET FLEXIBILITY THAT
LOCAL EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES HAVE
UNDER THE NOW FULLY IMPLEMENTED
LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA --
TO THAT AND THE TWENTY NINETEEN
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET AND THE
COMPANY INTEREST.
TRAILER BILL.
CONTAINS SEVERAL PROPOSALS TO
HELP STRENGTHEN THE STATE
STATEWIDE SYSTEM OF SUPPORT.
IMPROVE TRANSPARENCY AND HELP
IMPROVE OUTCOMES FOR ALL
STUDENTS.
THE FIRST IS THREE HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS ONE TIME
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT GENERAL
FUND TO SUPPORT THE ALIGNMENT
AND INTEGRATION OF ONLINE
PLATFORMS SUPPORTING THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL DASHBOARD.
THE LOCAL CONTROL ACCOUNTABILITY
PLAN ELECTRONIC TEMPLATE SYSTEM
AND THE SCHOOL ACCOUNTABILITY
REPORT CARDS.
SOMEONE TO PASS PROPOSALS THIS
FUNDING WILL BE PROVIDED TO THE
SAN JOAQUIN COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION.
WHO IS THE CONTRACTOR FOR ALL
THREE SYSTEMS?
INTEGRATING THE SYSTEMS INTO A
SINGLE WEB BASED APPLICATION%
WILL HELP TO INCREASE ENGAGEMENT
BETWEEN COMMUNITIES AND ELLIE IS.
BY ALLOWING THE PUBLIC TO ACCESS
A SINGLE PLATFORM FOR THIS
INFORMATION STREAMLINING THE
SYSTEMS AND ELIMINATING
DUPLICATIVE AN OUTDATED
INFORMATION.
THE BUDGET ALSO INCLUDES TWO
HUNDRED SEVENTY ONE THOUSAND
DOLLARS NON PRPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT GENERAL FUND TO MAKE
PERMANENT TO POSITIONS AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION.
THAT WAS SUPPORT THE ONGOING
IMPLEMENTATION AND MAINTENANCE
OF THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
DASHBOARD TO MEET STATE AND
FEDERAL ACCOUNTABILITY
REQUIREMENTS.
ADDITIONALLY THE ADMINISTRATION
RECOGNIZES THE SIGNIFICANT ROLE.
THAT THE CALIFORNIA
COLLABORATIVE FOR EDUCATIONAL
EXCELLENCE AND COUNTY OFFICES OF
EDUCATION PLAY WITHIN THE
STATEWIDE SYSTEM OF SUPPORT.
IN ORDER TO ALIGN WITH THE
EXPECTED WORKLOAD OF THE
COLLABORATIVE AND FOR THE
SUPPORT ITS MISSION OF PROVIDING
SUPPORT TO ELEAZAR.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSES
INCREASING FUNDING FOR THE
CALIFORNIA COLLABORATIVE OF
EDUCATIONAL.
FOR HAVE FOR EDUCATIONAL
EXCELLENCE BY TWO HUNDRED AND
THIRTY TWO THOUSAND DOLLARS
PROPOSITION NINETY GENERAL FUND.
THIS --
BRINGING ITS TOTAL ON GOING
ALLOCATION TO ELEVEN POINT EIGHT
MILLION DOLLARS.
THE BUDGET ALSO INCLUDES TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE TASK IN THE
COLLABORATIVE BUT THE ROLE OF
FACILITATING THE COORDINATION OF
ACTIVITIES.
BEING UNDERTAKEN BY VARIOUS
ENTITIES THE ONE SYSTEM SUPPORT.
THE BUDGET ALSO INCLUDES AN
ADDITIONAL TWENTY POINT TWO
MILLION DOLLARS FOR COUNTY
OFFICE OF EDUCATION SUPPORT
DISTRICTS. FOR ELIGIBLE FOR
DIFFERENT AGE ASSISTANCE FOR A
TOTAL OF SEVENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS AND TWENTY NINETEEN
TWENTY THIS IS AN INCREASE FROM
THE SIXTY SIX POINT FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS PROVIDE IN THE CURRENT
YEAR. FOR COUNTY OFFICES OF
EDUCATION TO PROVIDE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TO LOCAL EDUCATIONAL
AGENCIES TO IMPROVE STUDENT
OUTCOMES.
ADDITIONALLY THE BUDGET INCLUDES
APPROXIMATELY A HUNDRED AND
THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS IN
FEDERAL FUNDING. FOR SCHOOLS
IDENTIFIED FOR COMPREHENSIVE
SUPPORT IMPROVEMENT UNDER THE
EVERY STUDENT SUCCEEDS ACT.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT THIS
AMOUNT WILL LIKELY CHANGE DURING
THE SPRING PROCESS TO REFLECT
UPDATED FEDERAL GRANT
INFORMATION.
FINALLY THE BUDGET INCLUDES
SEVERAL TRAILER BILL PROPOSALS
AIMED AT PROVIDING MORE PARITY.
BETWEEN THE EL CAP DEVELOPMENT
PROCESS FOR SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND
CHARTER SCHOOLS.
SPECIFICALLY THE LANGUAGE
SPECIFIES THAT THE CHARTERS THAT
CHARTER SCHOOL SHOULD BE
ADDRESSING STATE PARTIES TO
THEIR AID AND THEY'RE ALL CAPS.
ADOPTING THEIR L. CAPS AT A
PUBLIC HEARING.
PROMINENTLY POSTING THEIR L.
CAPS ON THEIR WEBSITES.
AND TRANSLATING REPORTS AND
NOTICES IF 15% OR MORE OF THEIR
STUDENTS --
IN ROAD SPEAK A PRIMARY LANGUAGE
OTHER THAN ENGLISH.
THESE CHANGES ARE CONSISTENT
WITH RATHER THE REQUIREMENTS
PLACED ON TRADITIONAL PUBLIC
SCHOOLS AND WILL BRING MORE
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
TO CHARGE COOPERATIONS.
WITH THAT I WOULD BE HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU I BELIEVE WE WILL HEAR
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION.
YES GOOD MORNING I'M SAN BECAUSE
HONEST WITH THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION I'M
GOING TO SPEAK TO YOU ABOUT THAT
DESPERATE REDESIGN.
AND THEN GO INTO THE ELIGIBILITY
FOR DISTRICTS AND FOR OUR
SCHOOLS UNDER OUR STATE AND
FEDERAL ACCOUNTABILITY SYSTEMS --
SO I AM HERE REPRESENTING OF
COURSE --
OUR NEW SUPERINTENDENT WHO HAS
BEEN A STRONG SUPPORTER OF THE
DASHBOARD AND WE DID PASS OUT
BUT I WANTED HAND OUT OF WHAT IS
NEW ON THE DASHBOARD.
AND WITH THE ADDITIONAL FUNDING
THAT THIS BODY APPROVED IN THE
GOVERNOR SIGNED INTO LAW LAST
YEAR THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION WAS ABLE TO WITH
ITS CONTRACTORS SAN JOAQUIN
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION.
REDESIGNED CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
DASHBOARD THIS PAST FALL FIRM
WHO SPECIALIZES IN DATA
VISUALIZATION.
AND INPUT FROM NUMEROUS
STAKEHOLDERS TO INFORM THE
CURRENT DESIGN WHICH IS
FRIENDLIER SIMPLER SIMPLER TO
USE AND EASIER TO UNDERSTAND.
THE DASHBOARD IS NOW FULLY
TRANSLATED INTO SPANISH
AMERICA'S FOREIGN THE COST OF TO
ADD UP TO THREE MORE LANGUAGES
IN FUTURE RELEASES.
THE DASHBOARD ALSO NOW OFFERS A
COMPARISON FEATURE AT THE
INDICATOR AND STUDENT GROUP
LEVEL.
OF HOUSE SCORE DISTRICTS
PERFORMANCE IS COMPARED WITH THE
STATE LEVEL.
IN ADDITION WITH 80% FEWER PAGES
WERE ABLE TO KEEP USERS ENGAGED
IN THE SITE.
THE DASHBOARD PROVIDES PARENTS
EDUCATORS OF MEANINGFUL
INFORMATION ON SCHOOL DISTRICT
PROGRESS SO THEY CAN PARTICIPATE
IN DECISIONS TO IMPROVE STUDENT
LEARNING.
THE DASHBOARD IS USED TO HELP
DISTRICTS IN SCHOOL IDENTIFY
STRENGTHS AND WEAKNESSES AND
PINPOINT STUDENT GROUPS MAY BE
STRUGGLING. TO DISPLAY SUCH AS
THE EQUITY REPORT.
ADDITIONALLY WEB TRAFFIC
STATISTICS SHOW THAT THE
REDESIGNED DASHBOARD IS BEING
WIDELY USED AND THE FIRST TWO
MONTHS OF TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
ALONE THERE ARE APPROXIMATELY.
400-250-00400 AND TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND PAGES WITH ONE HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND UNIQUE VISITORS
ON THE SITE. TO SUPPORT THE
RELEASE THE REDESIGNED DASHBOARD
THE CVT ALSO DEVELOPED
ADDITIONAL REPORTS THAT ARE
FREQUENTLY USED BY EDUCATORS
REVIEWING THEIR ALL CAPS WHICH
SHOWS STUDENT GROUP RESULTS ON
HOW SCHOOLS AND DISTRICTS ARE
DOING.
BASED ON EACH INDICATORS FIVE BY
FIVE PLACEMENT OR COLOR GREAT.
FROM OCTOBER THROUGH FEBRUARY
THE DEPARTMENT CONDUCTED
NUMEROUS WEBINARS AND IN PERSON
PRESENTATIONS WITH OVER SIX
THOUSAND INDIVIDUALS ON THE NEW
DESIGN WE ALSO PARTNER WITH THE
CITY FOUNDATION TO PRODUCE NEW
VIDEOS TO DEMONSTRATE THE USE OF
THE SITE MY IT'S IMPORTANT FOR
PARENTS TO UNDERSTAND.
IN ADDITION A WITH THE
COLLABORATION THE CCC WE DID A
ONE A ONE ON THE DASHBOARD WHICH
WAS ALSO WELL ATTENDED.
WITH THAT I WAS GOING TO TURN
OVER TO DISTRICTS THAT HAVE BEEN
IDENTIFIED FOR DIFFERENT CHEATED
ASSISTANCE.
SO BASED ON THE PERFORMANCE OF
THE STATE AND LOCAL MEASURES ON
THE DASHBOARD THREE HUNDRED
EIGHTY SEVEN DISTRICTS WERE
ELIGIBLE FOR SUPPORT TO IMPROVE
STUDENT OUTCOMES BASED ON THE
STATE ACCOUNTABILITY SYSTEM.
THIS INCLUDES ELEVEN DISTRICTS
BASED ON LOCAL INDICATORS AND TO
BASED ON A COMBINATION OF STATE
AND LOCAL INDICATORS.
WITH THE ADDITION OF COUNTY
OFFICE OF EDUCATION ON THE DASH
FOR THIS YEAR WE SEE THAT FIFTY
TWO OF THE FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES
HAVE AT LEAST ONE DISTRICT
IDENTIFIED.
AND FINALLY.
WITH THREE STUDENT GROUPS THE
THREESOME GROUPS IN THE GREATEST
NEED OF SUPPORT CONTINUE TO BE
LED BY OF COURSE STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES.
HOMELESS AND OUR FOSTER YOU
STUDENT GROUPS.
AND FINALLY I'LL CONCLUDE WITH
SCHOOLS THAT IDENTIFIED UNDER
THE EVERY STUDENT SUCCEEDS ACT.
SO UNDER THE EVERY STUDENT
SUCCEEDS ACT --
THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION IS
REQUIRED TO DETERMINE SCHOOL
ABILITY FOR COMPREHENSIVE
ACRONYM IS C. S. I..
BASED ON THE CRITERIA IN
CALIFORNIA'S EVERY STUDENT
SUCCEEDS ACT STATE PLAN.
SUCH IDENTIFICATION MUST OCCUR
AT LEAST ONCE EVERY THREE YEARS
AND INCLUDE AT LEAST OF THE
LOWEST --
MUST INCLUDE AT LEAST THE LOWEST
PERFORMING 5% OF ALL SCHOOLS
RECEIVING TITLE ONE FUNDS.
IN ADDITION ANY PUBLIC HIGH
SCHOOL HAS GRADUATION RATE HAS
FALLEN BELOW 67% FOR THREE
CONSECUTIVE YEARS WILL BE
AUTOMATICALLY ELIGIBLE FOR THE
COMPREHENSIVE --
SCRIPT SUPPORT AN IMPROVEMENT
REGARDLESS OF ITS TITLE ONE
STATUS.
BASED ON THE DASHBOARD THREE
HUNDRED SCHOOLS RIGHT IN A FIGHT
BASED ON THE GRADUATION RATE.
OF THESE SCHOOLS 82% RESIDE IN
ELEAZAR ELIGIBLE UNDER THE STATE
ACCOUNTABILITY SYSTEMS THERE
DISTRICT HAS BEEN IDENTIFIED
ALREADY FOR DIFFERENTIATED
ASSISTANCE.
ADDITIONAL FOUR HUNDRED EIGHTY
ONE SCHOOLS ARE ELIGIBLE BASED
ON THE STATE INDICATOR IS OLD AT
THE ALL STUDENT LEVEL.
OF THE SCHOOLS 77% RESIDE IN
ELLIE IS CURRENTLY ELIGIBLE FOR
A DIFFERENTIATED ASSISTANCE
UNDER THE STATE'S ACCOUNTABILITY
SYSTEM.
THE EVERY STUDENT SUCCEEDS ACT
ALSO REQUIRES THAT STATES
DETERMINE WHICH SCHOOLS ARE
ELIGIBLE FOR A NEW AD AREA
CALLED TARGETED SUPPORT AN
IMPROVEMENT.
T. S. I..
BASED ON STUDENT PERFORMANCE
UNDER CALIFORNIA STATE PLANNED
FOR THE EVERY STUDENT SUCCEEDS
ACT SCHOOLS ARE NOT ELIGIBLE FOR
THE FOR THE PREVIOUS --
PART WHICH IS THE COMPREHENSIVE
SUPPORT IMPROVEMENTS WILL BE
ELIGIBLE FOR THIS NEW.
REGARDLESS OF THEIR FRIEND THEIR
TITLE ONE FUNNY STATUS IF THEY
HAVE ONE OR MORE STUDENT GROUPS
THAT FOR TWO COULD TO GO TO OUR
MARKETS ACTIVE YEARS MEET THE
CRITERIA APPLIED TO IDENTIFY THE
LOWEST PERFORMING 5% OF TITLE
ONE SCHOOLS.
I'D CALIFORNIA HAS USE THE
CRITERIA FOR THIS THIS NEW GROUP
YES I ENDS AND ADD IN AND THEN
THAT AND FOR ADDITIONAL TARGETS
SUPPORT.
AN IMPROVEMENT EIGHTY SI I IF
COMBINED THEM THE THE CRITERIA
SINCE THE THE SAME.
SO WE ARE --
WE HAVE IDENTIFIED IN.
200-018-19800 AND FORTY NINE
SCHOOLS THAT MEET THE
ELIGIBILITY CRITERIA FOR THIS
THIS NEW --
ATS SIDE OF THESE SCHOOLS AT
LEAST AT 8282% RESIDE AND
ELEAZAR ELIGIBLE UNDER THE
CURRENT --
DIFFERENTIATED ASSISTANCE BONTA
FOR THE STATE.
THIS DEPARTMENT.
IS IN THE PROCESS OF GETTING
FUNDING OUT FOR THE SCHOOLS THAT
ARE ELIGIBLE FOR THE
COMPREHENSIVE SUPPORT AN
IMPROVEMENT --
PART AND STUDENTS BUT SCHOOLS
ARE SCHOOLS INVESTORS WILL START
RECEIVING THAT MONEY SHORTLY.
WITH THAT I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK.
NEXT WE'LL HEAR FROM --
MR ARE YOU REALLY DON'T.
YES GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS TOM
MARMALADE ON THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
COLLABORATIVE FOR EDUCATIONAL
EXCELLENCE OF THE CCD.
WHEN I SPEAK TO FOUR ELEMENTS OF
OUR WORK THE FIRST IS IN REGARD
TO THE SYSTEM OF SUPPORTS ON
PAGE?
FOURTEEN OF YOUR PACKET OF
REFERENCES --
A DIAGRAM THAT WE HAVE USED TO
KIND OF HELP TO FIND HOW THE
SYSTEM WORKS AND IN PARTICULAR
YOU'LL NOTICE ON THE LEFT HAND
SIDE.
WORD SPEAKS THE CC IN THE CD AND
THEN ALSO WORKING WITH THE STATE
BOARD OF ED STAFF.
ON MAKING SURE THAT WE ARE
BRINGING THESE AGENCIES TOGETHER
WE HELPED IDENTIFIED. FOR
EXAMPLE THE CRITERIA CHOOSING
GEOGRAPHICALLY NEEDS AS WELL AS
A CELL BELIEVES WELLS A
COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT.
FOLKS TO AND SO OUR ROLE HAS
BEEN TO BE ABLE TO BRING THOSE
FOLKS TOGETHER TO FIGURE OUT HOW
THAT THEY'RE GOING TO BE ABLE TO
OFFER SUPPORT. TO OTHER COUNTY
OFFICES WITHIN THEIR EDUCATIONAL
BOUNDARIES AND AND THE
BOUNDARIES OF THEIR THEIR
GEOGRAPHIC LEAD IN ADDITION TO
THE LEAVES THAT YOU SEE ON THE
OUTSIDE.
THESE ARE OTHER LEADS THAT HAVE
ALREADY BEEN IDENTIFIED BY THE
STATE SOME OF OUR NEW THIS YEAR.
SOME OF THEM AROUND FOR YEAR.
TWO AND AGAIN OUR ROLE IS TO
BRING THOSE FOLKS TOGETHER
WORKING WITH THE GEOGRAPHICALLY
NEEDS TO MAKE SURE THAT IF
THERE'S A DISTRICT WITHIN THE
COUNTY OFFICE BOUNDARIES OF
ANYWHERE IN THE STATE THAT HAS A
PARTICULAR NEED.
AND THAT COUNTY OFFICES IN THE
ABLE TO BE ABLE TO PROVIDE THAT
SUPPORT THEY COULD REACH OUT TO
THE G. O. LEAD.
THE COULD ALSO REACH OUT TO
THESE OTHER LEADS THEY CAN REACH
OUT TO THE COLLABORATIVE AS WELL
AND WE WILL MAKE SURE THAT THEY
WERE ABLE TO GET THAT RESOURCE --
SO THAT'S ONE PARTICULAR ROLE
IT'S NEW THIS YEAR WE'VE BEEN
WORKING WITH FOLKS IN THAT
SYSTEM NOW FOR A COUPLE OF YEARS.
THE SECOND PIECE OF OUR WORK IS
AROUND EIGHTEEN FORTY SO THE
DISTRICTS THAT ARE IN FISCAL
DISTRESS IN THE STATE THERE ARE
FOUR DISTRICTS IN THE STATE.
OF INGLEWOOD --
MAN VALLEJO CITY UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT SOUTH MONTEREY IN
OAKLAND WE'VE DONE QUITE A BIT
OF WORK THIS YEAR IN PARTICULAR
WITH INGLEWOOD AND VALLEJO
SCHOOL DISTRICT.
WHERE IN INGLEWOOD WE'VE ALREADY
BEEN ASSIGNED THERE BY COUNTY
OFFICE TO TRY TO FIGURE OUT HOW
WE CAN HELP THEM ON THE ACADEMIC
SIDE IS THEIR STRUGGLING BOTH
PHYSICALLY?
AND ACADEMICALLY IN VALLEJO WE
HAVE BEEN ASKED BY THE DISTRICT
IN THE COUNTY OFFICE TO GO IN
AND DO SOME WORK WITH THEM TOO
SO WE'VE BEEN WORKING WE'VE
ACTUALLY SPENT A DAY THERE
YESTERDAY.
WITH THOSE FOLKS WE'VE GOT SOME
INITIAL WORK THAT WE'RE DOING
WITH OAKLAND AND WE'VE BEEN IN
SOUTH MONTEREY AND SELF MONTEREY
JUST LAST WEEK WE WENT IN AND
DID THEIR DIFFERENTIATED
ASSISTANCE. FOR THEM WITH THE
COUNTY OFFICE.
SO OUR WORKERS BEEN PRETTY
HEAVILY FOCUSED ON THAT WORK.
IN ADDITION YOU'LL SEE IN THE
PACKET IT REFERENCES THE WORK TO
BE DONE WITH PROFESSIONAL
LEARNING THAT WORKS.
SO THAT'S WHAT WE'VE BEEN DOING
OVER THE LAST COUPLE OF YEARS TO
WHERE WE HAVE FIFTY FOUR
PROFESSIONAL LEARNING THAT WORKS
ACROSS THE STATE MANY OF THOSE
AND THIRTY EIGHT OF THOSE ARE
WITH COUNTY OFFICE.
AND WHAT WE DO IS WE HAVE WITH
THE COUNTY OFFICE BRING FOLKS
TOGETHER USUALLY IT'S COUNTY
OFFICE AND SCHOOL DISTRICT FOLKS
WHO COME TOGETHER TO TRY TO
TACKLE SPECIFIC PROBLEM AROUND
THE ACADEMIC NEEDS OF THE
DISTRICT TO THE COUNTY OFFICE.
EXAMPLES OF THAT WOULD BE AND
AND NAPA COUNTYWHERE WE JUST
HAD SOME WORK IN PARTICULARLY
THE WORKING WITH THEM FOR TWO
YEARS WITH NAPA COUNTY OFFICES
WORK WITH THEIR LOCAL DISTRICTS
THAT HAVE REALLY SMALL DISTRICTS.
AND THEY ARE STRUGGLING TO SERVE
SOME OF THEIR FOSTER YOUTH SO
IT'S COME TOGETHER WITH THEM TO
TRY TO BRAINSTORM AND BRING
RESOURCES TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY
CAN MEET THE NEEDS OF THOSE
STUDENTS --
IN SOUTH MONTEREY WE'VE DONE
SOME WORK IN THAT COUNTY WHERE
THEY HAVE BROUGHT ALL THE
DISTRICTS THEY HAVE ONE LARGER
HIGH SCHOOL DISTRICT IN MOSTLY
DISTRICTS ARE FEEDER DISTRICTS.
SO THEY BROUGHT THOSE FOLKS
TOGETHER TO TALK ABOUT HOW THEY
COULD MAKE SURE THAT THE
ASSESSMENTS IN THE PROGRAMS AND
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT THAT'S
HAPPENING AT THE CASE LEVEL.
WOULD BE ABLE TO BE CONSISTENT
STATE WHEN STUDENTS WENT TO HIGH
SCHOOL THEY WOULD HAVE A THEY BE
ABLE TO BE MORE SUCCESSFUL IN
HIGH SCHOOL.
AND THEN THE LAST THING I'LL
SPEAK TO YOU ABOUT IS OUR LEVIN
PILOT DISTRICTS AND SO WE HAVE --
WE ARE FUNDED FOR YEARS AGO OUR
PILOTS PACIFIC FUNDING TO GO IN
AND WORK WITH ELEVEN DISTRICTS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE --
WHO ARE STRUGGLING ACADEMICALLY
WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH THOSE
DISTRICTS FOR THE LAST FEW YEARS?
IN A PARTICULAR TRYING TO HELP
THEM UNDERSTAND HOW TO USE TO
PROVIDE THE PTSA MODEL WHICH IS
A PLAN TO STUDY ACT SO BASICALLY.
LOOKING AT A PARTICULAR AREA
WHERE THEY'RE STRUGGLING HELPING
PLAN AROUND SOME RESOURCE
PROVIDING PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT HELP HIM STUDY
PARTICULAR WHAT IT IS THAT
THEY'RE GOING TO DO.
ACT ON THAT AND THEN DO THAT
UNDER THE SHORT CYCLES
THROUGHOUT THE SCHOOL YEAR SO
WILL WE HAVE A FINAL REPORT TO
BE COMING OUT NEXT PALMER
EXCITED ABOUT SOME OF THE WORK
THAT WE'VE BEEN DOING THERE'S
WELL.
THANK YOU SURE I'M SET FROM THE
STATE BOARD OF IT.
GOOD MORNING DAVID TOP OF THE
STATE BOARD OF EDUCATION I'M
GOING TO FOCUS ON THE LOCAL
ACCOUNTABILITY PLANNING PROCESS.
AND THE AGENDA MATERIALS AS WELL
THE ONLY --
GAVE A VERY GOOD OVERVIEW OF
WHAT THIS REQUIREMENTS ARE AND
HOW THEY HAVE SORT OF INVOLVES
AND SELF CFF WAS FIRST ENACTED.
SO I WON'T GO INTO TOO MUCH
DETAIL THERE BUT REALLY JUST TO
NOTE THAT THIS IS WHERE ELEAZAR
REQUIRED ON AN ANNUAL BASIS. TO
LOOK AT THEIR PROGRESS ACROSS
THE EIGHT OUT PRIORITY AREAS
IDENTIFIED IN STATUTE TRACK ON
THE TWENTY ONE STATUTORY METRICS
ENGAGE WITH THEIR STAKEHOLDERS
AND SORT OF DOCUMENT.
IN THE LOCAL ACCOUNTABILITY PLAN
HOW THE THE ACTIONS THEY'RE
TAKING AND THEIR GOALS IN THE
EXPENDITURES TO SUPPORT THOSE
ACTIONS TO ADVANCE PROGRESS.
THE L. THE LOCAL ACCOUNTABILITY
PLAN TEMPLATE THE STATE BOARD
WAS REQUIRED TO A DOCTOR AND IT
WAS INITIALLY ADOPTED IN JANUARY
OF TWENTY FOURTEEN WHICH GIVEN
THE OTHER PIECES OF THIS
ACCOUNTABILITY SYSTEM THAT
YOU'VE HEARD ABOUT.
THE FIRST THREE YEARS OF LOOK
DEVELOPMENT OF THESE LOCAL
ACCOUNTABILITY PLANS OCCURRED
BEFORE WE HAD THE DASHBOARD IN
PLACE.
AND OCCURRED BEFORE THE SYSTEM
OF SUPPORT WAYS --
BUILT OUT AND ROBERT.
IN ISRAEL WERE DEDICATED.
BUT THESE ELEMENTS THE LOCAL
ACCOUNTABILITY PLAN THE
DASHBOARD IN THE SYSTEM OF
SUPPORT WERE ALWAYS INTENDED TO
WORK TOGETHER AS A SINGLE SYSTEM.
AND SO WHAT HAPPENED WITH THE
LOCAL ACCOUNTABILITY PLAN IS
THAT THERE'S BEEN AN ATTEMPT TO
GO BACK AND UPDATE IT TO REFLECT
THE ADDITIONAL ACTIONS TAKEN.
AS WE PROGRESS WITH
IMPLEMENTATION.
IN FACT THE STATE BOARD IS
UPDATED THEIR LOCAL COMPANY PLAN
TEMPLATE TWICE SINCE TWENTY FOUR
SINCE JANUARY OF TWENTY FOURTEEN
BUT THE MOST RECENT CHANGE HAD
TO REALLY IMPORTANT CHANGES
FOCUSED ON TRANSPARENCY IN
PARTICULAR ABOUT THE INFORMATION
IN THE EL CAP IN THE
EXPENDITURES REFLECTED THEIR THE
FIRST IT.
WAS A BUDGET SUMMARY THAT REALLY
JUST A HIGH LEVEL OR SORRY A
PLAN SUMMARY THAT WAS A HIGH
LEVEL DESCRIPTION OF SIR WHAT'S
THE KEY TAKE AWAYS.
OF THE LOCAL ACCOUNTABILITY
PLANNED THAT THE DISTRICT HAS
ADOPTED IN ALSO CLARIFYING THAT
THE LOCAL EDUCATIONAL ACTUALLY
HAS TO IDENTIFY EACH ACTION IN
THE EL CAP THATIS CONTRIBUTING
TO ITS OBLIGATIONTO INCREASE
IMPROVE SERVICES. FOR THE THREE
HIGH NEED STUDENT GROUPS THAT
RECEIVE ADDITIONAL FUNDS UNDER
L. CFF.
AS THE AGENDA MATERIALS NOTED
LAST YEAR'S BUDGET ACT INCLUDED
TWO KEY CHANGES ONE IS A NEW
DOCUMENT THAT'S REQUIRED TO BE
ADOPTED IN CONJUNCTION WITH
LOCAL ACCOUNTABILITY COULD PLAN.
THAT IS A BUDGET SUMMARY FOR
PARENTS AND AGAIN THE GOAL OF
THAT DOCUMENT SPREAD GREATER
TRANSPARENCY AROUND THE
DISTRICTS OVERALL REVENUES AND
EXPENDITURES.
AS WELL AS HOW THOSE RELATE TO
WHAT WE SEE AND LOCAL
ACCOUNTABILITY PLAN THAT IT'S
ADOPTED.
AND ITS REQUIREMENT TO INCREASE
IMPROVE SERVICES HOW THE
EXPENDITURES IN THE EL CAP
REALLY MEET THAT OBLIGATION.
AND THE SECOND PIECE WHICH THE
BOARD WILL BE WORKING ON THIS
YEAR IS A REQUIREMENT TO UPDATE
THE LOCAL ACCOUNTABILITY PLAN.
TEMPLATE TO INCLUDE SUMMARY
TABLES THE ENTIRE LOCAL
ACCOUNTABILITY PLAN ALL THE
EXPENDITURES INCLUDED AND ALSO
FOR THOSE ACTIONS THAT
CONTRIBUTE TO THEIR APARTMENT TO
INCREASE IMPROVE SERVICES FOR
HIGH NEED STUDENTS.
SO THE GOAL THERE IS TO JUST
MAKE IT IS AS EASY AS POSSIBLE
FOR PARENTS IN THE COMMUNITY TO
UNDERSTAND HOW THE DISTRICT IS
PRIORITIZING ITS RESOURCES.
THAT THEY CAN ENGAGE AND THE
LOCAL PLANNING PROCESS.
SO THAT ADDITIONAL CHANGE AT THE
BOARD MEETING THEM IN THE
CURRENT TEMP --
EL CAP TEMPLATE IS TO ADD
PROBLEMS IN THE SUMMARY OF THE
EL CAP THAT REQUIRED THE ALLEY A
TO ADDRESS ANY AREAS ON THE
DASHBOARD WHERE THERE'S LOW
PERFORMANCE OR WHERE THERE AREAS
WHERE THERE ARE SIGNIFICANT
DISPARITIES IN PERFORMANCE AMONG
STUDENT GROUPS.
SECOND OF ALL THERE WAS TO BUILD
OUT THE RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN THE
DASHBOARD INDIA AND THAT LOCAL
ACCOUNTABILITY PLAN SET THE
STATE PERFORMANCE INFORMATION
PERFORMANCE RELATIVE TO THE
STANDARDS.
IS A KEY ASPECT OF THE
CONVERSATION LOCALLY ABOUT HOW
TO PRIORITIZE AND FOCUS WITHIN
THEIR LOCAL PLANNING PROCESS.
AND SIGNIFICANTLY REALLY
ENSURING THAT IF THERE ARE
DISPARITIES IN PERFORMANCE AMONG
STUDENT GROUPS THE LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL UNITS WE MUST
ADDRESS THAT WITHIN LOCAL
PLANNING PROCESS AND ENGAGE WITH
THEIR STAKEHOLDERS AROUND THAT
CONVERSATION.
SO I THINK TO CONCLUDE WHAT I
WOULD NOTE IS THAT WHERE WE ARE
NOW WITH THE EXISTENCE OF THE
DASHBOARD THE UPDATED LOCAL
ACCOUNTABILITY PLAN TEMPLATE.
IS SORT OF WHERE THE LOCAL
PLANNING PROCESS IS ABLE TO WORK
AS IT WAS ALWAYS INTENDED WHERE
WE HAVE LOCALLY AVAILABLE
INFORMATION BUT ALSO THOSE STATE
MEASURES.
THAT ARE REPORTED AGAINST
CONSISTENT PERFORMANCE STANDARDS
STATEWIDE AND REALLY HELP
FOCUSING GUIDE LOCAL
CONVERSATION ABOUT WHETHER WHAT
THE DISTRICT IS PROPOSING TO DO
AND HOW TO USING ITS FUNDS IT'S
FUNDS IS REALLY WORKING. FOR
STUDENTS TO IMPROVE OUTCOMES AND
OPPORTUNITIES FOR ALL STUDENTS
IN PARTICULAR THE HIGH NEED
STUDENT GROUPS THAT THEY SERVE.
I THINK THAT THE FURTHER
IMPROVEMENTS TO TRANSPARENCY
THAT THE NEXT LOCAL
ACCOUNTABILITY PLAN TEMPLATE
WILL INCLUDE AROUND THERE'S
EXPENDITURES WILL JUST FURTHER
THAT GOAL OF ENSURING ROBUST
CONVERSATION THE LOCAL LEVEL.
SO THAT PEOPLE WHO WANT TO
ENGAGE IN THE KIND IT JUST OF
WHAT IS THE DISTRICT PROPOSING
TO DO BUT HOW IS IT PRIORITIZING
ITS RESOURCES --
TO TO ACHIEVE THOSE ACTIONS AND
SERVICES SO WITH THAT I'M HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THAT THE
CAMPUS SECURITY THEY HAVE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU ALL I THE I
THINK THIS HIGHLIGHTS THAT THE
THE GOVERNMENT SYSTEM OF PUBLIC
EDUCATION CALIFORNIA'S PRETTY
CONFUSING --
I DON'T PUT THAT ON YOU
UNDERSTOOD IT IS.
THE SPIRIT HOW ABOUT THE ABOUT
MIKE MY QUESTIONS MA'AM ARE
MOSTLY FOR MISTER MOLINO --
ABOUT THE CAM THE CALIFORNIA
CLAMOR FOR EDUCATIONAL
EXCELLENCE --
IN JUST ALL DAHLE SURE ONE WHO
SAW A SCHOOL DISTRICT CALLS YOU
IN THEY MIGHT CALL YOU IN FOR
THE DISTRICT THE SCHOOL SITE.
WALK ME THROUGH HELP WHAT THAT
MIGHT LOOK LIKE THE AND IF IF
THE SCHOOL DISTRICT FOR EXAMPLE
WE WE GET CONTACTED AROUND
DIFFERENCE ASSISTANCE IT'S
USUALLY THE DISTRICT.
RIGHT SO THAT WORK IS FOCUSED
SPECIFICALLY ON THE DISTRICT
LEVEL IN THE DISTRICTS A THE
RESULTS BASED ON THE DASHBOARD
DATA OF THE SCHOOL DISTRICT
BECAUSE OF SEND.
THE SYSTEM THAT WE GENERALLY DO
WE REACH OUT TO THE COUNTY
OFFICE FIRST. TO SEE THAT THE
COUNTY OFFICE AS A RESOURCE TO
BE ABLE TO HELP THEM.
COUNTY OFFICE OFTEN WILL BE ABLE
TO SAY YOU KNOW WE HAVE THE
SPORTS IN THE RESOURCE TO HELP
WHETHER SAY LET'S GO AND LOOK
INTO THAT TOGETHER.
IN THE NEW SYSTEM YOU CAN ALSO
REACH OUT TO GEOGRAPHICALLY
ITSELF IT'S TRYING TO CREATE
MULTIPLE LEVELS OF SUPPORT --
BUT AGAIN ALL WORKING
COLLABORATIVELY TOGETHER SO
RECENTLY THERE WAS --
THERE WAS A LET'S PUT ON A
BELIEVE A LOW PERFORMING SCHOOLS
RIGHT THERE WAS LIKE EIGHT
HUNDRED SCHOOLS OR SOMETHING
LIKE THAT ON THE LIST.
CERTAINLY A VERY HIGH NUMBER SO
DO WE KNOW THAT DID DID EACH
DISTRICT REACH OUT TO AT A AT A
MINIMUM THERE COUNTY FOR HELP.
ARE THEY YOU'RE SPEAKING TO US
SO YES I CAN THE YOUR SPEAK AND
ACCESS TO THE SCHOOL'S EVER
IDENTIFIED.
SO IN THIS ASSEMBLY.
LOW BACK UP WHAT METRIC IS THERE
IS THERE IS THERE ARE METRIC
THAT MAKES YOU AVAILABLE TO A
SCHOOL DISTRICT OR IS IS THERE
ARE METRIC.
THAT MAKES IT MANDATED THAT YOU
HELP ON A SCHOOL DISTRICT.
AND THERE IS A MANDATE AND THAT
THE MANDATE IS AROUND EIGHTEEN
FORTY DISTRICTS LOGISTICS CENTER
IN FISCAL DISTRESS SO THERE'S A
MANDATE AROUND US WORKING WILL
AUTOMATICALLY BEING ASSIGNED TO
THOSE DISTRICTS SO DISTRICTS
LIKE INGLEWOOD THAT YOU'RE
FAMILIAR WITH THEM DOES HAVE A
STATE LOAN.
SO FOR THOSE DISTRICTS IN
PARTICULAR.
THERE'S A MANDATE THAT WE WOULD
GO IN AND WORK WITH THOSE
DISTRICTS IN PARTICULAR THE
OTHER ONES ARE THERE'S ALSO
MANDATES AROUND --
CHARTER SCHOOLS WHEN CHARTER
SCHOOLS WILL QUALIFY --
DID THE REST OF IT IS REALLY
DEPENDENT UPON WHAT THE COUNTY
OFFICE HAS TO OFFER AND WHAT
THEY CAN OR CANNOT OFFER ME ARTS
BE ABLE TO HELP THE DISTRICT.
YOU WERE REFERENCING SCHOOLS
SCHOOLS ARE UNDER THE S. A PLAN.
SO SCHOOLS HAVE A DARN GOOD FOR
WE DON'T HAVE A SPECIFIC TIED TO
THE SCHOOLS THAT ARE IDENTIFIED
UNDER SO.
ALTHOUGH WE COULD WORK WITH THE
COUNTY OFFICE ON SUPPORT THAT
THEY CAN OFFERS WELL LOCALLY.
SO THE FIRST THE FIRST UP FOR
DISTRICT IS THE COUNTY.
CORRECT CORRECT DO WE HAVE ANY
DATA RELATIVE TO TO HOW THIS IS
WORKING FOR FOR IF A DISTRICT
HAS GONE TO THE COUNTY OR EVEN
IF DISTRICTS ARE GOING TO THE
COUNTY DO WE KNOW THAT.
YES THEY ARE GOING TO THE COUNTY
THE MAJORITY OF COUNTY OFFICES
IN THE STATE.
ARE PROVIDING THAT FIRST LEVEL
OF ASSISTANCE WE HAVE ONLY
WORKED WITH A SMALL PERCENTAGE
OF FOLKS.
WHO HAVE --
ACTUALLY LESS THAN TEN DISTRICTS
TO WHERE THE COUNTY IS NOT
WORKING WITH THEM.
AND AGAIN THIS IS THEIR SECOND
YEAR THE GENERAL --
SENSE OF DISTRICTS AS THAT'S
WORKING PRETTY WELL.
SO YOUR MAJOR INTERACTION IS
WITH.
A COUNTY TYPICALLY THAT'S USE
USES THE COUNTY OFFICES TO BUILD
THE CAPACITY TO HELP.
THE DISTRICT LEVEL THAT'S RIGHT.
SO THAT'S IN IN ONE ELEMENT OF
OUR WORK THAT'S AROUND THE
DIFFERENCES SYSTEMS PIECE IN
BACK TO YOU SPOKE TO A WHEN IS
SCHOOL THIS UNIT IS IN FISCAL
DISTRESS HOW DOES YOUR OLD OF
HER THAN FACT MATT --
WHAT WOULD LOOK AT THE ACADEMIC
PIECE OF THICK MATS ROLE AS THEY
GO IN AND THEY?
THEY IN PARTICULAR LOOK AT DOING
A STUDY WE'RE ACTUALLY DOING
PART OF THAT WITHIN THE FIXED
MARRIAGE RECORD TO THE LAND LOOK
UNDER THESE THE SPECIFIC FIVE
ELEMENTS ONE OF THOSE IS
ACADEMIC.
AND SO THEY DO A REVIEW OF THE
DISTRICT AND THEY IDENTIFY WHERE
THEY'RE DOING WELL WHERE THEY'RE
NOT DOING WELL --
AND THAT'S REALLY WHAT THEIR
ROLE IS WHAT OUR ROLE NOW WITH
EIGHTEEN FORTY YEARS IS THAT WE
ACTUALLY WILL GO INTO AN
ACADEMIC REVIEW SO IT'S ALL
GOING TO REVIEW THE DISTRICT
ACADEMICALLY LOOKED COUNTY
OFFICE AND TO HELP THE DISTRICT
IDENTIFY PLANNED.
BETTER IN THAT WE ALSO ARE ABLE
TO PROVIDE SOME OF US FINANCIAL
RESOURCES PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT.
IN OTHER AREAS IT'S ACTUALLY
SUPPORT HELPING THEM GET BETTER.
AND THEN WHO DO YOU REPORT TO
A BOARD YES YOU HAVE A BOARD.
OKAY AND DO YOU HAVE ANY --
NUMBERS DATA RELATIVE TO WHAT
YOU DO EVERY YEAR.
HOW MANY INTERACTIONS YOU HAVE
OR YOU KNOW YOU'RE DOING AROUND
THE STATE YEAH WE DO ACTUALLY IF
THERE'S A?
SIDE AND BRING IT WITH ME BUT WE
HAVE ALSO HAVE WE HAVE A MAP ON
OUR WEBSITE THAT SHOWS THAT
WE'RE WE ARE AT LAST YEAR.
LAST YEAR WE OVER ITS DO WE
DON'T WE TOUCHED OVER SIX
HUNDRED DISTRICTS.
AND WORKED WITH ALMOST EVERY
COUNTY OFFICE IN THE STATE.
AND WHEN YOU GO INTO A DISTRICT
WHEN YOU ARE CALLED INTO A
DISTRICT.
DO YOU GET TO THE SCHOOL SITE
LEVEL.
AND TWO PENS AND AGAIN WE'RE
WORD NOT NESTLE CALLED INTO A
DISTRICT WERE CALLED IN DISTRICT
THAT'S IT SPECIFIC AROUND
DIFFERENCES ASSISTANCE OR
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE.
WE ALSO DO PROFESSIONAL LEARNING
RIGHT SO --
FEEL CITY ADVENTURE WE'VE DONE
SOME WORK COMPETE OUNTY OFFICES
AROUND THE EL CAP WE DO
TRAININGS WOULD --
DIFFERENT COUNTY OFFICES AROUND
A PARTICULAR ISSUE LIKE
ABSENTEEISM TRUE IS THAT --
TRUANCY THINGS OF THAT NATURE
THAT WE HAVE OUR PROFESSIONAL
LEARNING THAT WORKS WHICH WE
HAVE FIFTY FOUR WHICH IS WHERE
WE TOUCH MOST DISTRICTS.
SO THAT'S WORKING WITH COUNTY
OFFICES AND SCHOOL DISTRICTS
WITHIN THEIR COUNTY AROUND
IDENTIFYING A SPECIFIC ACADEMIC
AREA THAT THEY MAY BE STRUGGLING
WITH WE FACILITATE THAT.
PROFESSIONAL LEARNING NETWORK WE
PROVIDE THEM A COACH AND THEN
HELP THEM OVER A PERIOD OF TIME
TO GET BETTER.
THANK YOU SIR.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS --
TOGETHER WITH JUST THE ON THE
WAS A THREE IN SEVENTY FOUR I
BELIEVE.
ELEAZAR THAT WERE --
FOR THIS YEAR THAT HAD THE THE
QUALIFIED FOR THE WHAT DO YOU
CALL IT IS OUR EXCHANGE
ASSISTANCE.
YES RIGHT --
AND AND THEN AS I UNDERSTOOD
THERE'S TWO HUNDRED THIRTY NINE
NEW ELEAZAR ON THAT LIST THIS
YEAR -- NOT
NEW.
SO THE I THINK THAT THAT THAT
WAS COVERED IN LA A REMARKS
ACTUALLY.
AND IF YOU WANT TO CLARIFY.
THAT P. SIR --
SO I I DON'T HAVE THE SPECIFIC
NUMBERS IN FRONT OF ME BUT SO
THIS YEAR THERE WAS US THREE
HUNDRED AND FORTY THREE
DISTRICTS IN THAT INCLUDES
THIRTY ONE COUNTY OFFICES BUT
COUNTY OFFICES OF EDUCATION LAST
YEAR THERE WAS TWO HUNDRED AND
TWENTY EIGHT DISTRICTS SO
THERE'S AN INCREASE.
FROM THE PRIOR YEAR AN IMPORTANT
ANOTHER NINETY THREE OF THE
CITRIX MASTER DID EXIT THE
PROGRAM RIGHT AND I SO I GOT
THAT BUT THEN THAT THIS YEAR
THERE WAS TWO HUNDRED THIRTY
NINE NEW ELLIE ETS.
AS PART OF THAT OVERALL.
THREE HUNDRED SEVENTY FOUR
NUMBER AND MY QUESTION REALLY IS
I I NOTE THAT.
IT TALKS ABOUT --
THAT SOME OF THE REASONS FOR
THAT WERE --
IT DIDN'T KNOW WHERE.
WHERE THEY AND --
FALLING INTO THIS NEED WHAT
WHICH WHICH STATE PRIORITY AREAS
ARE THEY LACKING IN THAT ARE
CAUSING THEM TO GET ON THE LIST
IS IS KIND OF MY QUESTION WE CAN
DEFINITELY PROVIDE YOU THAT
INFORMATION I THINK IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT. TO KNOW THAT LAST
YEAR'S MEASURES.
HAVE GREATLY DIFFERED FROM THIS
YEAR'S MEASURES BECAUSE OF
ADDITIONAL DATA AS WE WERE AB
ABLE TO ADD FOR THE FIRST TIME
CHRONIC ABSENTEEISM.
THEY'RE ABLE TO ADD A COLLEGE
CAREER INDICATES DUE TO OUR
NEGOTIATIONS WITH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT OF OUR INTER EVERY
STUDENT SUCCEEDS ACT AND SO.
A GRADE ELEVEN NOW PLAYS INTO TO
TRADITIONAL INDICATOR SO SO
REALLY THE METRICS THAT WERE
USING FOR TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
IN THOSE ADDITIONAL TWO AND
FORTY THREE ARE ARE GREATLY
DIFFERENT THAN WHAT WAS
HAPPENING IN.
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN BUT I CAN
DEFINITELY PROVIDE YOU THAT THAT
DATA -- IT
IN A COMPREHENSIVE FORMAT --
ELECTRONICALLY YOU HAVE WE GET
THEN I NOTICED THAT YOU KNOW SO
IT WAS DEALING WITH HOMELESS --
SHERIDAN SOME WAS DEALING WITH --
I THINK FOSTER YOUTH --
AND OBVIOUSLY WE WANT TO TRY AND
GET A A WHAT IS IT THAT WERE
MISSING WITH REGARD TO THESE
POPULATIONS.
RIGHT --
BECAUSE AT I MEAN I THINK THAT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT THING FOR US TO
KNOW POLICY WAS IS.
IS NO WHERE THOSE THINGS BE
MISSED AT THAT LEVEL --
CERTAINLY IT'S GOOD TO KNOW THAT
DOES THOSE GROUPS THAT ARE
AFFECTED BUT WHAT IS IT THAT'S
NOT BEING DONE.
AND SO IF YOU CAN GET THAT
INFORMATION BACK TO US I MEAN
COULD YOU DO THAT IN A WRITTEN
FORM BACK TO THE COMMITTEE HERE.
I THINK THEY WERE GONNA BE
SPENDING THAT THAT THE NEXT YEAR
COVERING THAT BECAUSE WE'LL HAVE
TO YEARS OF METRICS COME TWO
THOUSAND AND NINETEEN WITH WITH
THE COUNTY IS BEING INVOLVED IN
THAT SYSTEM OF SUPPORT AT YOU
KNOW.
SIR THAT FIRST GROUND LEVEL THAT
STATE --
MISTER MOLINA SPOKE ABOUT --
THEY'LL BE ABLE TO FIGURE OUT
SOME OF THE ROOT CAUSES WE
SIMPLY WITH THE DASHBOARD TELL
THEM YOU HAVE A PROBLEM WE DON'T
AREN'T ABLE TO SAY.
WHAT IS CAUSING THAT PROBLEM I
THINK THE OTHER THAT'S A IS THAT
THE LEGISLATURE PASSED A
LEGISLATION THAT TOLD US THAT WE
HAVE TO USE IT?
A SMALLER NUMBER --
WHEN WE LOOK AT THAT STUDENT
POPULATION SO FAR OUR OTHER
STUDENT GROUPS IT'S IT'S AN AND
SIZE OF THIRTY FOR FOSTER IN FOR
HOMELESS IT'S GOES DOWN?
TO FIFTEEN SO WE ARE --
CAPTURING --
YOU KNOW.
PROBABLY A LARGER PERCENTAGE OF
FOSTER AND AND HOMELESS --
DUE TO THAT SMALLER --
SUBGROUP BUT BUT IT IS THAT
THERE IS AN INCREASED FOCUS ON
MAKES I'M OF COURSE ARE MOST
NEED YOUR STUDENTS.
IF.
IF YEAH IF I COULD JUST ADD TO
THAT A LITTLE BIT AYE I THINK --
THE THE QUESTION OUT THAT
ANALYSIS OF WHAT'S GOING ON WITH
THE NUMBERS I I THINK WHAT WE
HAVE IT WE'VE ATTEMPTED TO DO
THAT AND AND WE CERTAINLY CAN.
S. FOLLOWING UP ON THIS HEARING
SHARE WHAT WE HAVE AVAILABLE
THAT THE CHALLENGES IT'S VERY
HARD TO YOU BECAUSE OF THAT THAT
CHANGE IN THE INDICATORS THAT
WERE INCLUDED IN THE DASHBOARD.
AND IN PARTICULAR YOU KNOW
CHRONIC ABSENTEEISM.
THEY WERE VERY LIMITED
INDICATORS THAT APPLIED AT THE
K. EIGHT LEVEL.
SO THERE ARE A LOT OF ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL DISTRICTS THAT REALLY
ONLY HAD.
EFFECTIVELY THREE COLORS ON THE
DASHBOARD AND SO WHEN YOU ADD IN
THOSE ADDITIONAL INDICATORS THAT
THE NUMBER OF COMBINATIONS THAT
CAN LEAD TO IDENTIFICATION
INCREASED.
SO AS FAR AS REALLY GETTING TO
THAT QUESTION OF WHAT ANY
RELIABLE CONCLUSIONS JUST WITH
THAT SORT OF ONE YEAR OF DATA IS
GIVEN THE CHANGE BUT WE CAN
SHARE WHAT WE FOUND.
BUT I THINK IT'S MISS BECAUSE ON
A SAID AS WE LOOK TO NEXT YEAR'S
DASH FOR THE TWENTY NINETEEN
DASH BOARD WE WILL BE ABLE TO
HAVE GREATER LEVELS HEARD.
UNDERSTANDING FROM YEAR TO YEAR
THAT IT'S COMPATIBLE THERE WILL
BE SOME DIFFERENCES BUT THEY
WILL BE MUCH.
MUCH SMALLER IN TERMS OF THEIR
OVERALL IMPACT SO I THINK WE WEHOPE WE WILL BE ABLE DROPPED
BETTER CONCLUSIONS THAT CAN
INFORM SOME OF THE STATE LEVEL
POLICY CONVERSATIONS --
IN A WAY THAT THAT'S MORE
RELIABLE IN TERMS OF THE
CONCLUSIONS.
BUT I THINK I WOULD LIKE TO TAKE
I THINK I KNOW WHAT YOU'RE
ASKING BILL AND I THINK IT'S THE
RIGHT QUESTION IS SO.
I'LL USE SPECIAL ED FOR EXAMPLE
IF YOU LOOK AT THE DATA LAST
YEAR AND THIS YEAR THAT'S THE
LARGEST SUBGROUP THAT CONTINUES
TO QUALIFY.
AND SO ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE
DID LAST YEAR'S WE WORK WITH THE
DEPARTMENT IN PARTICULAR TO GO
FURTHER INTO THE DATA.
IS THE DATA WILL TELL YOU.
THAT THE OF SPECIAL ED STUDENTS
AND THEY'RE THEY'RE NOT MEETING
THE EXPECTATIONS RIGHT BUT SO
WHAT THAT DOESN'T TELL YOU IS
WHY.
SO WHAT'S HAPPENING AND SO WHEN
IT COMES TO SPECIAL ED FOR
EXAMPLE PEOPLE MAY SPECULATE AND
SAY WELL IT'S BECAUSE THEY'RE
THEY TEND --
TO CLASS BY A LOT OF HIS SPECIAL
THAT WE FOR A LOT OF STUDENTS TO
SPECIAL EDUCATION ANOTHER PIECE
THAT YOU CAN LOOKAT IN
PARTICULAR IS HOW OFTEN ARE
STUDENTS ACTUALLY SPENDING TIME
IN THE REGULAR CLASSROOM.
LEAST RESTRICTIVE ENVIRONMENT.
WHEN YOU GO IN AND DO THE
DIFFERENCES SYSTEMS YOU'RE ABLE
TO UNPACK THAT DATA LOCALLY?
SO FOR EXAMPLE ONE OF THINGS WE
FOUND LAST YEAR IS IS WHERE.
DISTRICTS THAT HAD WE'RE WE'RE
READ RIGHT THEY DIDN'T MEET THE
CRITERIA MORE THAN ONE AREA.
THE THE MORE IS THAT THEY DIDN'T
NEED IT WILL BE FOUND TO
STUDENTS WERE ACTUALLY IN THE
CLASSROOM LAST TIME.
SO THAT'S AN EXAMPLE WE CAN NEED
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THAT DAY
BECAUSE NOW YOU CAN START HAVING
SOME CONVERSATIONS AROUND WHY
WHY THE STUDENTS NINE CLASSROOMS.
RIGHT WHAT WHERE ARE THEY RIGHT
AND WHAT WE FOUND ALSO IS THAT
STUDENTS ARE IN CLASSROOMS GET
SUSPENDED MORE.
PARTICULAR BECAUSE THEY'RE
STRANGERS OFTEN RIGHT IN SO
THAT'S AN EXAMPLE OF THAT COULD
BE DIFFERENT FOR EVERY SINGLE
DISTRICT THAT DIFFERENCES
SYSTEMS PROCESS ALLOWS YOU TO
REALLY GET OUT THAT.
DAY JENNIFER I WHAT'S DIFFERENT
ABOUT THIS DISTRICT BASED BASED
ON THEIR DATA SO YOU CAN
ACTUALLY GO IN AND START TO DO
SOME PROBLEM SOLVING.
THANK YOU SURE.
THANKS JUST HAD A COUPLE QUICK
QUESTIONS --
FOR MISTER NOW --
YOU'D MENTIONED SORT OF THE WORK
THAT YOU'RE DOING IN INGLEWOOD
AND COUPLE OTHER DISTRICTS.
DO YOU ALSO TRACK DISTRICTS THAT
ARE SORT OF ON THE CUSP AND DO
ASSISTANCE PROVIDE ASSISTANCE TO
THEM.
WELL HAS HARD TO TRACK HIM
BECAUSE WORD WERE JUST IN OUR
FIRST COUPLE YEARS WITH THE DATA
RIGHT SO THERE ARE THE THE A WE
HAVE OUR THIS OUR SECOND YEAR OF
ACTUALLY HAVING DATA THAT'S
IDENTIFIED BASED ON YOUR
DIFFERENCES ASSISTANCE --
SO NO ANSWERS WE DON'T TRACK
THEM AT THIS POINT TWO WE ARE.
FOCUSED ON THOSE WHO ACTUALLY
QUALIFY HARD TO KNOW WHO WOULD
QUALIFY NEXT YEAR --
WHAT I CAN TELL YOU THOUGH IS
THAT WERE ROUND THOSE DISTRICTS
ARE IN FISCAL DISTRESS AROUND
THIS I MENTION THAT WE'RE DOING
THESE ACADEMIC REVIEWS?
AND WE'RE FINDING IS IS WHEN YOU
GO AND WEEKS THOSE ACADEMIC
REVIEWS WE BELIEVE COULD BE A
TOOL THAT WE COULD USE FOR ANY
DISTRICT.
RIGHT AND SO THAT WE INSTEAD OF
JUST THOSE DISTRICTS THAT ARE
ARE QUALIFYING ANDRIY EIGHTEEN
FORTY WERE ACTUALLY TRYING TO
IDENTIFY THESE TOOLS AND HAVE
SOME IDEAS TO WORK WITH COUNTY
OFFICES TO TRAIN ON THE USE OF
THOSE TOOLS.
SO THEY COULD THEY KNOW WHO
THOSE LOCAL DISTRICTS ARE AND BE
ABLE TO USE THAT TOOL TO BE ABLE
TO HELP FOLKS SO THAT VIEWERS
WERE ABLE TO APPROACH HIM BEFORE
THEY GO INTO DIFFERENCES SYSTEMS.
AND AND WITH WHAT YOU SEEN FROM
THE DISTRICTS THAT YOU ARE
ASSISTING TO SEE ANY COMMON
THREADS THAT ARE.
SORT OF DRIVING THEM TO DISTRESS
YEAH WE DO WHAT WHAT WE FIND IN
THERE IS A COUPLE THINGS IT
WON'T SURPRISE YOU ONE IS IS
THAT YOU KNOW WE USE THE WORD
COHERENCE OFTEN THEY HAVE A LOT
OF THINGS IN PLACE THINGS IN
PLACE LIKE.
THEY MAY HAVE A CURRICULUM IN
PLACE RIGHT BUT HOW IT'S BEING
IMPLEMENTED IS DIFFERENT.
ON AND EVERY SCHOOL SITE THEY
MAY HAVE --
TIME FOR TEACHERS TO BE IN
PROFESSIONAL LEARNING GROUPS
RIGHT WITH A MINIMUM DAY
TEACHERS COME TOGETHER.
HOW THEY MANAGE THAT TIME
TOGETHER IS DIFFERENT IN EVERY
SCHOOL --
DAYS SOME HAVE MORE PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT AND OTHERS USE OF
DATA IS AN ISSUE WE ALSO HAVE A
HUGE TURNOVER IN THOSE DISTRICTS
THEIR LEADERSHIP TEAMS IN
PARTICULAR.
INGLEWOOD FOR EXAMPLE THIS IS
THE FIRST YEAR THAT THEY'VE HAD
THE SAME CABINET LEVEL TEAM.
THAT THEY'VE HAD SEVEN YEARS SO
PEOPLE COMING AND GOING ALL THE
TIME TO CIVILIAN PEACE OR
NOTICING TO IS THERE IS A THEIR
ABILITY THEIR CAPACITY. TO
ACTUALLY DO THINGS TO ACTUALLY
MAKE IMPROVEMENTS THIS IS A
STRUGGLE IN PARTICULAR BECAUSE
THEY ARE VERY FOCUSED ON TRYING.
TO FIGURE OUT HOW FISCALLY
THEY'RE GOING TO BE ABLE TO GET
FISCAL DISTRESS AND SO OFTEN
ACADEMICS ARE LEFT BEHIND.
WHAT WERE THESE TWO ISSUES I
IMAGINE THEY OUGHT TO DO WITH
ARE DECLINING ENROLLMENT?
YES AND HOW ARE THEY GRAPPLING
WITH THAT THERE'S A GROWING WITH
THAT AND I GUESS YOU SENT YOU
OVERSEE OAKLAND IN OAKLAND JUST
GOT THROUGH A TEACHERS STRIKE.
WHAT WHAT WHAT DID YOU WHAT DID
YOU THINK HOW DID YOU THINK THAT?
RESOLUTION --
YOU KNOW WAS.
WAS RESOLVED TO DEFY HERE WAS A
GOOD RESOLUTION CONCERNING --
I DON'T KNOW IF I HAVE AN
OPINION ON ON THEIR THEIR
RESOLUTION IN REGARDS TO THEIR
CONTRACT THE THING I CAN TELL
YOU IS THEY'RE GONNA HAVE TO CUT
MORE PROGRAMS.
RIGHT AND SO --
SOME OF OUR WORK AROUND OAKLAND
IS SEVEN SUMMER HAVE INITIAL
DISCUSSIONS WITH THEM OF
ACTUALLY TRYING TO HELP THEM
DETERMINE WHAT TO CUT.
CONSTRUCTION WE CYLINDER EL CAP
THEY'VE IDENTIFIED THINGS THEY
WANT TO DO TO HELP KIDS AND
STRUCTURALLY.
SO THEY'VE ASKED US TO LOOK AT
THE RAIL KAPANEN HAVE
CONVERSATIONS AND SAY THEY HAVE
THEIR LIST OF CUTS.
IN TO SAY IF THEY CUT THIS HOW
WOULD THAT'D BE ABLE POWER THAT
AFFECT THEM ACADEMICALLY AND
SUCH I TO HELP WOMEN UP TO CLICK
AND ARE YOU ARE YOU SAYING THAT
WITH THE OTHER --
DISTRICTS AS WELL YES ABSOLUTELY
AND ARE THEY ARE THEY MAKING
THOSE.
VERY DIFFICULT CHOICES I MEAN WE
DON'T WE DON'T LIKE MAKING CUTS
I'M SURE THEY DON'T LIKE MAKING
CUTS THOSE ARE NOT FUN.
FUN THINGS TO BE DOING YEAH THEY
ARE YESTERDAY FOR EXAMPLE WE
SPENT THE MORNING WITH VALLEJO
IN VALLEJO WAS CUT AND FIFTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS FROM THEIR
BUDGET.
AND SO PART OF OUR CONVERSATIONS
YESTERDAY WAS THE THE REDUCING A
COUPLE SCHOOLS ARE TRYING TO
HELP THEM DETERMINE HOW WE WOULD
BE ABLE TO HELP THEM IN THAT
AREAS ARE DOING THAT --
THEY ARE LOSING PRINCIPLES AND
SO HAVE NUMBER DEVELOPING A
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT PLAN
FOR THEM.
IN TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW WE
CAN HELP THEM HOW THEY'RE GONNA
BE ABLE TO FUND THAT RIGHT IN
LOOKING AT THOSE PIECES.
AND HOW DO YOU HOW DO YOU FOCUS
ON YOUR SOURCE I CANNOT BE LIKE
THE EMERGENCY ROOM PHYSICIAN
WE'RE JUST TRYING TO DO SOME
TRIAGE HOW DO YOU.
HOW DO YOU CREATE STABILITY
BECAUSE THAT SEEMS TO BE THE
HARDEST?
THE HARDEST THING TO DO BECAUSE
IF YOU DON'T.
QUEST ABILITY YOU DON'T MAINTAIN
ENROLLMENT IF YOU DON'T MAINTAIN
AROMA YOU TO MAINTAIN FUNDING SO
HOW DO YOU.
HOW TO CREATE THAT STABILITY
YEAH I THINK THE BEST EXAMPLE IS
PROBABLY IN THE WOODS SO
INGLEWOOD UNDER THE DIRECTION TO
COUNTY OFFICE SO THE COUNTY
OFFICE IN PARTICULAR WE WENT IN
TOGETHER IN THE COUNTY OFFICE WE
SPENT?
IN SEPTEMBER THAT WHOLE FIRST
MONTH WITH A GROUP OF FOLKS WHO
WENT IN JUST ANALYZE WHAT WAS
GOING ON THEY LOOK THEY WERE
LOOKING AT THE FISCAL SIDE
ELECTED FACILITIES.
WE LOOKED AT SPECIAL ED THAT'S A
DISTRICT IN PARTICULAR THAT HAS
A LOT OF SPECIAL ED CONCERNS AND
WE LOOKED AT THE ACADEMIC
PROGRAMS SO WE SPENT TIMES
ACTUALLY TRYING TO ANALYZE WHAT
EXIST WHAT IS.
WHAT'S GOING ON WHERE ARE THE
PROBLEMS AND WE DEVELOPED OF
WITH THE WITH THE COUNTY OFFICE
FIVE STEP PLAN IN EACH OF THOSE
AREAS THEY'RE IDENTIFIED
STRATEGIES.
RESOURCES IN PARTICULAR HOW
WE'RE GOING TO ATTACK EACH OF
THOSE AREAS WERE MEASURING WE
DEVELOP MEASUREMENTS AND WE WILL
BE BASHING THOSE QUARTERLY.
SO WE CONSIDER THE IMPACT THAT
WE'RE GOING TO BE ABLE TO SO WE
CAN HELP --
NOT JUST WITH STAFF WILL AS WELL
AS MAYBE SOME PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT OR OTHER AREAS
WITHIN A HAVE A WHOLE I'M SO
SUGGESTED YOU GET INVOLVED IN
THE FISCAL SIDE SIDE AT ALL OR
TO KIND OF PICK IT BACK UP MR
O'DONNELL'S QUESTION.
OR IS THAT IS THAT STRICTLY WHAT
FIFTH MAN DOES.
IT IT'S REALLY THICK MATS ROLE
IN THE COUNTY OFFICES ROLE BUT
YOU CAN'T TALK ABOUT ONE WITHOUT
THE OTHER.
AND THAT'S WHAT'S I THINK UNIQUE
ABOUT EIGHTEEN FORTY IS A PUTS
US BOTH AT THE TABLE SO WE MEET
WITH THE MONTHLY.
FIXED BATS AT THE TABLE THE
COUNTY OFFICES AT THE TABLE
CITIES AT THE TABLE AND WERE AT
THE TABLE AND WE'RE ALL HAVING
CONVERSATIONS AND UPDATING AND
EACH OTHER ON WHERE WE'RE AT IN
REGARDS.
TO WHAT'S HAPPENING BOTH
PHYSICALLY AND ACADEMICALLY.
BECAUSE ONE OF MY MORE MORE
GLOBAL CONCERNS JUST WATCHING ON
SOME OF THE STRIKES PLAY OUT IS.
HOW?
ON MANY DISTRICTS ARE SORT OF ON
THE EDGE IT IS JUST TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT WHAT THE RIGHT.
SOLUTION TO CREATE THAT
STABILITY FOR THEM IS --
BECAUSE IT SEEMS --
RATHER THAN.
THE RATHER THAN THE BAR'S ANY
FOR THIS TO PRETEND IT SORT OF
MAKING THESE VERY DIFFICULT
DECISIONS THEY SEEM TO BE.
YOU KNOW LOOKING TOWARDS US FOR
MORE MONEY --
WHICH AGAIN AS I THINK IT'S KIND
OF A POLITICAL PLOY GOOD
POLITICAL POINT BUT NOT REALLY --
SOMETHING THAT'S GROUNDED IN
REALITY.
SO WHICH I GUESS IS ESPECIALLY
FOR THE DISTRICT FOR YOUR I MEAN
IN THAT OAKLAND'S.
OPEN SIX APPLE ONE OF THEM RIGHT
YOUR THAT YOUR WORK WAS HOW DOES
HOW DO YOU --
HOW DO YOU PROVIDE THE
OPPORTUNITY? FOR FOR FOLKS TO
SORT OF WHAT LAY THE GROUNDWORK
FOR FOLKS TO MAKE THOSE
DIFFICULT DECISIONS.
HELLO WANTED THINGS I THINK
BULLARD.
AGAIN MY WORKERS ON THE ACADEMIC
SIDE SO I COULD SPEAK MORE
DIRECTLY TO THAT I WAS A COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENT RIGHT AND SO IS A
COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT FOR MANY
YEARS I CAN TELL YOU.
WHEN WE HAD DISTRICTS THAT
REALLY STRUGGLED?
THERE WERE DECISIONS THAT THEY
SHOULD HAVE MADE SOONER.
RIGHT AND SO IN PARTICULAR WE
WOULD WE WOULD FIND DISTRICTS
WHO WERE DECLINING ENROLLMENT
AND MAYBE WE'RE NOT REACTING
QUICK ENOUGH SO FOR EXAMPLE
YOU'LL SEE SCHOOL CLOSURES WHICH
IS VERY DIFFICULT.
TO BUT IF YOU LOOK AT THE SCHOOL
COOL YOU LOOK AT HOW MANY
EXISTENCE SOME OF THOSE
DISTRICTS LIKE.
OAKLAND IN LIKE IN THE LATE HOLE
MOST OF THE SAME SCHOOLS ARE
STILL OPEN.
RIGHT WOULD SEVEN OR EIGHT
THOUSAND STUDENTS.
IT'S A VERY DIFFICULT THING TO
DO COMMUNITY DOESN'T LIKE IT FOR
ITS I'VE DONE IT MYSELF --
BUT THAT'S AN EXAMPLE TO WEAR
THE SOONER YOU CAN REACT TO MAKE
SOME OF THOSE DECISIONS IT HELPS
GOING DOWN.
DOWN THE ROAD THE THING I CAN
TELL YOU ON THE ACADEMIC PIECES
IS THAT.
I THINK I MENTIONED TO THERE ARE
A LOT OF RESOURCES EVEN IN THE
SCHOOLS BUT THERE'S NO COHERENCE
TO IT.
AND SO ONE OF THINGS THAT WE'RE
TRYING TO SAY IS WITH THE
RESOURCES THAT YOU DO HAVE.
MANY OF MY HAVE INSTRUCTIONAL
COACHES FOR EXAMPLE HOW CAN WE
MAKE SURE THAT THE INSTRUCTIONAL
COULDN'T WE'RE GETTING THE MOST
OUT OF THOSE INSTRUCTIONAL
COACHES.
HOW CAN WE MAKE SURE THAT TRYING
TO BE MORE SYSTEMIC ACROSS THE
DISTRICT AND OW WE'RE DOING
THAT WORKS AT LEAST WE GET THE
BEST BANG FOR OUR BUCK WITH THE
MONEY SAID?
THAT CONTINUE TO EXIST.
THIS SERVICE IS NOT A SINGLE
OAKLAND OPERATE SORT OF TOP OF
MIND SINCE IT'S BEEN THERE IN
THE PRESS MOST OF OUR FLIGHT --
YOU'D MENTIONED THAT THE THE
SCHOOL CLOSURE SHOW AND I FORGOT
THIRD THE RESOLUTION TO DATE
OAKLAND OAKLAND HAD A FAIRLY --
FOR THE WELL LAID OUT PLAN
AROUND SCHOOL CLOSURES AND MY
AND MY RECOLLECTION AND AND
FORGIVE ME IF I REMEMBER
RECOLLECTING CORRECTLY BUT THAT
THEY PUNTED ON THAT ISSUE
[inaudible]
AND SO.IS THAT ONE IS THAT CORRECT IN
THE TO WIN WIN TO PUT A DISTRICT
AND WITH YOU KNOW UNDER YOUR
GUIDANCE IS DOING THAT HOW DO
YOU.
GET THEM TO THE BACK ON THE
CONTRACT.
WELL A COUPLE THINGS ABOUT THAT
DISTRICT GUIDE I BELIEVE THAT
THEY WERE MORE IN THE MIX TO
LOOK AFTER THEY HAD ALREADY MADE
SOME DECISIONS ON SCHOOL
CLOSURES THAT THEY ARE GOING
THROUGH WITH THIS YEAR --
TO I THINK THE OTHER ONE THAT
THEY'VE LOOKED AT EVEN THE ONES
THAT THEY WERE TALKING ABOUT
WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN NEXT YEAR
BECAUSE IT TAKES SOME TIME TO SO
I THINK THEY JUST AGREED FOR
THIS NEXT FOUR MONTHS OF FUN.
AGAIN MISTER A TO FIND FROM FAKE
NAKED -- BUT
CLEARLY IN OUR WORK.
AS I MENTIONED IN INGLEWOOD SO
GREAT EXAMPLE OF THOSE FIVE
AREAS ONE OF THOSE FACILITIES
WERE IT WAS SPECIFICALLY LOOKING
AT FACILITIES AND SAYING OKAY.
HOW MANY FACILITIES YOU HAVE?
WHICH ONES DO WE NEED TO LOOK AT
THE YOU KNOW WE NEED TO LOOK AT
SCHOOL CLOSURES CAN BE LOOK AT
SELLING SOME OF THOSE OTHER
FACILITIES.
OTHER WAYS BECAUSE FACILITIES
ARE A LARGE COSTS SO THAT IS IN
THE PLAN THAT IS PART OF THE
DISCUSSION AGAIN WHICH I THINK
IS UNIQUE.
ABOUT EIGHTEEN FORTY THIS IS A
PUTS US AT THE TABLE WITH ON THE
FISCAL AND ACADEMIC SIDE.
GREAT DID I TALK ABOUT LOOK AT
THE STATE BORDERDEPARTMENT OF
THAT KIND OF CHOMPING AT THE BIT
TO HAVE ANY YOU WANT TO ADD TO
THIS OR NOT OKAY NOW --
JUST [inaudible]
TO SELECT.
YES -- GO
STRAIGHT BACK HERE OR NOT.
THIS FIGURE OUT ONE COME UPPER
THEY'RE GONNA ACT ACTUALLY
PRESENTING ACTION OTHER PERCENT
NOT SMOKE WELCOME BACK FOR THAT
THANK YOU.
BUT HE HAS JUMPED ON THE BED I
CAN SEE ABOUT --
IT JUST JUST --
JUST A QUICK.
QUESTION TO BOTH THE THE STATE
BOARD IN THAT DEPARTMENT OF AND
IN TERMS OF THE TRANSPARENCY
MEASURES REALLY THANK YOU FOR
SOARED HIGHLIGHTING THAT MISTER
MISTER SAP.
WE APPRECIATE IT ALSO JUST A
COMMENT ON THE DASHBOARD THE
DASHBOARD LOOKS.
I THINK --
VERY GOOD MUCH MUCH BETTER THAN
THE I GUESS VERSION ONE POINT OH
IF THE ALL CAPS I THINK IT'S A
REALLY GREAT STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION REALLY APPRECIATE THAT.
BUT JUST WANTED TO SEE HOW P. T.
A.'S OR IS IT --
YOU KNOW LOCAL COMMUNITY GROUPS
OR JUST RANDOM PARENTS HOW HOW
IT THE INFORMATION IS BEING
DIGEST.
SO ALL START ON THAT THE LOCAL
ACCOUNTABILITY PLAN PUT PIECES
BUT MISS BECAUSE HONEST MAY HAVE
SOMETHING MORE THE DASHBOARD
BECAUSE THEY ARE VERY CLOSELY
RELATED AND I THINK
COMPLEMENTARY --
THAT BUDGET SUMMARY FOR PARENTS
IS YET BEING ADOPTED LOCALLY FOR
THE FIRST TIME THIS COMING BY
JULY FIRST OF THIS COMING YEAR
SO AS FAR AS HOW IT'S BEING USED
LOCALLY AND HOW PEOPLE ARE
REACTING TO IT LOCALLY AND
SPECIFIC EXAMPLES WE REALLY
DON'T HAVE.
MUCH INFORMATION ON THAT WE HAVE
GOTTEN AND THE DEPARTMENT
EDUCATION REALLY TOOK THE LEAD
ON DEVELOPING THE FORMAT FOR
THAT THERE WAS SOME CLEAR
GUIDANCE IN THE BILLING WHICH
FROM LAST YEAR --
BUT GETTING SOME FEEDBACK FROM
FROM DIFFERENT USERS AND I THINK.
UNIFORMLY IT'S BEEN GENERALLY
POSITIVE AS FAR AS THE THE RIGHT
GRAIN SIZES MAY BE HOW I WOULD
PUT IT AS FAR AS THAT ONE OF THE
LARGEST.
GUY CRITICISMS I GUESS I WOULD
PUT IT OF THE EL CAP A PRIOR TO
TWO YEARS AGO WAS IT WAS VERY
DIFFICULT TO UNDERSTAND HOW THE
ACTIONS AND SERVICES AND
EXPENDITURES PROPOSING THE ALL
CAPS.
FIT INTO THE ALLEY IS OVERALL
BUDGET THIS DOCUMENT THIS NEW
DOCUMENT KIND OF PULLS TOGETHER
IN ONE PLACE.
THAT CONNECTION TO THE LOCAL
BUDGET WHICH WAS KIND OF
INTENDED THAT THAT OUT THE LOCAL
COUNTY THE PLAN SUPPOSED TO BE.
SERVE THE OPERATIONAL PLAN FOR
IMPLEMENTING THE LIKELY ADOPTED
BUDGET IT REALLY BUILT THAT
LINKAGE BUT WITHOUT GOING IT
THAT'S A HUNDRED TWENTY PAGE
DOCUMENT LIKE IT'S NOT REALISTIC
THAT ANYONE.
NORMAL PERSON IS GOING TO DIG
INTO THAT SO THIS IS A THREE
PAGE DOCUMENT THAT REALLY GIVES
THOSE HIGH LEVEL SUMMARIES
OVERALL BUDGET PICTURE WHAT'S IN
THE EL CAP.
AND WHAT'S TIED TO INCREASE
IMPROVE SERVICES FOR HIGH NEED
STUDENTS.
AS WELL AS AN UPDATE ON WHAT WAS
PROPOSED IN THE PRIOR YEAR FOR
INCREASED IMPROVE SERVICES WHAT
HAPPENED WITH THIS.
YEAH WAS IT DID YOU DO WHAT YOU
SAID YOU WERE GOING TO DO SO IN
GENERAL AS FAR AS LIKE THOSE KEY
TOPICS I THINK WE'VE GOTTEN
GENERALLY BUT IT'S NOT FROM THE
END USER.
WHICH IS REALLY PARENTS SO I
THINK WE'LL LEARN A LOT MORE
AFTER THIS SORT OF CYCLE COMES
AROUND.
ON THE BRIGHTER UPDATES TO THE
LOCAL ACCOUNTABILITY PLAN --
THAT IS FOR THAN THE UPCOMING EL
CAPITAN OPTION NOT THE ONE RIGHT
NOW BUT FOR THE NEXTEL CAP THE
BOARD'S ACTUALLY CAN BE.
ADOPTING THE NEW TEMPLATE WE'RE
HOPING BY NOVEMBER.
OF THIS YEAR AND SO WE'VE
ALREADY STARTED OUR COLLEAGUES
AT THE DEPARTMENT OF RESERVED
TIME TO DO THAT BIG STAKEHOLDER
PROCESS.
ON SOME OF THE KEY AGAIN THE
STATURE LANGUAGE WAS.
VERY SPECIFIC IN SOME REGARDS SO
THERE ISN'T A GREAT DEAL OF
DISCRETION ON SOME PIECES BUT TO
TRY TO GET FEEDBACK AND SOME OF
THOSE KEY DESIGN CHOICES THAT
THE BOARD WILL HAVE TO MAKE.
AS FAR AS HOW TO MAKE THIS
INFORMATION AS YOU TRY TO GET IT
I THINK THE ISSUE WAS HOW LONG
THE DOCUMENT IS.
SOME OF THAT ISN'T SOLVABLE
COMPLETELY BUT THERE MAY BE SOME
WAYS THAT WE CAN REALLY TRY TO
MAKE IT MORE DIGESTIBLE DOCUMENT.
EVEN IF THE OVERALL DOCUMENT
STILL HAS SOME LENGTH YOU CAN
PULL OUT MAYBE SEVEN EIGHT PAGES.
THEY GIVE A FULLPICTURE OF
WHAT'S BEEN SORT OF ADOPTED AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL.
IT ENDED JUST STATE GUY AGAIN
YEAH THE STATUTORY LANGUAGE IS
REALLY OUR BASS FIRST FOR SHOT
AND FIRST GAS AT THE HELPFUL TO
GET FEEDBACK IF WE NEED TO MAKE.
CHANGES I THINK THERE'S SOME
INTEREST IN DOING THAT.
I AND ON THE DASHBOARD WE VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS --
WE DID ENGAGE IN A AS THE LARGE --
STAKEHOLDER INPUT SESSION.
NUMBER SESSIONS TO GET TO THE
POINT WE'RE AT TODAY I ON THE
TRANSPARENCY SIDE I I LIKE TO
THINK THAT IT'S WHEN YOU HAVE A
FORM OF IMITATION OTHER PEOPLE
ARE DOING A DASHBOARD LIGHT SO
WERE SEEN COUNTY OFFICES PICK UP
THE DATA THAT WE PUT.
PUBLISHED --
OF COURSE ON OUR WEBSITE IN THE
DASHBOARD SO I I I THINK WITH
JOSH FOR TWO POINT NOW I'M WE'VE
COME A LONG WAY IN IN AGAIN WE
APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT OF THAT
ADDITIONAL FUNDING TO MAKE IT
HAPPEN.
GREAT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I JUST ONE MORE
QUESTION FOR MISTER MOLINA WITH
REGARD TO CHARTER SCHOOLS.
I THINK YOU MENTIONED YOU DO A
SYSTEM AS WELL DO THEY GO DO
THEY GO TO THE COUNTY FIRST
HOUSE HOW WOULD THAT LOOK BUT
WITH THAT WHATEVER THEY'RE NOT
IDENTIFIED YET NEXT YEAR WILL BE
THE FIRST YEAR --
IDENTIFIED IN THE DASHBOARD SO
WE HAVE DONE SOME WORK WITH THEM
AND NOT SPECIFICALLY RUN
DIFFERENCE IN ASSISTANCE.
THANK YOU SIR THANK YOU
[inaudible]
FOR YEAH.
NEXT WE'LL HEAR FROM MICHAEL
FIND FROM A FAKE MATT.
AND IF YOU COULD PLEASE I KNOW
YOU HAVE YOUR I'M SURE YOU HAVE
YOUR PREPARED REMARKS BUT ALSO
IF YOU COULD.
MAYBE GIVE US A GLIMPSE OF
WHAT'S GOING ON OUT THERE TALK
ABOUT THE REAL WORLD TODAY --
AND HOW YOU MIGHT BE INTERACTING
WITH THOSE DISTRICTS THAT MIGHT
NOT EVEN BE IN FULL CRISIS MODE
YET.
WHAT ROLE YOU MIGHT PLATE SETTER?
GOOD MORNING MIKE FINE CHIEF
EXECUTIVE OFFICER OF THE STATE'S
FISCAL CRISIS MANAGEMENT
ASSISTANCE TEAM.
MATCH -- MY
OUTLINE IS COMING AROUND TO YOU
AND I THINK --
MISTER CHAIR IT WILL --
RELEASED THE FIRST SECTION GIVE
YOU A A GOOD FLAVOR OF WHERE
THINGS ARE APT AT LEAST THROUGH
DECEMBER.
AND I'LL WALK YOU THROUGH THOSE
IT'S QUITE A BIT OF DATA HERE --
I'LL BE QUICK --
BECAUSE I I KNOW THAT THE
COMMITTEE HAS QUESTIONS AND AND
THAT MAYBE THE MORE PIECE OF OF
MY TIME THIS MORNING.
FIRST THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE --
SCHOOL DISTRICT GIVE US
STABILITY IS MEASURED THROUGH --
WHAT WE GENERALLY REFER TO AS
THE A. B. TWELVE HUNDRED PROCESS
SAYS THE COMMITTEES WILL WHERE --
WHILE THAT STARTED IN. NINETEEN
NINETY ONE WITH THE PASSAGE OF
AB TWELVE HUNDRED THERE'S BEEN
FORTY PLUS PIECES OF LEGISLATION
SINCE THAT TWEAK IT IN SOME
FASHION WE STILL REFERRED TO
THAT OVERALL PROCESS IS THE AB
TWELVE HUNDRED PROCESS.
INTER COAL IN THAT PROCESS IS
THE EARLY WARNING SYSTEM --
WERE DISTRICTS SUBMIT THEIR
BUDGETS TO THE COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENT OF THE AND COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENTS CONSIDER
APPROVING APPROVING WITH
CONDITIONS ARE DISAPPROVING THE
BUDGET THAT HAPPENS EACH SUMMER --
AND THEN THERE'S A MINIMUM AT
LEAST TO UPDATE TO THAT BUDGET --
FIRST IN ROOM WHICH IS DATA
THROUGH OCTOBER DONE IN DECEMBER.
AND SECOND IN ARM DATA THROUGH
JANUARY I DONE IN MARCH.
AND THE DATA THAT I'M PRESENTING
TO THIS COMMITTEE IS THROUGH
FIRST IN ROME BECAUSE SECOND
INTERIM DATA ISN'T DUE UNTIL --
TELL FRIDAY OF THIS WEEK AND SO
WE'RE JUST TIMING OF THE HEARING
THIS.
IS JUST A SLIGHTLY OFF FROM
BEING ABLE TO REPORT ON SECOND
IN A ROOM --
SO FIRST IN A ROOM IN ALL ALL
SPEAK IN GENERALITIES ABOUT
IMPLICATIONS SECOND AND ARMY
HAVE THAT FIRST IN A ROOM --
AND THERE YOU HAVE IN YOUR STAFF
REPORT PLUS IN THE MATERIAL I
JUST GAVE YOU A DETAILS OF OF
ALL OF THIS BUT WE HAVE THIRTY
NINE QUALIFIED SELF
CERTIFICATIONS --
I I SHOULD PAUSE AND REMIND YOU
THAT SCHOOL DISTRICTS SELF
CERTIFY THEIR FIRST THEIR IN
ARMOR PORTS AS POSITIVE MEANING --
THEY CAN MEET THEIR FINANCIAL
CURRENT PLUS TWO ADDITIONAL
YEARS.
QUALIFIED WHICH MEANS THEY MAY
NOT MEET THEIR OBLIGATIONS IN
THE CURRENT IN TWO SUBSEQUENT
YEARS IN NEGATIVE WHICH MEANS
THEY WILL NOT MEET THEIR
OBLIGATIONS IN AND EITHER THE
CURRENT FOR SINGLE SUBSEQUENT
YEAR -- AND
SO IT'S THE COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENTS JOB --
AS THE ANALYZE AND EVALUATE
THOSE INTO REPORTS TO CONCUR OR
NOT CONCUR --
WITH THAT CERTIFICATION AND SO
YOU'LL AS ALL SPEAK TO IN JUST A
SECOND COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT CAN
CHANGE THATCERTIFICATION ASK
HIM THE CD --
SO THERE WERE --
THIRTY NINE SELF QUALIFIED SELF
CERTIFICATIONS AT FIRST IN A
ROOM.
IN ADDITION THE COUNTY THREE
COUNTY OFFICES DOWNGRADED THREE
DISTRICTS FROM POSITIVE TO
QUALIFY TO HAVE A TOTAL OF FORTY
TWO QUALIFIED.
DISTRICTS AT FIRST INTERIM
INTERESTS ENOUGH THAT'S THE
EXACT NUMBER THAT WE HAD A YEAR
AGO AT FIRST DETERMINES WELL --
THE THREE COUNTY OFFICE
DOWNGRADES --
I INCLUDE ONE IN MARIN BUT ONE
ALAMEDA WHICH IS OAKLAND --
AND ONE IN RIVERSIDE.
THERE WERE FOUR NEGATIVE SELF
CERTIFICATIONS WHICH ARE THE
SAME NUMBER THAT WE HAD A YEAR
AGO --
HOWEVER AS I'VE SPOKEN THIS
COMMITTEE IN THE PAST THE THE
BEAUTY OF AB TWELVE HUNDRED YES
THAT IT'S ACTUALLY SYSTEM THAT
WORKS AND GENERALLY SPEAKING
WORKS REALLY WELL.
WE HAVE A DISTRICT THAT GETS ALL
THE WAY TO THE NEGATIVE --
CERTIFICATION --
STATUS --
THERE ARE NUMEROUS INTERVENTION
RESOURCES AVAILABLE TO THAT
DISTRICT AND SELDOM DO THEY STAY
ON THE NEGATIVE LISTS MORE THAN
ONE REPORTING PERIOD.
AND SO ALL THE NUMBERS THE SAME
AS LAST --
DISTRICTS --
ON THE NEGATIVE LIST ARE
DIFFERENT --
AND ONE I WILL SPEAK TO IT'S
BEEN ON THE NEGATIVE LIST
ACTUALLY FOR SEVERAL YEARS AND
AND WE'RE GETTING TO THE END OF
OUT.
THE THREE NEW ANSWER SACRAMENTO
CITY SOUTHERN KERN IN SWEETWATER
UNION -- IN
SAN DIEGO. ONE IS CONTINUING
WHICH IS FEATHER FALLS UNION
ELEMENTARY YOU WILL SEE FEATHER
FALL SHOW UP SEVERAL TIMES IN MY
REPORT --
NOT TO BE ALARMED THIS IS A
SINGLE DISTRICT SCHOOL BY SINGLE
SCHOOL DISTRICT.
IN BUTTE COUNTY WITH TEN K. A
WITH TEN STUDENTS FIVE OF WHICH
ARE IN THE EIGHTH GRADE IF THEY
BET ON THE NEGATIVE LIST NOW FOR
MULTIPLE YEARS.
ALL WITH THE GOAL TO GET.
HALF OF THEIR STUDENTS WHICH ARE
ALL IN THE SAME GRADE --
THROUGH PROMOTION THROUGH EIGHTH
GRADE PROMOTION THIS JUNE.
AT WHICH POINT IN TIME IN
NEIGHBORING THE PLAN IS THAT A
NEIGHBORING DISTRICT WILL BEGIN
TO SERVE THE REMAINING.
STUDENTS IN THAT SCHOOL DISTRICT
WILL BASICALLY CEASE TO OPERATE
SO THERE'S THEY ARE NOT ON OUR
RADAR SCREEN WITH RESPECT TO
ANTICIPATED INTERVENTION.
NEEDED BY --
THE STATE THE COUNTY HAS BEEN
ASSISTING THEM FINANCIALLY --
BUT THIS IS THIS IS BEEN DRAWN
OUT REALLY SO THAT WE COULD
ADEQUATELY SERVE --
FIVE OF THEIR TENTS PROMOTION IT
AT EIGHTH GRADE WHEN THEY WOULD
HAVE MOVED ON TO THE HIGH SCHOOL
DISTRICT.
WE HAVE ONE LACK OF GOING
CONCERN DISTRICT --
THIS IS EQUIVALENT TO A NEGATIVE
CERTIFICATION HOWEVER --
THIS IS WHERE THE COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENT CAN MOVE A
DISTRICT TO THAT STATUS AT ANY
TIME DURING THE YEAR NOT JUST OF
THE INTERIM REPORTING --
BUDGET REPORTING STAFF --
TIME PERIODS BUT AT ANY TIME
THIS WAS ACTUALLY DONE IN
NOVEMBER THIS IS ALBERT UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT IN RIVERSIDE
COUNTY.
WE ALSO HAVE IN THE SYSTEM SHOW
UP VERY OFTEN BUT WE HAVE ONE
NEGATIVE CERTIFICATION FOR A
COUNTY OFFICE AMADOR COUNTY
OFFICE.
OF THE DID SUBMIT QUALIFIED --
THE DEPARTMENT OF ED IS THE
OVERSIGHT AGENCY FOR COUNTY
OFFICES AND THEY DOWNGRADED THEM.
TO A NEGATIVE THIS IS A SINGLE
DISTRICT COUNTY SO AMADOR
UNIFIED AMADOR COUNTY THEY ARE
CLOSELY LINKED COMMON BOARD.
AS OF JANUARY THEY HAVE TWO
DIFFERENT SUPERINTENDENTS THOUGH
THEY HAVE FOR THE MOST RECENT
PERIOD TIME AN OPERATING WITH A
SINGLE SUPERINTENDENT.
OF BOTH --
BUT NOW OF THROUGH THE THE
ELECTION PROCESS --
THERE'S A NEW COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENT THAT'S DIFFERENT
THAN THE DISTRICT SUPERINTENDENT --
THE DISTRICT ITSELF MOVING IN A
POSITIVE DIRECTION THE COUNTIES
MOVING IN AN OPPOSITE DIRECTION --
AN INTERVENTION.
WE JUST HAD A TEAM THERE WILL BE
ISSUED A REPORT --
ON THAT --
SINGLE ENTITY OF THE COUNTY
DISTRICT COME HERE AND IN THE
NEXT WEEK OR SO.
I GIVES YOU A OF FLAVOR WHAT'S
OUT THERE VERY SIMILAR NUMBER
WISE TO LAST YEAR --
HOWEVER SOME OF THE DISTRICTS
THAT ARE ON THE LIST --
ARE ARE DIFFERENT --
BOTH IN --
SIZE AND MAGNITUDE.
ARMED WITH RESPECT TO THEIR
ISSUES THAT THEY'RE FACING A
WILL CERTAINLY --
CAN CAN DIG INTO SOME OF THAT --
AS WE MOVE FORWARD.
AS THE COMMITTEE IS AWARE THE
CURRENT YEAR'S BUDGET ACT --
PROVIDED THAT VIC MATCH MORE --
PROVIDE MORE PREVENT EVE --
ON A PROACTIVE BASIS --
INTERVENTION IN SCHOOL DISTRICTS
HISTORICALLY WE HAVE ONLY
INTERVENED IN A SCHOOL DISTRICT
WHEN ASKED TO COME INTO THE
DISTRICT BY THE DISTRICT FOR THE
COUNTY OFFICE OR ASKED TO GO
THERE BY --
THE ADMINISTRATION OR THE
LEGISLATURE IN SOME FASHION.
AND SO IN AN AGREEMENT WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IN THIS --
IDEA ABOUT BE MORE PROACTIVE WE
HAVE -- THIS
YEAR PRACTICED A NEW PROCESS
THAT WE CALL AUTOMATIC
ENGAGEMENT IN THAT AUTOMATIC
ENGAGEMENT BY US IS UNDER
CERTAIN TRIGGERS THOSE ARE
LISTED THERE DISAPPROVE BUDGET.
A NEGATIVE CERTIFICATION ON IN
ARMOR PORT THREE CONSECUTIVE
QUALIFIED --
CERTIFICATIONS A DOWNGRADE BY
EITHER THE COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT
OR THE DEPARTMENT OF ED OR A
LACK OF GOING CONCERN
DESIGNATION BY THE COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENT.
THE TOOL THAT WE USE WHEN WE GO
IN TO THE DISTRICT IS THE FISCAL
HEALTH RISK ANALYSIS IT'S A TOOL
WE DEVELOP MANY YEARS AGO.
WE'VE DONE SOME PRETTY EXTENSIVE
UPGRADES AND MODERNIZATION TO
THAT TOOL THIS PAST SUMMER AND
USED IT FOR THE FIRST TIME IN
THREE DISTRICTS IN THE FALL --
USE THE UPDATED TOOL FOR THE
FIRST TIME IN THREE DISTRICTS
THIS FALL.
THIS YEAR THERE WERE SIX
APPROACH DISAPPROVE BUDGETS
ACROSS THE STATE THAT'S UP FROM
TO THE PRIOR YEAR.
AND WE PERFORMED BY FISCAL RISK
HEALTH ANALYSIS IN THREE OF
THOSE CALAVERAS WHERE WE
DETERMINE THEIR RISK WAS
MODERATE SACRAMENTO CITY WHERE
WE DETERMINE THEIR RISK WAS HIGH.
SWEETWATER UNION --
IN SAN DIEGO COUNTY WHERE WE
DETERMINE THEIR RISK WAS HIGH AS
WELL.
AT FIRST IN A ROOM.
THERE ARE AS I'VE ALREADY
MENTIONED THERE ARE FOUR
NEGATIVE CERTIFICATIONS.
WE JUST PERFORMED FISCAL RISKY
HEALTH ANNOUNCES THAT TWO OF
THOSE SPECIFICALLY SACKS CITY
AND SWEET WATER JUST A COUPLE
MONTHS EARLIER AND SO THERE'S NO
NEED TO PERFORM THAT SAME STUDY
AGAIN. TWO OF THE OTHERS WE ARE
MONITORING ONE OF THOSE A
SOUTHERN KERN AND THE OTHER AS
I'VE ALREADY MENTIONED IS
FEATHER FALLS WHICH AT THIS
POINT WE WOULDN'T DESCRIBE.
WHETHER WHETHER QUALIFY FOR
NEGATIVE THEY'RE THEY'RE NOT
THEY HAVE A PLAN TO ACCEPT OUT
OF NEXT FISCAL YEAR.
SOUTHERN KERN --
CURRENTLY HAS A LOAN OTHERWISE
IT WOULD HAVE ALREADY BEEN TO
THE LEGISLATURE AS AN INSOLVENT
DISTRICT --
REQUIRING AN EMERGENCY
PREPARATION IT'S COUNTY OFFICES
STEPPED IN TO PROVIDE IT THE
CASH RESOURCES.
THAT IT NEEDS WHILE YET --
RECTIFY ITS CURRENT SITUATION.
WE HAVE THREE CONSECUTIVE
QUALIFIED CERTIFICATION I'M
SORRY OF THE THREE CONCERT WELL
THAT'S NOT COMING OUT RIGHT AT
ALL THE OTHER ANOTHER TRIGGER IS
THREE CONSECUTIVE QUALIFIED
CERTIFICATIONS WE HAVE SIX OF
THOSE.
WE HAVE SCHEDULED TO VISIT THREE
OF THOSE DISTRICTS --
COACHELLA VALLEY IN RIVERSIDE
COUNTY CLIMATE TRINITY AND
HUMBOLDT OCEANSIDE IN SAN DIEGO.
CAN WE ARE MONITORING --
THREE BUT WE HAVE NOT SCHEDULED
THOSE REVIEWS THOSE INCLUDE GOLD
TRAIL UNION IN EL DORADO.
IN CASCADE UNION AND GATEWAY
BOTH IN SHASTA COUNTY.
WE ARE --
USING OUR DISCRETION NOT JUST
FOLLOWING EXACTLY THE TRIGGER IF
YOU WILL --
WE ARE IN COMMUNICATION BOTH
WITH THE DISTRICT AND IT'S
COUNTY OFFICE TO SAY --
WHILE THEY'VE MET THE TRIGGER --
IF WE COME IN AND DO THIS STUDY
DO WE REALLY THINK IT'S GOING TO
ADD VALUE WHAT IS WHAT ARE THE
DRIVING --
FORCES IF CURRENT DISTRESS --
AND WILL THIS TOOL HELP THEM --
BE A A POSITIVE INTERVENTION
FORM AND WHERE WE HAVEN'T FELT
THAT WAS GOING TO BE THE CASE
WE'RE NOT TAKING THE TIME WERE.
THERE'S OTHER INTERVENTIONS THAT
ARE AVAILABLE TO THEM AND WE'RE
MONITORING THEM IN THAT REGARD.
AS I MENTIONED WE HAVE ONE LACK
A GOING CONCERN ALFORD UNIFIED
RIVERSIDE COUNTY --
AND WITH THEIR FISCAL HEALTH
RISK ANALYSIS IS ALSO SCHEDULED
HERE IN THE COMING WEEKS --
THE THREE DOWNGRADED --
DISTRICTS --
ALL OF THOSE ARE BEING MONITORED --
AS YOU'RE WELL AWARE IN THE CASE
OF OAKLAND --
WE ACTUALLY DID A FISCAL HEALTH
RISK ANALYSIS THEIR YEAR AND A
HALF AGO --
WE'VE BEEN INVOLVED IN OAKLAND
ON A DAILY BASIS --
FOR THE LAST --
CERTAINLY EIGHT MONTHS AND WELL
REALLY ALMOST OVER A YEAR NOW --
TRULY OF HAD A MEMBER OF PRESENT
IN THE DISTRICT CAN ALL SPEAK TO
THEM MORE.
MORE DIRECTLY --
IN THE NEXT SECTION.
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTEEN FORTY IS
THE COMMITTEE SO WHERE WAS
BUDGET TRAILER BILL LAST AUGUST
IT INCLUDED --
SOME POLICY CHANGES WHICH CHANGE
THE LONG STANDING --
PROCESS ON HOW --
A DISTRICT.
THE IS ADMINISTERED ONCE IT
COMES TO THE LEGISLATURE --
FOR AN EMERGENCY APPROPRIATION
PREVIOUSLY --
HE GOVERNING AUTHORITY ALL THE
RIGHTS AND DUTIES OF THE
GOVERNING BOARD WERE SHIFTED --
TO THE STATE SUPERINTENDENT ONCE.
THE STATE --
A GRANTED AN EMERGENCY
APPROPRIATION UNDER EIGHTEEN
FORTY THOSE RIGHTS AND DUTIES
ARE SHIFTED TO THE COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENT.
IT'S THE COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT
IN --
CONCERT WITH THE STATE
SUPERINTENDENT IN THE BOARD OF
THE PRESIDENT OF THE BOARD STATE
BOARD OF EDUCATION THAT NOW
APPOINT TO STATE ADMINISTRATOR
STATE TRUSTEE WHATEVER'S
WARRANTED.
ON A AND IT'S THE COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENT THE ON A DAILY
BASIS AND INTERACTS WITH THE
DISTRICT ON A DAILY BASIS.
THE FIRST ARE REQUIRED REPORTING
UNDER EIGHTEEN FORTY WAS LAST
FRIDAY MARCH FOR IT WILL NOT
LAST FRIDAY THE FRIDAY BEFORE
MARCH FIRST AND WE DID ISSUE TWO
LETTERS --
ONE FOR OAKLAND ONE FOR
INGLEWOOD --
INC IN --
COMPLIANCE WITH THAT REQUIREMENT --
IN INGLEWOOD I THINK IS A STORY
AND YOU HEARD --
TOM R. MOLINA SPEAK TO IT OF A
FEW MINUTES AGO IN INGLEWOOD WE
HAVE A SUCCESS STORY REALLY
UNDER EIGHTEEN FORTY I WOULD
DESCRIBING THE WOOD IS.
HAVING MADE MOREPROGRESS IN THE
LAST -- SIX
MONTHS UNDER THE COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENTS DALY DIRECTION
THAN THEY MADE IN QUITE A BIT OF
TIME UNDER THE PREVIOUS STATE
SUPERINTENDENT'S --
DALY DIRECTION --
THIS IS --
I'VE I I MENTIONED WE MENTIONED
IN OUR REPORT ISSUED ON MARCH
FIRST THAT WHILE THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT OF SCHOOLS
DID NOT ASK FOR EIGHTEEN FORTY
IN FACT PROBABLY WOULD HAVE.
ADVOCATED AGAINST IT ONCE IT WAS
PASSED IN THOSE DUTIES WERE
ASSIGNED TO HER SHE FULLY
EMBRACE THEM BUSINESS MADE A
TREMENDOUS INVESTMENT OF STAFF.
IN LEADERSHIP AND TIME --
IN HELPING INGLEWOOD AND THAT
PROCESS IS ACTUALLY GOING VERY
WELL WE ARE CURRENTLY ESTIMATING
THEIR DEFICIT THAT IS SUBJECT TO
THE EIGHTEEN FORTY AID AS
ROUGHLY ONE POINT THREE THE
MINOR.
NUMBER --
WITH RESPECT TO OAKLAND --
I WOULD SAY PROCESSES AS NOTED
HERE PROGRESS HAS BEEN
INCONSISTENT THE COUNTY OFFICE
AGAIN FOR BY HAS EMBRACED THEIR
ROLE IN EIGHTEEN FORTY IT IS
DIFFERENT IN THOSE TWO DISTRICTS
WERE OFTEN LUMP THEM TOGETHER
AND LOTS OF DISCUSSIONS.
BUT THEY'RE VERY DIFFERENT
REMEMBER THAT ANGLE WOULD --
HAS BEEN THROUGH THIS PROCESS
NOW FOR SIX YEARS AND IS
ACTUALLY GOVERNED BY A STATE
ADMINISTRATOR NOW REPORTING TO
THE COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT.
OAKLAND GOES ALL THE WAY BACK TO
TWO THOUSAND THREE WENT THROUGH
THAT INTENSE RECOVERY PROCESS
WERE CERTIFIED IS RECOVERED
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS A FORTY WAS
RETURNED TO THEM FOR OVER A
DECADE.
AND THEN QUESTIONS BEGAN TO
SURFACE LAST YEAR ABOUT THEIR
FISCAL STATUS.
ARM AND SO THEY HAVE A TRUSTEE
IN PLACE BUT THERE LOCAL BOARD --
IS GOVERNING THE DISTRICT AND
THEY HAVE A SUPERINTENDENT IN
PLACE HIRED BY THAT LOCAL BOARD.
HE'S A TEACHER JUST COULD YOU
TELL.
EXPLAIN WHY.
WHY THERE'D BE A A TRUSTEE THERE
IN THE LOCAL MORE WOULD RETAIN?-SO THAT IS THE LONG ESTABLISHED
PROCESS THE STATE UNTIL THEY PAY
OFF THEIR LOAN THE STATE CLEARLY
HAS AN INTEREST IN THEIR FISCAL
STABILITY BECAUSE IN OAKLAND
CASE THEY NEED TO MAKE IT EIGHT
MILLION PLUS.
PAYMENT EACH YEAR TO THE STATE --
A COMBINATION OF STATE GENERAL
FUND LOAN AND I BANK LOAN --
AND SO IT'S IN THE STATE'S
INTEREST --
TO HAVE A TRUSTY IN PLACE IT HAS
STAINED RESCIND AUTHORITY SHOULD
THE DISTRICTS DEVIATE FROM ITS
FINANCIAL STABILITY PLAN --
AND THEREFORE PUT THAT LOAN
PAYMENT AT JEOPARDY IN JEOPARDY --
AND SO THAT'S REALLY THE
DISTINCTION --
GOVERNANCE LEADERSHIP --
IN OTHER DISTRICTS CERTAINLY
CONTINUE TO HAVE DEFICIENCIES --
DATA LACKS CREDIBILITY --
WE AS AN ORGANIZATION --
THERE ON ON ALMOST A DAILY BASIS
IN SOME FASHION --
DO BELIEVE THAT THEY HAVE THE
ABILITY TO GET THEMSELVES OUT OF
THIS CURRENT --
FISCAL DISTRESS WITHOUT
ADDITIONAL AID HOWEVER WE HAVE
ESTIMATED --
FOR EIGHTEEN FORTY PURPOSES THAT
THEY'RE PROJECTED DEFICIT FOR
NEXT YEAR IS SEVEN POINT SIX
MILLION DOLLARS --
THIS PROJECTION IS BEFORE THEY
SETTLED THEIR MOST RECENT.
LABOR --
NEGOTIATIONS AND BEFORE THEIR
BOARD ADOPTED BUDGET REDUCTIONS --
THEIR SETTLEMENT CAME EVENING ON
THE DAY BEFORE OUR REPORT WAS
DUE -- AND
THEY'RE BUDGET ADJUSTMENTS
ADOPTED BY THE BOARD --
CAME THE WEEK THE THE FOLLOWING
WEEK AND SO WITH THE CONCURRENCE
OF THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WE
WILL RE ISSUE ARE MARCH FIRST.
LETTER ON OAKLAND I'M IN THE
COMING WEEKS --
TO REFLECT OF BOTH OF THOSE
SIGNIFICANT ADVANCE AN UPDATE
THIS DEFICIT CALCULATION.
SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN ARM.
WITH FISCAL EMERGENCIES
OBVIOUSLY INGLEWOOD WE'VE
MENTIONED WELL WE'VE JUST
STARTED THE SEVENTH
COMPREHENSIVE REVIEW --
AS THE COMMITTEES AWARE WHEN A
DISTRICT IS.
BEFORE THEY RECOVER --
FIX MATT DOES AN ANNUAL
COMPREHENSIVE REVIEW YOU HEARD A
LITTLE BIT OF THAT REFERRED TO
AND IN THE COMMENTS ON THE PANEL
BEFORE ME --
WE LOOK AT UNDER CODE WE LOOK AT
FIVE AREAS STUDENT ACHIEVEMENT
WHICH YOU TALKED WITH THE PANEL
BEFORE ME ABOUT.
OF FISCAL MATTERS FACILITY
MATTERS HUMAN RESOURCE MATTERS
AND THEN A COMBINATION OF
GOVERNANCE AND COMMUNITY
RELATIONS MATTERS.
AND WE ISSUE REPORTS THERE ARE
HUNDREDS OF PAGES LONG WITH
HUNDREDS OF RECOMMENDATIONS IN
IT.
A WE JUST BEGAN THE WORK FOR THE
SEVEN BEGIN LAST WEEK --
AS WE TACKLE THE AREA OF
GOVERNANCE.
SWEETWATER UNION HIGH SCHOOL
DISTRICT --
I THINK IN THE LAST COUPLE
MONTHS A STARTED TO TURN THE
CORNER.
I THINK THE MOST FROM OUR
ASSESSMENT. ONE OF THE MOST
DIFFICULT ISSUES IN SWEETWATER --
HAS BEEN A BOARD NOT
ACKNOWLEDGING THE GOVERNING
BOARD NOT ACKNOWLEDGING THE
MAGNITUDE OF THE PROBLEM.
AND THEY HAVE STARTED TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT AND ONCE WE GET
THROUGH THAT IF YOU WILL STEP
ONE ON THAT RECOVERY PROCESS
ADMITTING THAT WE'VE GOT A
PROBLEM --
DAN HELP DUMB AND PROGRESS --
BECOMES VERY APPARENTFAIRLY
QUICKLY --
AFTER THAT IN IN CONVERSATIONS
BOTH FRIDAY AND YESTERDAY --
TO REALLY GET AN UPDATE ON WHERE
THEY'RE OUT --
WE WE SEE SOME PROGRESS CITY.
MISTER CHAIR PERFECT TIMING --
NO THIS OF INTEREST TO YOU
SACRAMENTO CITY --
THE ABILITY TO AVOID --
INTERVENTION AND EMERGENCY LOAN
FRANKLY IS QUESTIONABLE --
WATER LOCAL MEDIA COVERAGE I
THINK YOU'RE ALL SENSITIVE TO
THEIR A GREAT ARTICLE OVER THE
WEEKEND THAT I THINK SUMMARIZED --
IN THE SACK BE KIND OF SUMMARIZE
WHERE THEY'VE BEEN A WHERE --
WHERE THEY'RE OUT RIGHT NOW --
THEIR ORIGINAL PROJECTION THAT
THEY WOULD BE OUT OF CASH IN
NOVEMBER AND THEREFORE REQUIRED
EMERGENCY PREPARATION A PROCESS
THAT WE WOULD --
PROBABLY INITIATED THE MADE A
JUNE TIME PERIOD --
WITH THE LEGISLATURE --
RIGHT NOW PROBABLY IS MOVED OUT
ONE OR TWO MONTHS DEPENDING ON
THE EFFECTIVENESS AND THE TIMING
OF THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THEIR
FIRST SET OF CUTS.
ON THAT THEY IDENTIFIED JUST
LAST WEEK WE'VE NOT EVALUATED
THOSE CUTS THEIR FRESH AT THIS
POINT.
ON THEY WILL BE CRITICAL --
TO MOVING FORWARD ISSUE
APPRECIATE MANY OF THOSE CUTS
WILL BEGIN TO TAKE EFFECT TILL
JULY FIRST.
WHICH IS A VERY SHORT WINDOW
BETWEEN --
JULY FIRST IN THE TIME THAT
THERE COULD.
TO RUN OUT OF CASH.
OVERALL ACROSS THE STATE.
FROM SOLVENCY TRANS MOST SCHOOL
DISTRICTS IN THEIR MULTI YOUR
FINANCIAL PROJECTIONS DO SHOW
SOME DEFICIT TRENDS --
MANY OF HAVE A LONG HISTORY OF
DEALING WITH --
PROJECTED DEFICITS BY TAKING
APPROPRIATE ACTION EARLY IN THE
PROCESS -- I
THINK WHAT'S COMMON AMONG THE
DISTRICTS THAT --
WE OFTEN SEE IN FISCAL
DISTRESSES THEY'VE NOT BEEN --
AS PROACTIVE THEY'VE NOT ACTED
QUICK ENOUGH --
IN RESPONSE TO CHANGING
CONDITIONS WHETHER THAT'S
DECLINING ENROLLMENT --
HIGHER --
HIGHER EXPENSES ARE EXPENSES
GROWING AT A FASTER RATE THAN
THE REVENUE --
AND SO ON BUT MOST DISTRICTS
WILL DEAL WITH THAT VERY
EFFECTIVELY AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
ON THROUGH THEIR GOVERNANCE TEAM.
WITH RESPECT TO EXTRAORDINARY
AUDITS -- AB
ONE THIRTY NINE EXTRAORDINARY
AUDITS IF YOU RECALL MY
TESTIMONY LAST YEAR AT THIS
POINT TIME WE WERE COMPLETELY
OVERWHELMED WE HAD --
DOUBLED OUR ALL TIME PEAK WE
WERE INTO THE TWENTIES ACTUALLY
BY THE TIME WE FINISHED LAST
YEAR OF EXTRAORDINARY AUDITS ARE
PREVIOUS PEAK HAD BEEN TEN IN A
YEAR.
AND WE WERE OVER TWENTY LAST
YEAR AS RESET FOR WHATEVER
REASON --
TREND AS BACK --
TO KIND OF WHAT WE WOULD CALL
THE NORMAL LEVEL OF ACTIVITY
ABOUT HALF OF WHAT IT WAS LAST
YEAR SO BACK IN THAT THAT TEN
ALTHOUGH TEN PROBABLY IS A
STRETCH FOR ME TO CALL THAT
NORMAL.
GIVEN THAT HAD BEEN OUR PREVIOUS
PEAK ARM WE HAVE ONE HIGH
PROFILE --
AUDIT THAT'LL BE RELEASED IN THE
NEXT THIRTY TO FORTY FIVE DAYS
IT'S IN ITS --
GOING THROUGH ITS EDITING IMPAIR
OF YOU PROCESS RIGHT NOW.
AND WE HAVE ONE HIGH FOR PROFILE
AUDIT SPECIFICALLY SWEETWATER
UNION --
THAT IS JUST BEGINNING WHICH IS
STUDIED UP PARTIAL ENTRANCE --
CONFERENCE ON THAT --
MATTER YESTERDAY.
WITHOUT A BE HAPPY TO ANSWER-QUESTIONS.
MR DONNA I THANK YOU ARE WITH
REGARD TO CHARTERS DID YOU PLAY
A ROLE -- IN
IN IN IN THE FISCAL OVERSIGHT OF
CHARTERS AND WHAT MIGHT TRIGGER
THAT ARE THEY SUBJECT AB TWELVE
HUNDRED SHOULD THEY BE SUBJECT
AB.
TWELVE HUNDRED GREAT QUESTION SO
OUR OUR ROLE IS IS A LITTLE BIT
MIX THERE --
THE AB TWELVE HUNDRED PROCESS
FOR CHARTERS THEY ARE REQUIRED
TO SUBMIT A BUDGET TO THEIR
AUTHORIZING --
BODY WHETHER IT'S A SCHOOL
DISTRICT OR COUNTY OFFICE --
THEY ARE RESPONSE RESPONSIBLE --
FOR TO SUBMIT IN ARMOR PORT HE
IS --
DIFFERENT THAN AN ALLEY A THERE
ARE NOT PENALTIES ARE
CONSEQUENCES WHEN THEY FAIL TO
DO THAT WE HAVE SOME OF THOSE
RIGHT NOW --
WHERE THE CHARTERS REFUSED TO
SUBMIT A A FIRST IN A REPORT DUE
BACK IN DECEMBER AS AN EXAMPLE --
SO THE SAME PENALTIES APPLY TO
TRADITIONAL PUBLIC SHOOL DON'T
APPLY TO THEM --
OUR INVOLVEMENT IS --
MULTI FULL FIRST OFF WE HAVE
PUBLISHED A LOT OF GUIDANCE FOR
CHARTER SCHOOLS WE'RE THE
PUBLISHER.
OF THE CHARTER SCHOOL COUNTY
MANUAL -- WE
ARE THE PUBLISHER OF THE AUTHOR
I SEARCH CHECK LIST SO --
AGENCIES THAT AUTHORIZED
CHARTERS THEIR OVERSIGHT PROCESS
A CHECKLIST TO CONDUCT THEIR
OVERSIGHT --
ALL ALL AVAILABLE ON OUR WEB
PAGE WE DO ON CHARTERS ARE
INCLUDED IN ALL OF OUR
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT --
WE PROVIDE THEM ADVICE JUST LIKE
WE DO ANY OTHER SCHOOL DISTRICT --
BUT THEY ARE.
THEY ARE NOT SUBJECT TO THE AB
TWELVE HUNDRED PROCESS WERE --
IF THEY'RE HAVING FISCAL
DISTRESS THAT THEY CAN COME TO
THE LEGISLATURE FOR AN EMERGENCY
PREPARATION --
THEY ARE NOT GUARANTEED --
THEY HAVE THE SAME LEVEL OF
GUARANTEES THE CONSTITUTION
PROVIDES TO K. TWELVE IN OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGE OF PARTNERS --
THOSE -- DE
THESE -- AND
SO THE STATE BE IN ESSENCE
BECOMES THE GUARANTEE YEAR OF
THEIR OPERATIONS WHICH IS WHY WE
GET INTO THE WHOLE IDEA OF A OF
A STATE EMERGENCY APPORTIONMENT --
CHARTERS COULD TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
US BANKRUPTCY --
LAWSON AND SOME OTHER AREAS SO
IT'S A IT'S A MIX --
CHARTERS ARE OFTEN THE SUBJECT
OF AUDIT REQUEST THAT WE GET --
HOWEVER THAT IS --
ACTUALLY DOWN QUITE A BIT --
FROM BUT WHILE VERY MENTIONED
TOTAL WATER DOWN EXTRAORDINARY
OUT TO DOWN FROM LAST YEAR --
THEY WOULD BE TRUE FOR BOTH
CHARTERS AND REGULAR --
NOT REGULAR BUT MORE TRADITIONAL
PUBLIC SCHOOLS.
WITH REGARD TO SACK CITY YOU MAY
KNOW THIS ON TOP OF YOUR HEAD
YOU MAY NOT HOW LONG.
ARE THEY QUALIFY NOW ARE THEY
NEGATIVE NO HERE NEGATIVE THEIR
NEGATIVE THEY HAD A IS ON ROUTE
BUDGET IN THE SUMMER.
AND THEN --
THEIR FIRST IN ARM THEY FILED
NEGATIVE LAST WEEK AND IT WAS
ALSO NEGATIVE.
THERE COUNTY BUSES THAT DOES
HAVE YOUR NEGATIVE.
THE KIND OF THE WAY IT WORKS --
YES THERE ISN'T REALLY A
DOWNGRADE FROM NEGATIVE --
SO PRETTY NOW --
THAT IN SOME RESPECTS COUNTY
DOESN'T GET A CHOICE ON THAT YOU
BUT YES THAT NEGATIVE HIS FAULT
IN THEIR CASE BOTH THE FIRST
ENORMOUS SECOND IN OUR NEGATIVES
WERE FILED --
IN CONCERT WITH THE COUNTY
OFFICE I GUESS MY POINT IS THAT
COUNTY IF YOU SUBMIT A BUDGET
THAT YOU SEE AS POSITIVE AS
ACTUALLY QUALIFIED OR NEGATIVE
THE COUNTY.
WOULDN'T CAN DOWNGRADE THAT
COULD DOWNGRADE THAT SWEAT WHERE
THEY WHERE THEY WERE THEY'RE A
YEAR AGO. TWO YEARS AGO DO YOU
KNOW -- TWO
YEARS I'LL HAVE TO LOOK UP --
LAST YEAR AT THIS POINT IN TIME
I BELIEVE THEY WERE POSITIVE --
THE PROCESS BEGAN LAST NOVEMBER
OF SEVENTEEN SO JUST OVER A YEAR
AGO -- WELL
THERE'S A LONG HISTORY OF
INTERACTION BETWEEN THE COUNTY
IN THE DISTRICT WHERE THE COUNTY
EXPRESSED CONCERNS BUT VERY
SPECIFICALLY --
IN RELATIONSHIP TO APPROVAL OF A
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING AGREEMENT
AND EARLY DECEMBER OF SEVENTEEN
ON THE COUNTY EXPRESSED IN
AFFORDABILITY CONCERN --
DID THAT AGAIN AT THEIR FIRST IN
ROME THEIR SECOND IN AROUND THE
DISTRICT WAS UNRESPONSIVE TO
THOSE ITEMS --
AND WHEN IT CAME TIME FOR UP
BUDGET APPROVAL --
IN THE SUMMER FOR THE NEW THE
NEW FOR BUDGET.
WHICH IS --
IN SOME RESPECTS ONE OF THE
HIGHER LEVELS OF INTERVENTION A
COUNTY CAN TAKE THE CODE THEN
PROVIDES FOR A PROCESS TO BE
FOLLOWED.
FULL TIME LINE AND WHO'S
INVOLVED IN THAT PROCESS ONCE A
BUDGETS DISAPPROVED --
COUNTY SIMPLY DOWNGRADED IN IN A
REPORT IT KIND OF STOPS THERE
OTHER THAN INTERVENTION --
MAKE MAY COME INTO PLAY --
BUT DISAPPROVAL OF A BUDGET
OBVIOUSLY THE DISTRICT AT THAT
POINT DOESN'T HAVE A
EXPENDITURES FORTY THERE HAVE
APPROPRIATIONS AUTHORITY.
WHEN WHEN WHAT WHEN THE BUDGETS
DISAPPROVED EARLY AND SO LOCAL
BOARD APPROVES IT?
THEY VOTE ON IT.
THEN THEY SUBMITTED TO THE
COUNTY YES BY JULY FIRST THE
COUNTY GOES THROUGH AN
EVALUATION PROCESS A CHECKLIST
PROCESS.
AN ANALYSIS PROCESS AND THEN
MAKES A DETERMINATION OF WHETHER
THEY CAN.
APPROVE IT APPROVE IT WITH
CONDITIONS OR DISAPPROVE IT
THOSE ARE THE THREE CHOICES A
COUNTY HOUSE.
AND THEY DISAPPROVE IT.
THEY THIS CASE THEY DID
DISAPPROVE THAT'S CORRECT.
AND THAT WHAT HAPPENS THAT --
THAT SETS A BOTH A TIME LINE IN
A PROCESS THAT.
IN COMPLIANCE WITH THE AD CODE --
FOR A BUDGET REVIEW COMMITTEE TO
BE --
ADDENDA FI --
THE CORRECTIVE ACTION THAT NEEDS
TO BE TAKEN AND THEN --
IN ESSENCE RESUBMITTED TO THE
COUNTY.
THAT BUDGET REVIEW COMMISSION
PROCESS --
CAN BE WAIVED AND IN FACT.
I THINK WE JUST DETERMINED IN
THE LAST TEN YEARS IT'S BEEN
WAIVED IN ALL CASES BUT ONE AND
SO -- THE
WAIVER PROVIDES GENERALLY THE
PARTIES -- A
LITTLE LESS FORMAL RESOLUTION
PROCESS AND IT GIVES THEM AN
EXTRA THIRTY DAYS TO ACHIEVE
THAT WHEN YOU WAVE IT BUT THERE
ARE STILL SOME.
CONSTRAINTS EVEN WITHOUT THE
BUDGET REVIEW --
COMMITTEE PROCESS.
THANK YOU.
SURE CAN I CLASS THE FOLLOW UP
ON THIS FOR FOR SACRAMENTO REAL
QUICK.
SO I I JUST WANTED TO TO ASK IT
AND OVERALL QUESTION BEFORE I
GET THE SACRAMENTO.
I KNOW YOU YOU'VE BEEN HERE WITH
THIS CHART FOR THE LAST FEW
YEARS AND IT'S SOMEWHAT --
ON THE QUITE.
A QUITE ACCURATE PICTURE BECAUSE
AT THIS POINT IF YEARS AGO WE
STILL HAD.
ROUGHLY FORTY DISTRICTS ARE
QUALIFIED AND A HANDFUL THAT
WERE NEGATIVE AND NOW WE HAVE
THE SAME AMOUNT THAT ARE
QUALIFIED AND DOUBLE THAT THERE
ARE NEGATIVE [inaudible]
BUT WHAT DO YOU ATTRIBUTE THIS
IS BIG PICTURE BECAUSE IF IF YOU
WOULD ASK SOMEBODY ON THE STREET
[inaudible]
HEY.
STATE TAX REVENUE FIFTY PRESS
THE INCREASE IN MONEY GOING TO
OUR SCHOOL DISTRICTS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA AND NOW WE HAVE MORE.
THAT ARE IN TROUBLE SO HOW DO
YOU RECONCILE.
THAT THAT ISSUE WHICH JUST
COMPOUNDS.
US AND PEOPLE ACROSS CALIFORNIA
WHEN THEY HEAR ABOUT THIS WELL I
THINK IT COULD FOR CONFOUNDS US
A LITTLE BIT TOO WE ARE AT A
POINT AFTER SIX YEARS OF A
SIGNIFICANT REINVESTMENT.
RAH RESTORATION OF THE CUTS THAT
WERE MADE IN THE GREAT RECESSION
PLUS ADDITIONAL --
BASICALLY GROWTH FUNDS AND AND
THE QUESTION IS --
IF THINGS SLOW DOWN NOW GOING
FORWARD WE EXPECT TO SEE THIS
KIND OF TREND TWO YEARS FROM NOW --
MAYBE FOR A COUPLE DISTRICTS A
YEAR FROM NOW ON THOSE TYPES OF
THINGS THE FACT THAT WE HAVE --
SO MANY AND FULL THAT ARE REALLY
IN SOME EXTREME CONDITIONS IS --
IS ABSOLUTELY A GREAT QUESTION --
THEY ALL VERY SLIGHTLY IN IN THE
REASONS FOR THAT THAT'S A GREAT
QUESTION --
IS ONE OF GREAT CONCERN NO IT'S
BOTH IT'S A GREAT OBSERVATION IT
IS A GREAT CONCERN BECAUSE WE'RE
NOT DEALING WITH --
SOME EASY FIXES IN IN SOME OF
THESE CASES SO COMMON IN ALL OF
THESE --
LIKELY IS SOME DECLINE IN
ENROLLMENT --
ALTHOUGH SEX CITY SPECIFICALLY
IS ABOUT A 1% THE CLIENTS BEEN
RELATIVELY FLAT FOR THE LAST.
FIVE SIX YEARS --
SO DECLINE ENROLLMENT --
CERTAINLY THE ITEMS THAT YOU
HAVE HEARD FROM YOUR
CONSTITUENTS ABOUT IN THIS
REGARD ABOUT --
PRESSURE POINTS FROM --
INCREASE PENSIONS SPECIAL
EDUCATION COSTS --
AND THOSE THINGS BUT AT THE SAME
TIME -- WE
WOULD WE WOULD TAKE A VIEW THAT
SAYS --
ACROSS THE STATE WE HAVE ELEVEN
HUNDRED AND SOME SCHOOL
DISTRICTS.
AND THEY EACH HAVE A GOVERNING
BOARD WHO HAS A FIDUCIARY
RESPONSIBILITY TO ENSURE THAT
THE DISTRICT IS LIVING WITHIN
THE MEANS --
TO GET EARLIER ABOUT YOU KNOW
THERE SEEMS TO BE SOME PRESSURE
POINTS OF THAT THIS NARRATIVE OF
COMING TO THE STATE FOR MORE.
AND MORE AND WHILE I DON'T THINK
ANY OF US COULD ARGUE THAT --
FUNDING OUR K. TWELVE IN K.
FOURTEEN SYSTEM SHOULD BE A HIGH
PRIORITY THE REALITY IS THERE'S
BEEN A SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENT.
ON THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS AND SO
WHY ARE THERE ON THESE DISTRICTS --
WHAT IS ALSO COMMON IN EACH OF
THESE PROBLEM AREAS?
IS SLOW TO RESPOND --
GOVERNANCE ISSUES.
LEADERSHIP ISSUES SOME CASES
TURN OVER A VERY SENIOR
LEADERSHIP BULL SUPERINTENDENT
BUSINESS OFFICE CAPACITY OF THE
BUSINESS OFFICE IN MANY OF THESE
CASES.
ARM IN OUR EARTH IN TH OUR THREE
NEGATIVES OTHER THAN I'M I'M FOR
THE SAKE OF DISCUSSION WOULD.
IGNORE FEATHER FALLS --
SACRAMENTO CITY SOUTHERN KERN.
AND SWEET WATER THOSE ARE ALL --
LOW CAPACITY --
BUSINESS OFFICE FUNCTIONS ARE UP
TO THIS POINT.
IN THE CASE OF SWEET WATER
THEY'VE HIRED A VERY --
HIGH CAPACITY PERSON TO LEAD
THEIR BUSINESS FUNCTIONS --
BUT IN THE OTHER DISH GO WITH
CAPACITY OF THAT LEADERSHIP
SPECIFICALLY YEAH SO AS FAR AS I
KNOW IT'S HARD TO PREDICT.
BUT IF WE SEE THAT YOU KNOW
WE'VE HAD A INCREASE IN SCHOOL
FUNDING FROM THE STATE THE LAST
FIVE YEARS KIND LIKE THIS.
IN THIS YEAR SOMEWHAT.
YELLOWING SLOWING AND THEN LET'S
SAVE IT SLOWS YOUR SLOWS EVEN
MORE.
DO YOU ANTICIPATE.
A YEAR FROM NOW THAT THESE
CHARTS AND BE.
COMING OFF THE CHARTS.
AND I I KNOW IT IS HARD TO
PREDICT AND YOU GUYS YOU SAID
SACRAMENTO WAS EVEN ON THE LIST.
EIGHTEEN MONTHS AGO.
YEP ONE OF THE CERTAINLY
EIGHTEEN MONTHS AGO SACRAMENTO
WAS ON THE LIST THEY HAD A VERY
HEALTHY RESERVE AND CASH
FORECAST --
BUT EVEN A YEAR AGO --
AFTER MULTIPLE WARNINGS IN SACKS
CITY THEY WEREN'T ON THE LIST
THIS PUTS ACT WHEN OKAY SAYING
SO DO YOU ANTICIPATE THAT AS
WERE -- YES
DIDN'T INVESTING IN OUR SCHOOLS
AND NOT AS MUCH AS WE HAD BEEN
THE PRIOR FOR YEARS.
SO IT WE WOULD SAY WE WILL SEE A
SIGNIFICANT INCREASE IN OTHER
DISTRICTS ON THE THE ON THE
NEGATIVE ARE QUALIFIED.
THERE WILL BE CHORE PRESSURE
POINTS AS REVENUE SLOWS AND
EXPENSES DON'T SLOW IN CONCERT
WITH THAT THAT SAME REVENUE
SLOWING RIGHT.
ARM THAT SPEAKS TO THE IMPORTANT
BACK TO STIRS ON PROVIDING SOME
RELIEF THERE AT ONE OF THOSE
PRESSURE POINTS AND SO ON AS
NOTED IN MY COMMENTS UNDER
SOLVENCY TRENDS WE ARE SEEN
MULTI YEAR.
FORECAST THAT SHOW DEFICIT TRANS
MOST DEFINITELY THE MAJORITY OF
SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
THIS IS THE VALUE OF THE MULTI
YOUR FINANCIAL PROJECTION THE
AND SHOULDN'T AND AND SHOULDN'T
BE DISCARDED --
BY GOVERNING BOARDS OF THE
IMPORTANCE OF THIS IT SHOWS THEM
UNDER CURRENT LAW AND CURRENT
FORECAST WHERE THEY'RE HEADED.
AND SO NOW IS THE TIME TO TAKE
THAT ACTION --
TAKING ACTION EARLY MEANS THAT
THEY PREVENT THOSE.
THOSE KINDS OF DISTRESS.
AND PRESSURE POINTS --
IT IS.
AGAIN I MUST SAY IT'S A
FIDUCIARY THE RIVER BURE SPOTS
ABILITY OF THE LOCAL SCHOOL
BOARDS. TO INSURE THAT THEY LIVE
WITHIN THEIR MEANS --
AND THAT THEY SET THE PRIORITIES
FOR THEIR DISTRICTS AS THEY MOVE
FORWARD THAT ARE WITHIN THEIR
THEIR FORECASTED REVENUE MEANS
OR REPORTER RESERVE MEANS.
AND THAT COURSE IS EXHIBIT A
HERE IN SACRAMENTO AND AND BY
THE WAY I I'M COUNTING ON OUR
SCHOOL DISTRICT. TO TO TO MAKE
THE ADJUSTMENTS AND AVOID GOING
TO THE STATE TAKEOVER TAKING --
ACTIONS LITTLE LITTLE BY LITTLE
CHIPPING AWAY.
BUT IT'S YET TO BE SEEN BUT
WE'RE CERTAINLY COUNTING ON AS
YOU KNOW OUR ADVICE TO THEM HAS
BEEN DO EVERYTHING YOU CAN TO
AVOID --
COMING TO THE LEGISLATURE FOR A
EMERGENCY PREPARATION SO SO WITH
SACRAMENTO.
IT EAT IT THERE WAS A
PRECIPITOUS DECLINE.
AS YOU AS YOU KNOW JUST AND THEY
WERE ON THE THE POSITIVE.
LEISURE THE REMAIN ON THAT DATE
YELLOWER READ.
FAR AS YOUR ON THE CHART.
HAVE WE SEEN THAT BEFORE OTHER
DISTRICTS IN SUCH A SHORT PERIOD
OF TIME.
GOING FROM POSITIVE TO QUALIFIED
TO NEGATIVE YES SO ALSO ON THE
NEGATIVE LISTA SWEETWATER THAT
WAS AN OVERNIGHT --
ISSUE YEAH THAT WAS BROUGHT
RIGHT -- I
WOULDN'T DESCRIBE IT AS FRAUD --
WE MAY HAVE HAD --
SOME ACTIVITY THAT DIDN'T SURE --
BUT I DON'T BELIEVE THERE'S ANY
EVIDENCE THAT SOMEBODY WALKED
OUT THE DOOR WITH YEAH FUNDS I
WOULD ROSY THAT DEFINITION --
GROSS MISMANAGEMENT SACRAMENTO
WASN'T WE DON'T KNOW IF THAT'S
THE CASE YET BUT IT.
DID WE EVER SEE A DISTRICT GO SO
FAST.
FROM GOOD NEWS --
TO TO TO NEGATIVE SO QUICKLY YES --
I THINK THERE ARE PROBABLY A
NUMBER OF EXAMPLES IN HISTORY
THAT SHOW THAT WE WE DON'T
ALWAYS SEE THEM MOVE FROM
POSITIVE NAY GAVE THE AB TWELVE
HUNDRED PROCESS IS.
DESIGNED TO BE A PROGRESSIVE
SYSTEM SO BABY STEPS TOWARDS
THAT AND SO THERE'S A RELUCTANCE
FIRM -- FOR
EVERYBODY TO GO FROM A
CERTIFICATION POSITIVE TO
CERTIFICATION OF NEGATIVE
OVERNIGHT IT'S MEANT TO KIND OF
BUILD UP TO THAT AND THE
INTERVENTION THAT COMES WITHOUT.
IS MEANT TO BE A BABY STEPS MUCH
LIKE WHAT WE DO WITH THE STUDENT
IN A CLASSROOM THROUGH A MULTI
TIERED SYSTEM OF SUPPORT --
WE PROVIDE JUST THE RIGHT
INTERVENTION AT THE RIGHT TIME --
BUT YES --
SMALL DISTRICTS WITH A CHARTER
THAT'S OPENING.
WHAT WHAT LET ME GIVE YOU
ANOTHER EXAMPLE ON ON BEEN
BEFORE YOU BEFORE IS VALLEJO
CITY -- THEY
HAD A DEFICIT --
IN THE CURRENT.
IN THE CURRENT PERIOD --
THAT WAS FAIRLY MANAGEABLE --
THEY HAD A VERY LARGE.
ARE A CHARTER SCHOOL OPEN WITH --
IF I RECALL RIGHT --
ROUGHLY SEVEN HUNDRED STUDENT
DECLINE --
AS OUR BUT IN THEDISTRICT AS A
RESULT OF THE CHARTER SCHOOL ON
MORE THAN.
MORE THAN DOUBLES THEIR DEFICIT
ALMOST OVERNIGHT.
AND SO THAT WOULD BE AN EXAMPLE.
OF SOMETHING LIKE THAT PARADISE
MY LAST QUESTION WOULD BE IN A
BIT EXTREME SITUATION RIGHT BUT
WITH THE WITH THE FIRES --
BUT PARADISE IS CURRENTLY
OPERATING AT HALF OF ITS
ENROLLMENT THAT IT HAD JUST IN
OCTOBER --
FORECASTED GO DOWN ANOTHER THIRD
IN OF THE NEW SCHOOL YEAR SO
THEY'LL BE ON THIS LIST.
IT DEPENDING ON THE
LEGISLATURE'S ACTION WITH
RESPECT --
TO ASSISTANCE FOR THEM UNIQUELY
BECAUSE OF THEIR THE NATURAL
DISASTER --
THE THE FIRE MY LAST QUESTION --
WE HAVE FEW MEMBERS HERE WHEN I
GOT A JOB IN.
IS YOU WE HAVE.
CHANGED THEIR THE RULES IN THESE
DISTRESSED DISTRICTS OF COURSE
YOU ALLUDED TO THAT NOW WITH THE
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION AS A
AS A STRONGER ROLE IN WE HAVE
THESE.
IDENTIFYING POINTS BUT SON
DISTRICTS DID SLEPT.
OVERNIGHT ROUGH YOU KNOW TO THIS
SO I GUESS --
MY QUESTION TO YOU IS.
IS IT IS THE CURRENT SYSTEM
ADEQUATE HER TO BE LOOKING AT AT
THAT OTHER WAYS TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE CAN IDENTIFY THESE EARLY
WARNING SIGNS AND AND YOU KNOW
KIND OF BLOW THE WHISTLE.
AND AND MAKE SURE THAT SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ON THEIR ELECTED
LEADERSHIP AND THEIR
SUPERINTENDENTS ARE AWARE AND
MAKING THESE DECISIONS EARLIER
SO WE DON'T HAVE.
YOU KNOW THESE CATASTROPHES
IMPACTING OUR CLASSROOMS GAS IN
A DAY WHO GETS HURT THE MOST.
CLASSROOMS YOUR KIDS.
STUDENTS ARE LEARNING WHICH IS
YOU KNOW OUR TOP PRIORITY FOR A
STATE SO.
OUR IS THE CURRENT SYSTEMATIC
WITH OR DO ANYTHING I THINK IT
OTHER OTHER WAYS THE CURRENT
SYSTEM WORKS VERY WELL THAT
DOESN'T MEAN IT'S PERFECT THERE
ARE TWO WEEKS IT CAN BE MADE TO
IT AND THAT'S IN PART WHY WE'VE
SEEN SOME FORTY PIECES OF
LEGISLATION SINCE NINETEEN
NINETY ONE WHEN.
AB TWELVE WONDER WAS PUT IN
PLACE TO DO THIS FIND TWEAKS IN
EACH OF THOSE DRIVEN BY
EXPERIENCE ALONG THE WAY --
ARE THERE SOME TWEAKS AROUND --
THE REPORTING AND THE COUNTY'S
ROLE WITH RESPECT --
TO COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
AGREEMENTS GREEN MEANT BUT THE
REPORTING OF THE THE DATA AND
THE COUNTIES ON THE TIME LINES
RELATIVE TO THAT.
STRENGTHENING THAT AREA --
I THINK PROBABLY WOULD BE
HELPFUL TO THE SYSTEM.
AGAIN NOT INFRINGING UPON A
LOCAL BOARD IN ITS IN ITS LABOR
PARTNERS TO ENTER INTO AN
AGREEMENT --
I WOULD I WOULD DISCUSS WE ARE
HARD PRESSED --
TO CRITICIZE ACTUALLY ANY OF THE
LABOR AGREEMENTS THAT SOME FOLKS
WOULD POINT TO AS THE CAUSE FOR
SOME OF THESE BECAUSE THOSE MAY
HAVE BEEN PERFECT AGREEMENTS FOR
THAT DISTRICT. FOR ITS --
INSTRUCTIONAL MISSION --
IT'S TEACHERS WHICH ARE CRITICAL
TO THAT MISSION --
HOWEVER THE DISTRICT AND DIDN'T
RESPOND AFTER THAT TO THE
CHANGES THAT THEY NEEDED TO MAKE
CAN SO THE COUNTY SPECIFIC ROLE
ON WITH REGARD TO THAT.
A FOCUS ON ON THE COUNTIES
EVALUATION OVER THE LIFE OF AN
AGREEMENT AS OPPOSED TO TO ONLY
FOCUSING ON THE CURRENT YEAR
PLUS TWO YEARS.
SO IF A COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
AGREEMENT GOES OUT FOUR YEARS OR
FIVE YEARS WHICH IS.
PRETTY RARE THAT IT GOES OUT
THAT FAR BUT IF IT DOES --
TO LOOK AT THE LIFE OF THE
AGREEMENT THE CODE ALREADY
PROVIDES FOR THAT BUT THAT'S NOT --
THAT IS NOT THE NORMAL PRACTICE
IT'S EVERYTHING IN IN SCHOOL
FINANCE FOCUSES ON CURRENT PLUS --
TO SYSTEM STRENGTHENING THEIR
THOSE WOULD BE TO THE SYSTEM
DOES WORK I THINK THE BEST
EVIDENCE OF THAT.
IS THAT WE IN TWENTY SEVEN
TWENTY EIGHT YEARS SINCE AB
TWELVE HUNDRED WAS PASSED.
WE'VE HAD. NINE SCHOOL DISTRICTS
OF ONE COMMUNITY COLLEGE COME TO
THE LEGISLATURE FOR EMERGENCY
PREPARATION.
WE HAVE ELEVEN HUNDRED PLUS
ANOTHER HUNDRED AND TWELVE OR SO
COMMUNITY COLLEGES SEVENTY SOME
COMMITTEE COLLEGE DISTRICTS --
THAT GO THROUGH THIS PROCESS
EVERY YEAR RIGHT AND WE'RE ONLY
TALKING ABOUT JUST TRULY A
HANDFUL THAT HAVE WERE THE
PROPER OVERSIGHT THE PROPER
INTERVENTION --
THAT THE DISTRICT ULTIMATELY
WASN'T RESPONSIVE TO THAT OKAY
THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER LIMA.
THANK YOU AND IT.
YOU KNOW I JUST I APPRECIATE THE
CUT THE QUESTIONS THAT I'VE BEEN
ASKED TO THINK ONE OF THE THINGS
I'M LOOKING AT TO USE THE CHART
THAT AND WE'VE SEEN BEFORE.
BUT THAT --
YOU KNOW THINKING OF THIRTY NINE
THAT ARE QUALIFIED RIGHT NOW AND
WHERE WE WERE PRIOR TO THE
RECESSION AND KNOWING AND THEN
THE NEXT THREE TO FOUR YEARS --
WE MAY FIND OURSELVES IN SOME
DIFFICULTY I'M TRYING TO FOR
PASSED ON WHAT.
I MEAN HOW WECAN THINK ABOUT
THIS THIRTY NINE DOESN'T SEEM
LIKE A LOT COMPARED TO WHEN WE
HAD A HUNDRED AND SEVENTY SIX
BUT CERTAINLY WE DON'T WANT A
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY SIX AT
QUALIFIED --
IN SO CAN YOU JUST HELP US
FORECAST A LITTLE BIT IN TERMS
OF WHAT WE SHOULD EXPECT THE
NEXT THREE TO FOUR YEARS AND IF
YOU HAVE ANY THOUGHTS.
OUR RECOMMENDATIONS --
UP ON TRYING TO ENSURE THAT WE
DON'T GET TO WHERE WE WERE IN.
TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN TWELVE SO
MAY HAVE BEEN ON THE SCHOOL
BOARD AT THAT TIME OKAY RIGHT SO
I WILL NOTE THAT PORTABLE
PERFECT EXAMPLE RIGHT --
SO IF YOU YOU WERE REALLY TO
PLOT OUT THIS THE ECONOMY IN THE
STATE BUDGETS RESPONSE TO THE
ECONOMY WITH RESPECT TO TAX
INCOME --
INCOME FROM TAXES AND SO ON THE
QUALIFIED IS AN EBB AND FLOW
THAT ALMOST MATCHES EXACTLY --
GOOD BUDGET YEARS ABOUT BUDGET
YEARS RIGHT THE PEAK OF ONE
SEVENTY SIX WAS RIGHT SMACK IN
THE MIDDLE OF THE GREAT
RECESSION.
IT WASN'T THE FIRST YEAR TOOK A
FEW YEARS RIGHT IS DISTRICTS
BEGAN TO SPEND DOWN THE RESERVES --
AND AND IN AN ATTEMPT TO AVOID
CUTS TO PROGRAMS AND LAYOFFS --
TO OUR OUR PRECIOUS STAFF THAT
THAT SERVER KIDS AND SO --
THAT'S WHERE YOU SEE THAT PEAK
ARE WE ANYWHERE CLOSE TO THAT NO
WHILE REVENUES MAY BE SLOWING AT
THE STATE --
GOING FORWARD WE HAVE A FULL
IMPLEMENTATION OF L. C. F. F. --
AND SO WERE IN THIS COAL ONLY
FOR LACK OF A BETTER WAY OF
DESCRIBING IT ENVIRONMENT FOR
YEAR OVER YEAR REVENUE GROWTH
ASIDE FROM ANY ADDITIONAL
PREPARATIONS AT THE STATE.
OF THAT THE LEGISLATURE IN
ADMINISTRATION MAY AGREE --
TO THERE THERE'S GOING TO BE
SOME PRESSURE POINTS COMING
FORTH -- THE
YEAR OVER YEAR REVENUE GROWTH
FOR THE NEXT SEVERAL YEARS --
WILL NOT MATCH THE YEAR OVER
YEAR EXPENDITURE GROWTH IN --
IN FOUR AREAS THAT DISTRICTS
OFTEN SAY THEY DON'T HAVE
CONTROL OVER.
PENSIONS AND SO MAYBE THAT THE
PERSIAN FOOD PUMP ON TOGETHER
STEP IN COLUMN WHICH IS A
NATURAL PROGRESSION OBVIOUSLY OF
AN EMPLOYEE --
BASED ON TIME IN EDUCATION --
IN THE DISTRICT AND BUT
CONTRIBUTIONS TO SPECIAL ED --
REMEMBER THAT --
SPECIAL ED EXPENSES ARE
INFLUENCED GREATLY NOT ONLY BY
THE NUMBER OF STUDENTS BUT ALSO
EVERY TIME THAT WE HAVE A
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING.
SETTLEMENT THAT IS BASED ON AT
LEAST AS THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS
BEEN BASED ON A COMBINATION OF
COLA AND GAP FUNDING.
SPECIAL ED DIDN'T RECEIVE THE
GAP FUNDING RIGHT IT RECEIVED
COLA.
BUT NOT A SAID THE HAPPENINGS
THAT IMMEDIATELY --
PUT SPECIAL ED EXPENDITURES AND
REVENUES OUT OF SYNC THE OTHER
ISSUE THAT YOU HAVE IS AS WE
HAVE ABOUT 65% OF THE DISTRICTS
ACROSS THE STATE DECLINING
ENROLLMENT.
SB SIX SO --
TO WHICH IS SPECIAL STATE MASTER
PLAN SPECIAL ED FUNDING --
IS ALLOCATED BASED ON TOTAL AND
BE DROPPING --
IN IN WIDE.
SORRY IN WHITE AREAS ACROSS THE
STATE -- A
AS A PERCENTAGE OF THE
ENROLLMENT SPECIAL IT IS
INCREASING RIGHT --
THAT'S NOT THE THAT'S NOT THE
SUBGROUP FOR LACK OF BETTER TERM
THAT IS NOT OF IN TOTAL
ENROLLMENT THAT'S DROPPING SO
THOSE COULD DOES CREATE SOME
CONFLICTS IN CERTAINLY THE
GOVERNOR --
IN HIS JANUARY PROPOSAL BEGINS
TO LOOK AT SOME OF THAT --
AND SPEAK TO SOME OF THAT WITH
RESPECT TO SOME SOME ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES SHORTLY --
SUBLIMINAL DONALD'S BOMB ON
CHAIRED A COMMITTEE AND HAD A
NUMBER PROPOSALS IN IN THE AREA
OF SPECIAL ED --
IN IN THE PAST --
EIGHTEEN MONTHS TWO YEARS REALLY --
AND SO.
THOSE ARE ALL GOING TO BE
PRESSURE POINTS THOSE WILL ALL
INCREASE PROBLY.
AT INDIVIDUAL DISTRICTS --
THOSE EXPENDITURE AREAS WILL
INCREASE AT A HIGHER RATE THAN
WHAT THE REVENUES GOING TO
INCREASE OVER THE NEXT COUPLE
YEARS THAT'S WHAT THIS.
THAT'S WHAT THESE DEFICIT
TRENDING MODELS ARE SHOWING US
ON A DISTRICT BY DISTRICT.
MOST DISTRICTS THEN WILL STEP UP
AND MAKE ADJUSTMENTS IN THEIR
PRIORITIES AND THEIR
EXPENDITURES --
TO MEET THAT CHALLENGE AND THEY
WILL HAVE BALLOTS BUDGETS --
A FEW DISTRICTS WON'T DO THAT
THEY'LL END UP INFLUENCING
WHATEVER THE COUNTY IS HERE WE
HOPE FOR A VERY SHORT PERIOD OF
TIME -- BUT
CERTAINLY MAY BE LONGER PERIOD
THAT IS WHY ONE OF THE TRIGGERS
WE IDENTIFIED IN OUR PROACTIVE
WORK.
WAS THREE CONSECUTIVE QUALIFIED.
IF YOU'RE SETTING IN THAT
QUALIFIED AND YOU'RE NOT GETTING
OFF THAT LIST IMPACT THE
POSITIVE AFTER THREE WHICH IS
ABOUT A YEAR AND A HALF FIRST
SECOND FOLLOWING FIRST ENRON OR
SECOND FIRST SECOND.
INTERIM --
SO YEAR YEAR AND A HALF THE TIME
IF YOU'RE NOT MOVING BACK IN
THAT TIME PERIOD THEN WE WANT TO
LOOK AT WHAT'S GOING ON IN THE
DISTRICT AS PART OF THAT EARLY
WARNING SYSTEM.
AS A SUPPLEMENT TO WHAT ARE
COUNTY OFFICES ARE ALREADY DOING
[inaudible]
THANK.
OKAY MISTER DON.
JUST A FOLLOW UP MAYBE RELATED
TO THE THE SACRAMENTO SITUATION.
AND WE HAVE DECLINING ENROLLMENT
[inaudible]
EXCUSE ME.
QUINCY NO.
HERE WE GO ALL RIGHT I WITH
REGARD TO DECLINING ENROLLMENT
AND CLOSING SCHOOL FACILITIES --
YOURS LIBERAL POLITICAL VENTURE
THERE AT THE LOCAL LEVEL I'M
SURE THAT'S THE BIGGEST HURDLE.
TO CLOSING SCHOOLS BUT IS THERE.
IS THERE ANYTHING WE CAN DO TO
HAVE DISTRICTS TAKE A CLOSER
LOOK.
AT CLOSING THOSE SCHOOL
FACILITIES THEY REALLY NEED TO
CLOSE BECAUSE OF THE FISCAL
IMPACT THEY MAY HAVE.
WELL DIFFICULT DIFFICULT TOPIC
DIFFICULT QUESTION IS A SCHOOL
BOARD MEMBER OF THE LAST YOU
WANT TO DO IS CLOSE A
NEIGHBORHOOD SCHOOL CRISIS --
SO LET'S BEGIN OUTLETS FOR THE
RECORD I'M NOT ADVOCATE OKAY I
WAS GOING TO CLOSE I WAS CERTAIN
OF THAT BUT LET'S LET'S HAVE
SOME CLARITY THOUGH. FOR SAKS
CITY THEIR ENROLLMENT DECLINE IS
A VERY VERY MINOR IT'S IN THE 1% --
SO THAT'S NOT.
FAIR THAT IS THERE AT JUST OVER
FORTY THOUSAND STUDENTS IN A
PROJECT TO BUILD THEIR MOST
RECENT HISTORY HAS BEEN ROUGHLY
1% A YEAR --
YES I'M AWARE OF A NEW
PROJECTION JUST IN THE LAST
MONTH OR SO THAT.
THAT -- THAT
THAT NUMBER IS HIGHER --
CERTAINLY AWARE OF THAT FOR NEXT
YEAR BUT CERTAINLY THEIR ACTUAL
IS WHEN WE COMPARE YEAR TO YEAR.
FOR THE LAST FIVE OR SIX YEARS
LEADING UP TO THIS YEAR IT'S
BEEN JUST IT'S BEEN. ONE YEAR
WAS A LITTLE HIGHER THAN 1% BUT
ON AVERAGE BEEN ABOUT 1% --
SO A BETTER EXAMPLE OF THAT
WOULD BE INGLEWOOD IN OAKLAND.
ARM INGLEWOOD IS DROPPED FROM
SERVING ROUGHLY NINETEEN
THOUSAND STUDENTS TO LESS THAN.
EIGHT THOUSAND THEY HAVE SURPLUS
SEATS SURPLUS CLASSROOMS SURPLUS
SCHOOLS --
IN EIGHTEEN FORTY THEY WERE
REQUIRED TO ADDRESS THAT.
A LOCAL PLAN TO ADDRESS THAT.
IN THE LAST SEVERAL MONTHS THEY
HAVE TAKEN.
AFTER YEARS OF CONVERSATION --
IN THE LAST SEVERAL MONTHS
THEY'VE PUT TOGETHER A VERY
VIABLE PLAN.
ON TO ADDRESS THAT --
SOME VOIGTS I'M SOME RE USE OF
SITES DIFFERENT CONFIGURATIONS
OF SITES AND SO ON AND CERTAINLY
ALSO THE SELL OR LEASE OF SOME
SITES.
IN OAKLAND'S CASE --
AS WAS DISCUSSED EARLIER IN THE
PANEL BEFORE ME ON THE DISTRICT
HAS COME UP WITH A DRAFT PLAN
THEY CALL THE CITY PLAN --
TO LOOK AT TWENTY FOUR SCHOOL
SITES HAVE TAKEN ACTION I
BELIEVE TO DATE ON ONE OF THOSE --
THEY'VE NOT ADOPTED THE WHOLE
PLAN UNLESS IT'S BEEN DONE IN
THE LAST WEEK AND I'M JUST NOT
CAUGHT UP TO IT --
BUT THEY'VE TAKEN ACTION ON ONE
SITE WITHIN THAT GROUP OF TWENTY
FOUR AGAIN THEY'RE UNDER --
EIGHTEEN FORTY GUIDELINES IN
ORDER TO TO RECEIVE THE
ADDITIONAL STATE ASSISTANCE
EIGHTEEN FORTY WOULD PROVIDE
HAVE CERTAIN BENCHMARKS THEY
NEED TO MEET --
RIGHT SIZING THE DISTRICT'S
FACILITIES IS ONE OF THOSE
BENCHMARKS --
AS YOUR I THINK WHILE WEARING
OAKLAND'S CASE THEY HAVE A LONG
HISTORY OF OPERATING RELATIVELY
SMALL VERY SMALL NEIGHBORHOOD
CAMPUSES TO START WITH.
THERE ARE GONNA BE TO SCALE
ISSUES WITH THAT FROM A QUALITY
STANDPOINT THOSE THOSE MAY BE.
GOOD THINGS FOR KIDS BUT THERE
ARE SOME PRETTY EXTREME
ECONOMIES OF SCALE ISSUES THERE
WHEN YOU'RE OPERATING TWO
HUNDRED AND THREE HUNDRED
STUDENT CAMPUSES AS COMPARED.
TO ELEMENTARY CAMPUSES COMPARED
TO A LITTLE BIT MORE ON ON
AVERAGE YOU KNOW WHICH IS.
SOMEWHERE IN THE FIVE HUNDRED TO
SEVEN HUNDRED RANGE ACROSS THE
STATE TOOK TOOK ONE LAST
QUESTION.
KITA DISTRICTS --
FISCAL STABILITY IS OF THEIR
CHIEF BUSINESS OFFICIAL.
OR THEIR ASSISTANT
SUPERINTENDENT OF A BUSINESS
SERVICES.
WHAT IS THE SELLING Y. OF THOSE
LOOKING LIKE AROUND?
IT CERTAINLY HAS BEEN A
CHALLENGE OVER THE LAST SEVERAL
YEARS WE SAW DURING THE GREAT
RECESSION WE SAW A NUMBER OF
VERY EXPERIENCED FOLKS LEAVE --
MAINLY DUE TO RETIREMENT BUT
PROBABLY SOME PROBABLY SAID KHAN
HAD ENOUGH OF TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT HOW.
TO MAKE ALL THESE PUZZLE PIECES
FIT TOGETHER RIGHT --
FIGMENT ITSELF OPERATES THE
LEADING --
CBO PREPARATION PROGRAM --
WE JUST GRADUATED TWO WEEKS AGO
THE NEXT CLASS OF TWENTY SIX
FOLKS --
CURRENTLY PROBABLY A THIRD OF
THE CBO'S AROUND THE STATE HAVE
GONE THROUGH OUR PREPARATION
PROGRAM YOUR LONG PREPARATION
PROGRAM HERE IN SACRAMENTO --
WE STAFF THE U. S. C. PROGRAM
THAT DOES SOMETHING VERY SIMILAR.
AND WE SUPPORT WITH --
STAFF THE BUSINESS OFFICIAL
PREPARATION PROGRAM I'M BETWEEN
THOSE THREE PROGRAM THAT'S THE
MAJORITY OF NEW FOLKS COMING
INTO THEIR SEATS AND RAN BY AND
FAR THEY'RE PREPARED. TO TO BE
IN OF SEATS --
IT'S A MIXED BAG BEYOND THAT --
GOT IT.
AND JUST A MISTER DONALD.
ABOUT FIVE YEARS AGO THE TAXI
DISTRICT CLOSED I THINK. EIGHT
TO TEN SCHOOLS.
SO THEY'VE THEY'VE DONE THAT A
PLANET YEAH --
MISTER ICE FISHING.
THANK YOU A MUST SHARE MISTER
FINE THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF A
PRESENTATION I ESPECIALLY
APPRECIATE.
TO YOUR YOUR YOUR COMMENT THAT
YOU KNOW WILD SO MUCH ATTENTION
IS BEING FOCUSED ON THE
DISTRICTS THAT ARE --
REALLY STRUGGLING THE VAST VAST
MAJORITY OF SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE
MAKING THE HARD DECISIONS BEING
RESPONSIBLE TO LIVE WITHIN THEIR
MEANS -- AND
AND AND TO ME YOU KNOW.
I MEAN I I I I I WISH THAT THE
THE BUDGET SHARE WAS STILL HERE
BECAUSE I WANTED TO PUSH BACK ON
ON NOW --
ONE OF HIS COMMENTS AND PERHAPS
HE'S HIM AMOROUS STAFF IS
LISTENING.
TO THE ON ON THE TV BUT IT ON ME
HE MADE THE COMMENT THAT THAT IT --
IT'S A IT'S A POLITICAL PLOY TO
BE -- YOU
KNOW THE TURN TO THE STATE FOR
MORE FUNDING.
BUT TO ME IT SEEMS OBVIOUS THAT
HAVE IT IS NOT TRUE THAT THE
THAT THE DISTRICT RATES OF THE
PENSION COSTS.
ARE MORE THAN DOUBLE OF WHAT IT
WAS IN --
TWENTY THIRTEEN TWENTY FORTY YES
YES ROUGHLY EIGHT POINT TWO FIVE
IS THE HISTORICAL STIRS RATE IN
WHERE ABOVE SIXTEEN RIGHT NOW SO
THAT WOULD BE MORE THAN DOUBLE
AND WE'RE GOING TO EIGHTEEN AND
19% BY. TWENTY TWENTY ONE OF
WITH SOME ASSISTANCE PROPOSED IN
THE BUDGET AND THEN STIRS.
STIRS HAS A FORECAST THAT
ACTUALLY BRINGS US BACK --
AFTER HITTING IN THE NINETEEN
BRINGS US BACK INTO THE EIGHT
LOW EIGHTEENS --
I FORGOT THE YEAR TWENTY FIRST
YEAR THINGS TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO OF THEM FIVE ELCO.
BUT BUT ROUGHLY DOUBLING --
WITHIN A RELATIVELY SHORT PERIOD
TIME AND THEN YOU YOU MADE THE
COMMENT THAT.
THAT IS ONLY PROJECTED THAT THE
THE THE HIGH NEED SPECIAL
EDUCATION COSTS ESPECIALLY ARE
ARE PROJECTED TO BE.
CONTINUE --
TO TO TO INCREASE.
AND WAIT WE ALSO HAVE THE
SITUATION.
OF A IT WHEN WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
FULL IMPLEMENTATION OF LCF WE'RE
ONLY TALKING ABOUT GETTING BACK
TO WHERE WE WERE.
IN -- SEVEN
OH AID SO.
IT'S A CORRECT.
ROUGHLY SPEAKING DEPEND ON
PERSPECTIVE YES.
THE THE THE GOVERNOR'S GOAL WAS
TO GET BACK TO PRE RECESSION
LEVELS AN N. --
EDUCATION FUNDING IN IRAQ DURING
GROWTH IN FACT WAS WORTH YES.
SO.
I MEAN HOW MUCH OF ALL OF WHAT
WE'RE SEEING AND HAPPENING HERE
NOT JUST TO THOSE WITH NEGATIVE
AND QUALIFY CERTIFICATIONS.
BUT WITH ALL THE DISTRICTS
STRUGGLING IS THE FACT THAT WERE
THEY ALL DISTRICTS ARE BEING
ASKED YOU KNOW TO TO COVER SO
MUCH MORE IN TERMS OF THESE.
THESE RISING FIX COSTS WITH.
YOU KNOW WELL OF FUNDING THAT --
WHICH IS LIT WITH WAS BASICALLY
GETTING THE GOAL WAS TO GET US
BACK TO WHERE WE WERE --
BEFORE THE RECESSION.
WELL THIS IS NOT IT.
THIS IS NOT AN EASY EQUATION --
UNDERSTAND THAT FOR SOME
DISTRICTS AND ROMAN IS PLAYING A
ROLE FOR A SIGNIFICANT MAJORITY
OF DISTRICTS --
THEIR ABILITY TO I'M A FASHION
TO REDUCTIONS IN ENROLLMENT --
DECLINING ENROLLMENT YEAH
WHETHER SHORT TERM OR LONG TERM
CERTAINLY HAS --
A VERY SIGNIFICANT IMPACT ON
THEM THEY'VE GOT TO BE
RESPONSIVE STATE LAW PROVIDES
FOR THAT YEAR OF DELAY THAT --
WE OFTEN REFER TO IT AS THE SOFT
LANDING --
WHERE YOU GET THE CHOICE OF
USING THE GREATER OF THE CURRENT
YEAR THE PRIOR YEARS --
AVERAGE DAILY ATTENDANCE WHICH
IS THE THE CASE LOAD FACTOR IN
THE REVENUE.
RIGHT --
MANY DISTRICTS ARE ALSO TURNING
TO THEIR LOCAL --
CONSTITUENTS THEIR TAXPAYERS FOR
ASSISTANCE WHETHER THAT'S YOUR
PARCEL TAX OR MORE COMMENT ON
THE FACILITY SIDE THROUGH
GENERAL OBLIGATION BOND BUT MANY
MANY -- MORE
MORE PREDOMINANTLY IN THE
NORTHERN HALF OF THE STATE THAN
THE SOUTHERN HALF OF THE STATE --
LOOK TO PARCEL TAXES TO FUND
VERY SPECIFIC THINGS LIKE LOWER
CLASS SIZES AND BROADER
CURRICULUM OFFERINGS INCLUDING
MUSIC ART --
SUPPORTING OTHER --
HIGH PRIORITIES IN THEIR
DISTRICT SO.
IT IT IS NOT A IT'S COMPLICATED
IT'S A COMPLICATED AND HAND I
DON'T.
THE EACH COMMUNITIES IN EACH
DISTRICTS JUST A TAD DIFFERENT
IN ITS CIRCUMSTANCES.
BUT BUT HOW MUCH OF THIS OVERALL
IS A REFLECTION YOU KNOW --
WE WE WE'VE BEEN HAVING ITS
ONGOING DEBATES ABOUT --
HOW MUCH CALIFORNIA COMPARES TO
THE REST OF THE NATION IN PER
PEOPLE SPENDING?
ACCORDING TO EDUCATION WEEKLY IF
WE TAKE INTO ACCOUNT THE COST OF
LIVING OR FORTY FIRST IN THE
NATION -- LA
L. -- YOU
KNOW -- YOU
KNOW WHAT IS PRESENT LAST WEEK
PRESENTED TO ADD TO THE THE THE
THE OVERALL ADVOCACY OF OF K.
THROUGH TWELVE FUNDING I MEAN WE
WE WERE TALKING ABOUT.
YOU KNOW OR LOSE SOME OF US ARE
PATTING US ON OURSELVES ON MY
BACK IN TERMS OF HOW MUCH WE'VE
SIGNIFICANTLY INCREASED AND AND
AND THE LAST SIX SEVEN YEARS.
BUT IT IF IN A FOR STILL TALKING
ABOUT THE OVERALL --
FUNDING BEING AN ADEQUATE TO
MEET THE THE REAL COSTS THAT ARE
DISTRICTS ARE FACING THEN AND
HOW MUCH OF THAT IS IS THE
BOTTOM LINE --
REALITY THAT ARE DISTRICTS ARE
FACING.
SO.
SIR I I WOULD ENCOURAGE THAT
THAT'S A QUESTION OF THE LA --
AND AND MOST LIKELY DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE FROM MY PERSPECTIVE
YOU KNOW OUR ROLE IS TO ASSIST
TO DISTRICT --
UNDERSTANDING WHAT IT'S REVENUES
ARE AND LIVING WITHIN THE LIVING
WITHIN THE CONFINES OF THAT
REPRESENTS --
AS OPPOSED TO SAYING WE HOPE --
FOR AND YOU CAN BUILD A PLAN
AROUND THE HOPE THAT THERE WOULD
BE --
ADDITIONAL --
DOLLARS IN SOME FORM OR ANOTHER
AND SO --
THAT'S THE PERSPECTIVE THAT WE
WOULD TAKE IS WORKING WITH A
DISTRICT GETS LEADERSHIP ITS
GOVERNING BOARD --
TO LIVE WITHIN THE MEANS OF YOU
WE COULD GO BACK TEN YEARS WE
COULD GO BACK TWENTY YEARS AND
SAY THERE WERE OTHER PRESSURE
POINTS BACK THEN.
RIGHT -- AND
IT WOULD JUST BE A SLIGHTLY
DIFFERENT LIST --
BUT THERE WERE PRESSURE POINTS
IN DISTRICTS THE MAJORITY OF
DISTRICTS AGAIN --
TOOK THE ACTION THEY NEEDED --
TO TO PROVIDE HIGH QUALITY
PROGRAMS FOR THEIR KIDS BUT
WITHIN.
THE CONFINES OF THEIR REVENUES
OKAY BUT WHAT MY LAST QUESTION
THEN IS FROM YOUR PERSPECTIVE AS
THE THICK MAT DIRECTOR I I I
BELIEVE YOU'VE SAID THIS IN.
SO MANY WAYS --
EARLIER BUT IN A WAIT WE'VE HAD
THE LONGEST RUN --
ECONOMIC RUN --
WHERE WE'RE?
OVERDUE FOR A ECONOMIC DOWNTURN --
IT IS YOU KNOW MOST LIKELY THAT
WE WILL SEE ANOTHER SPIKE AND
THE A NUMBER OF NEGATIVE AND
QUALIFY CERTIFICATIONS WITH
ECONOMIC DOWNTURN QUALIFIED FOR
SURE NEGATIVE WHEN YOU LOOK AT
THAT CHART --
NEGATIVE --
ARE -- WHEN
I DISTRICTS IN NEGATIVE THERE'S
A LOT GOING ON THERE --
THAT ISN'T RIGHT.
AND SO --
BUT CERTAINLY FOR QUALIFIED YES
IT FOR IT FOLLOWS THE EVAN FLOW
OF OF THE OF THE BUDGET IN THE
ECONOMY.
OKAY THANK YOU YES.
THANK YOU I I DO THINK YOU'RE
RIGHT YOU RAISE A GOOD POINT
THOUGH BRING US BACK TO OUR PRE
RECESSION LEVELS THAT A BE
INTERESTED MAYBE THE LA OR
SOMEONE COULD HELP US UNDERSTAND.
IF WE DIDN'T HAVE THAT PER IS
INCREASE WHAT WOULD IT LOOK LIKE
AS YOUR JOB IS TO DEAL WITH
DISTRICTS THAT ARE IN TROUBLE
RIGHT NOW AND OUR WORLD WE'D
LIKE TO HAVE YOUR DISTRICTS.
CALLING YEAR CALLING YOUR OFFICE
AND SO.
TAKE THAT OUT EVEN POTENTIALLY
LOOK AT HOW THE SPECIAL THAT
INCREASES AND KIND OF GET A
HANDLE AS FAR AS THE OVERALL
FUNDING IN CALIFORNIA.
BUT THE REALITY IS WE DO HAVE
THESE THESE --
INCREASES IN PRESENCE THERE SO
THAT'S A DISTRICTS HAVE TO HAVE
TO LIVE WITH.
THANK YOU FOR THE PRESENTATION.
WE WILL WE WILL --
SEE YOU --
HE SAID.
YES AND WITH THAT WE WILL NOW
PROCEED WITH PUBLIC COMMENT.
PLEASE LINE UP IN THE MIDDLE.
GOOD MORNING SERRA BUDGETS FOR
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
SCHOOL BUSINESS OFFICIALS HERE
TO TESTIFY ON ITEM ONE AND THREE
SUPPORTING THE GOVERNOR'S --
COMMITMENT TO THE LOCAL CONTROL
FUNDING FORMULA AS WELL AS THE
RECOGNITION OF OUR PENSION
CONTRIBUTIONS AND COSTS THAT ARE
ENCROACHING ON ALL OUR OTHER
EDUCATIONAL SERVICES THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING CATHERINE OCCUR
GONNA ON BEHALF OF CAPT COPYING
CALIFORNIANS TOGETHER --
MAKE COMMENTS ARE ON ISSUE THREE
THE ACCOUNTABILITY UPDATE AND
THE STATEWIDE SYSTEM OF SUPPORT.
ARE WE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THAT
THIS COMMITTEE CONSIDER
PROVIDING FIVE MILLION TO BE
ALLOCATED TO THE SAN DIEGO
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION.
WHICH HAS BEEN DESIGNATED AS THE
STATE LEAD.
THIS IS THE ONLY LEAD AGENCY OF
ALL OF THE ENTITIES BUILT INTO
THE STATE SYSTEM OF SUPPORT THAT
DOES NOT HAVE FUNDS TO CONDUCT
THEIR WORD THEIR WORK REGIONALLY
OUR STATE WHITE.
WE ALSO RECOMMEND THAT THE STATE
DEFINITION FOR THE ENGLISH
LEARNER ACADEMIC INDICATORS BE
REVISED AND DISAGREED IT BY
ENGLISH LEARNER ONLY AND RE
CLASSIFIED ENGLISH LEARNERS.
SEVERAL ANALYSES HAVE INDICATED
THAT AGGRAVATING THE SCORES
MASKS THE NEED TO ADDRESS THE
CURRENT ENGLISH LEARNERS AND
SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
AND THAT THIS HAS DIMINISH THE
NUMBER OF SCHOOLS AND DISTRICTS
THE OPPORTUNITY TO RECEIVING
TECHNICAL SUPPORT UNDER THE LCS
FAST AND THAT YES AS THE
ACCOUNTABILITY SYSTEM.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING SHERRY MEMBERS
DEREK LENNIX ON BEHALF THE SMALL
SCHOOL DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION OF
SCHOOL BOARDS ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA TO THE BIG ISSUES
RAISED BY YOU AND OTHER MEMBERS
TODAY AROUND DISTRICTS OFTEN
SEEN GOING ABOVE AND BEYOND THE
PROP NINETY EIGHT MINIMUM
GUARANTEE --
ON ISSUE NUMBER TWO AROUND
PENSIONS I THINK ARE THE BEAUTY
OF THIS PROPOSAL MY WE SUPPORTED
SO STRONGLY IS THAT IT DOES
ALLOW DISTRICTS IN A FUNCTIONAL
SENSE TO GO ABOVE AND BEYOND THE
MINIMUM GUARANTEE.
YES IT'S GENERAL FUND NO IT'S
NOT ON GOING NINETY EIGHT MONEY
BUT FOR ALL PRACTICAL PURPOSES
DISTRICTS ARE EXPERIENCING AT
THE SAME WAY AND THAT'S WHY WE
THINK IT'S SUCH A SMART MOVE FOR
THE GOVERNMENT LEGISLATORS. TO
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR STAFF --
JEFF BARKER REPRESENTING THE
RIVERSIDE COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT
OF SCHOOLS --
WE WILL FOLLOW UP WITH A LETTER
BECAUSE YOU'VE COVERED UP ALL
COVERED A LOT OF GROUND TODAY.
I WOULD I JUST WANT TO LEAVE YOU
WITH A COUPLE OF QUICK THOUGHTS.
ONE IS THAT EARLY ON IN THE
HEARING YOU HAD A CONVERSATION
ABOUT THE LOW PERFORMING STUDENT
BLOCK GRANT.
AND WE'RE VERY SUPPORTIVE OF THE
LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA
OBVIOUSLY WE ALL WANT TO IMPROVE.
THE PERFORMANCE OF ALL OF OUR
STUDENTS INCLUDING THOSE THAT
ARE MOST OF STE.
PERFORMING AT THE LOWEST LEVELS
WE WOULD ENCOURAGE --
THE COMMITTEE AND THE
LEGISLATURE TO BEFORE IT MAKES
ANY DECISIONS ABOUT PROVIDING
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR THAT
PROGRAM. TO REALLY WAIT AND SEE
WHAT THE DATA DEMONSTRATE --
WE'RE CONCERNED THAT AS WELL
MEANING AS THAT MIGHT BE AND WE
DO BELIEVE IT TO BE COMPLETELY
WHILE MEANING.
THAT CARVING OUT WHAT
ESSENTIALLY IS A CATEGORICAL
PROGRAM WITH AN L. C. F. F. IS
NOT THE OUTE THAT WE WOULD LIKE
TO GO.
AND THEN --
WITH REGARD TO THE CONVERSATION
ABOUT STATEWIDE SYSTEM OF
SUPPORT --
AND IT'S HARD AFTER HEARING LIKE
THIS NOT TO STAND AT THE EDGE OF
THE CLIFF AND LOOK INTO THE A
BEST BUT THERE IS A LOT OF GOOD
WORK GOING ON IN MANY IN ALL
COUNTIES ACROSS THE STATE IN ALL
REGIONS ACROSS THE STATE.
COUNTY OFFICES OF EDUCATION
COLLABORATING WITH SCHOOL
DISTRICTS TO DO SOME OF THE KIND
OF WORK THAT MR ARE MOLINO WAS
TALKING ABOUT IDENTIFYING ROOT
CAUSES.
WE'RE ALL VERY IMPATIENT TO SEE
IT'S BUT THAT WORK TAKES TIME.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
STAFF CALENDAR HOWEVER THE
CHARTER SCHOOLS DEVELOPMENT
CENTER AND I'M HERE ON ITEM
THREE I'M SPECIFICALLY WE HAVE
SOME CONCERNS AROUND THE NEW
CHARTER SCHOOL REQUIREMENTS ON
EL CAP.
AS YOU KNOW THAT --
BY DESIGN CHARTER SCHOOLS
ACTUALLY BEGIN WITH MORE
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
THAN TRADITIONAL SCHOOLS.
WITH THE PUBLIC HEARINGS ON
THEIR ACTUAL CHARTERS WHICH ARE
SIXTEEN POINT DOCUMENTS AND THE
FRAMEWORK FOR CHARTERS IS
ALREADY SET AND INFLEXIBLE.
SO ADDING ADDITIONAL PUBLIC
HEARINGS AND REQUIREMENTS AROUND
AN EIGHT POINT EL CAP --
SORT OF CONFLICTS WITH --
WITH THE CHARTER ITSELF AND
COULD LEAD TO CHARTER REVOCATION
WITHOUT THE RIGHT OF APPEAL SO
WE'RE CONCERNED ABOUT THAT WE
ALSO THINK THAT CHARTER SCHOOL
PARENTS TEND TO BE MUCH MORE
INVOLVED AS A GENERAL RULE.
AND COULD VOTE WITH THEIR FEET --
AND LEAVE THE SCHOOL IF THE
SCHOOL IS IT MEETING THEIR
EXPECTATIONS.
LASTLY WITH A NEW LANGUAGE
CHARTER OFF THE RISERS NEED TO
REVIEW AND READ TO DOCUMENTS
IT'S AN UNNECESSARY BURGER
BURDEN ON A CHARTER AUTHORIZED --
AND THE CHARTER DOCUMENT ALONE
SHOULD BE CLEAR ENOUGH ON ITS
MISSION AND GOALS THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MARK THE ON BUTTON
BEFORE THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL ADMINISTRATORS
ACCESS SUPPORTIVE OF THE TWO
BILLION DOLLARS FOR LC.
ALSO THE THREE BILLION DOLLARS
FROM GENERAL FUND FOR THE
PERSONS OF FOR THE STARS --
CONTRIBUTION I'M OUT OF SCHOOL
DISTRICTS WE ECHO THE COMMENTS
BY MR BACA FROM RIVERSIDE COUNTY
OFFIE OF IT WE ARE ENCOURAGED
BY THE STATE'S WORK AROUND
SYSTEM OF SUPPORT AND HELPING
SCHOOL DISTRICTS WITH THE
GREATEST NEEDS.
ARE TO BETTER BE ABLE TO IN
IMPROVE STUDENT ACHIEVEMENT OVER
TIME I WE HAVE EMBRACE THAT
CONTAINS IMPROVE MY PHILOSOPHY
THAT WE UNDERSTAND IT WILL TAKE
TIME TO RUN A REFER TO IS ALSO
CHIEF MEN GAPS THAT WE HAVE IN
OUR STATE.
AND REGARDING ITEM NUMBER FOR
ABOUT FISCAL DISTRESS WERE ALSO --
VERY I'M APPRECIATIVE OF MISTER
AFFINE COMMENTS REGARDING FIX
PACK WORK AROUND SCHOOLS WITH
FISCAL DISTRESS.
HOWEVER WE CONTINUE TO URGE THE
LEGISLATURE AS WAS POINTED BY A
BY THE CHAIR AND OTHERS I TO
CONTINUE TO INVEST IN L. CFF
INFLEXIBLE FUNDING.
AS YOU HEARD FROM THE SPEAKERS
THIS MORNING THERE'S A LOT OF
GROWING COST FOR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND WHAT WE NEED IS
MORE FLEXIBLE FUNDING TO BE ABLE
TO SUPPORT STUDENT NEEDS.
THANK YOU.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS GI SO
PROCESS WITH THE CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION I'M
HERE TO SPEAK ON NIGHT NUMBER.
TWO ON YOUR ANALYSIS THAT'S BEEN
RAISED WE THINK THE CLASSIFIED
SCHOOL EMPLOYEES UNDER THE PO'S
SYSTEM WITH BUT LEFT OUT.
WE HAVE REACHED OUT TO THE
ADMINISTRATION I HAVE MET.
WITH THE THE ADMINISTRATION
DIRECTLY ON THIS --
THE AMOUNT --
FOR THE SAME PARITY TREATMENT
FOR CLASSIFIED THAT YOU HAVE
WITH TEACHERS AND WE SUPPORTED
THREE BILLION FOR TEACHERS.
IT WOULD BE ESSENTIALLY A
HUNDRED SEVENTY FIVE MILLION
FOUR TO BUY DOWN THE EMPLOYER
RATE FOR A YEAR.
EVERYTHING IS A REASONABLE
AMOUNT TO TREAT CLASSIFIES HIM
PLEASE THREE QUICK POINTS OUT
RATES ARE GOING UP JUST.
AS HIGH AS TEACHERS ON THE BASE
LC PERCENT OF ESTABLISHED BACK
IN NINETEEN EIGHTY TWO THAT SAYS
THAT WHEN RATES DROP THE STATE
CAN PULL MONEY BACK OUT OF THE
REVENUE LIMITS SYSTEM UNDER THE
OLD SYSTEM.
BUT WHEN RATES ARE SUPPOSED TO
GO UP THAT'S OPPOSE IT BACK FEEL
BECAUSE DISTRICT NOW FACING
RISING PENSION COSTS WERE NOW NO
ONE THOUGHT IT WOULD GO ABOVE
THIRTEEN POINT OR TWO NOW WE'RE
GOING PAST FIFTEEN AND GOING
225%.
THAT'S WHY YOU HAVE THESE KINDS
OF PRESSURE AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
ONE FINAL POINT IF YOU DON'T DO
THIS FOR CLASSIFIED SCHOOL
EMPLOYEE ALSO THERE WILL BE A
RELUCTANCE ON THE LOCAL LEVEL.
EVERY EMPLOYEE YOU HIRE WILL BE
AN ADDED COST FOR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS THAT AND I PENSION
ISSUE THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON JENNIFER BAKER
THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION APPRECIATETHAT IN
THE ANALYSIS --
FOR THE COMMITTEE HEARING TODAY
IT ACTUALLY REFLECTED UPON THE
FACT THAT IT'S NOT JUST PENSIONS
THAT'S NOT MAKING DISTRICTS ARE.
ODD DISTRESS LOCALLY WHEN IT
COMES TO FISCAL ISSUES THERE ARE
NUMBER OF ISSUES THAT YOU
DISCUSSED THIS AFTERNOON WE
WOULD ACTUALLY ENCOURAGE THIS
COMMITTEE TO REFLECT A LITTLE
MORE ON THE LONGEVITY OF SCHOOL
FUNDING THERE HAS BEEN A NUMBER
OF CONVERSATIONS ABOUT THE
INCREASES THAT WE'VE SEEN OVER
THE LAST. TWO YEARS MUCH OF THAT
WAS DUE TO PROP THIRTY IN THEM
PROP FIFTY FIVE BOTH OF THOSE
WERE NOT TENNESSEE IS BUT WERE
MEANT TO BRING US BACK --
TO TO STOP THE BLEEDING
ESSENTIALLY IN IT WOULD BE
HELPFUL FOR THIS COMMITTEE TO
ACTUALLY LOOK AT WHAT WE LOOK
LIKE BEFORE THE RECESSION AND
WHAT WE LOST DURING THE
RECESSION IN AND HOW IT IMPACTED
OUR SCHOOL DISTRICTS WE DO
SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
FOR CALPERS.
COASTERS AND APPRECIATE --
THE SUPPORT THAT GOVERNOR NEW
SIM HAS ILLUSTRATED FOR SCHOOLS
AND WE ALSO WOULD SUPPORT THE
EQUIVALENT FOR CALPERS IN ORDER
TO DO TAPPED BY DOWN FOR OTHER
EMPLOYEES.
MISTER CHAIR MICHAEL HOLE SAYS
OR ON BEHALF OF THE KERN COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENT OF SCHOOLS MY
COMMENTS AND RECOMMENDATIONS
HERE TODAY WILL BE BRIEF.
AND THEY ALL REFLECT THE
CONSENSUS OPINION AND
RECOMMENDATIONS OF OUR FORTY
SEVEN SCHOOL DISTRICTS THAT
SERVE HUNDRED NINETY THOUSAND
STUDENTS.
MY COMMENTS ARE REALLY IN THE
CON OF YOUR COMMENTS AND MISTER
O'DONNELL'S THIS MORNING ABOUT
FUNDING INADEQUACY IN THE STATE.
OUR SCHOOL DISTRICTS UNDERSTAND
THAT ARE WE WE WE LACKED THE
ADEQUATE RESOURCES TO DO WHAT WE
NEED AND WANT TO DO FOR OURSTUDENTS.
IN THAT CONTEXT WE ALSO
UNDERSTAND THAT YOUR LIMITED AND
IN THIS YEAR THIS ENVIRONMENT.
THIS ISN'T THE YEAR WE'RE GOING
TO FIX OUR ADEQUACY PROBLEM IN
CALIFORNIA WE HAVE LIMITED
RESOURCES.
AND FOR US TO ASK YOU TO FIX
THAT IS IS REALLY INAPPROPRIATE.
WHAT WE CAN ASK YOU TO DO OR
THREE THINGS?
ONE CONTINUE TO SUPPORT THE LC
FF WHICH MAXIMIZES LOCAL CONTROL.
AND FLEXIBILITY AND
RESPONSIBILITY AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL WE KNOW WHAT'S BEST.
SECONDLY WE'RE ASKING YOU TO
ADDRESS THE INEQUITIES THAT
REMAIN IN OUR CURRENT SYSTEM.
AND THAT WOULD BE FUNDING MISTER
O'DONNELL'S BILL FROM LAST YEAR
THIS YEAR MR MEDINA IS BILL
WHICH IS SPECIAL LATE
EQUALIZATION OVER THREE THANK
YOU.
WITH THIS THAT YET THRILLED
WHAT'S YOUR THIRD POINT WELL THE
THIRD POINT IS TO RECOGNIZE THAT
INS BECAUSE OF SPECIAL AT THE
EARLIER COMMENTS TODAY ABOUT OUR
AT ACCOUNTABILITY SYSTEM. 65% OF
THE SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN
CALIFORNIA. TWO HUNDRED AND
FORTY THREE TO BE EXACT ARE
THERE BECAUSE OF SPECIAL AT OUR
SCHOOL DISTRICTS UNDERSTAND THAT
OKAY THANK AND THEY'LL FIX IT
THEY JUST NEED EQUAL RESOURCES
THANK YOU CAN I GIVE YOU DOUBLE
TIME.
SO BY THE WAY.
EVERYBODY ELSE IS TO KEEP A TWO
MINUTE BECAUSE WE HAVE TO LEAVE
HERE AT NOON OKAY GOT IT THANK
YOU AND PEOPLE. TEN MINUTES
LET'S DO IT ALL RIGHT.
NO PRESSURE --
GOOD MORNING --
CHAIR MCCARTY --
MICHELLE UNDERWOOD ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL FUNDING
COALITION OUR BUDGET AND
LEGISLATIVE PRIORITIES TO YOU --
THIS IS A GROUP OF MORE THAN
FIFTY DISTRICTS INCLUDING SOME
IN YOUR REGION THAT HAVE BEEN --
ADVOCATING FOR MORE ADEQUATE
FUNDING IN LCF SINCE IT WAS
CREATED MORE THAN SIX YEARS AGO
TODAY YOU HIT ON MANY OF THOSE
PRESSURE POINTS --
SPECIAL EDUCATION AND PENSIONS --
IN TERMS OF THE LC FF WE KNOW
THAT --
MAYBE THIS ISN'T THE DIRECTION
THAT REVENUES ARE MOVING BUT WE
DEFINITELY SUPPORT FULL FUNDING
THE LC FF AND IF THERE ARE MORE
REVENUES AT THE MAYOR VISION WE
THINK AN ADDITIONAL INVESTMENT
IS -- THAT
THE BEST PLACE TO PUT THAT AS
WELL AS CREATE A ROAD MAP FOR
INCREASING --
LCF FUNDING RATES THROUGH THE
CONVERSATION THAT WE'RE HAVING
TODAY IN TERMS OF PENSIONS --
WERE VERY SUPPORTIVE OF THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO PROVIDE
THREE BILLION DOLLARS FOR CAL
STIRS AGAIN TO THE EXTENT THAT
THERE MAY BE MORE RESOURCES
AVAILABLE OUTSIDE OF PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT AT THE MAYOR VISION.
WE WOULD SUPPORT ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES FOR CASTERS AND
CALPERS EMPLOYER CONTRIBUTIONS
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR OF COW
HIGHLANDER BEHALF OF THE CAL
STIRS FUNNY COALITION --
HERE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE
GOVERNOR'S THREE BILLION DOLLAR
PROPOSAL FOR CAL STIRS.
LIKE TO LIE MY COMMENTS WITH THE
MISS UNDERWOOD THESE LETTERS OF
MORE FUNDING AVAILABLE FOR THIS --
WE WOULD BE SUPPORTIVE AS WELL
WE BELIEVE IT'S APPROVED USE OF
RESOURCES THAT'LL GIVE DISTRICTS
MUCH NEEDED RELIEF WELL BUILT
FOR TO WORK WITH ON THIS ISSUE
THANK YOU.
ERICA HOFFMAN ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION.
I'LL JUST LINE MYSELF WITH A LOT
OF WHAT EVERYBODY SAID WE ARE
VERY SUPPORTIVE OF THE INCREASE
WITHIN THE LC FF WE WOULD URGE
YOU TO LOOK AT POTENTIALLY
THOUGH.
LOOKING TO INCREASE THE BASE
GRANTS PROVIDE A LITTLE MORE
FLEXIBILITY IN THAT --
WE DO SUPPORT THE NEED TO AND
ACCOUNTS CALPERS SIMILAR WE
DIDN'T CAL STIRS BECAUSE THAT
WILL THEN PROVIDE SOME
FLEXIBILITY AT THE LOCAL LEVEL.
FOR THE USES OF OF LOCAL FUNDING
SO THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR RON
ROUTE FROM THE CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS
REPRESENTING THE EDUCATION
COALITION THIS MORNING --
ONE ECHO SOME OF THE COMMENTS OF
MY COLLEAGUES WE SUPPORT THE THE
GOVERNOR'S OVERALL FRAMEWORK --
FOR HIS BUDGET PROPOSAL WANT TO
THANK HIM FOR SUPPORTING PUBLIC
EDUCATION --
WE SUPPORT CERTAINLY THE TWO
BILLION --
ADDITIONAL DOLLARS --
FOR LCF SOUTH --
WE DO HAVE A LONG WAY TO GO AND
I KNOW YOU'RE VERY CONCERNED
ABOUT THIS AND THAT WAS PART OF
THE DISCUSSION TODAY --
WHETHER OR FORTY FIRST FORTY
THIRD FORTY SIX WERE STILL AT
THE BOTTOM WE NEED TO ADDRESS
THAT -- SO
WE SUPPORT --
IDEAS RELATED TO INCREASING THE
BASE CERTAINLY --
WE SUPPORT THE THREE BILLION
DOLLAR INVESTMENT AND CAL STIRS
AND LIKE MANY OF OUR COLLEAGUES --
WE SUPPORT AND IT AND AS AS WELL
AND I WANT TO TURN IT OVER TO MY
COLLEAGUE FROM CASCO WHO IS ALSO
REPRESENTING THE EDUCATION
COALITION THANK YOU.
IN ADDITION WE ALSO SUPPORT THE
TWENTY POINT TWO MILLION DOLLARS
TO PROVIDE ASSISTANCE TO SCHOOL
FOR THE STATEWIDE SYSTEM OF
SUPPORT FOR SUPPORTER THREE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND AND
ONE TIME PROD MY DAY FUNDING FOR
THE CALIFORNIA DASHBOARD AND
MERGING ALL THE SCHOOL THIS
REPORTING TOOLS.
AND ON CHARTER SCHOOL
ACCOUNTABILITY WERE SUPPORTIVE
OF THE ADMINISTRATION'S
COMMITMENT TO IMPLEMENT
STATEWIDE ACCOUNTABILITY
POLICIES THAT HOLD ALL SCHOOL
DISTRICTS CHARTER SCHOOLS AND
COUNTY OFFICES OF EDUCATION
ACCOUNTABLE FOR OPERATIONAL
TRANSPARENCY AND COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
HI GOOD MORNING OR GOOD
AFTERNOON.
ANDREA BALL HERE ON ITEMS ONE
AND TWO ON BEHALF OF THE CENTRAL
VALLEY EDUCATION COALITION AND
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
SUBURBAN SCHOOL DISTRICTS. TO
DIVERSE GROUPS.
BOTH STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
ADDITIONAL OF FUNDING THROUGH LC
FF AND APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS
AND SUPPORT LOOKING AT THE BASE
GRANT AND WHETHER WE NEED TO RE
EVALUATE AN INCREASE THAT.
ALSO VERY SUPPORTIVE OF TO
CONTRIBUTE THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL FOR CASTERS AND
PENSIONS AND ALSO INTERESTED IN
LOOKING AT SOMETHING SIMILAR.
FOR CALPERS ON BEALF OF THE
ORANGE COUNTY DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION SUPERINTENDENT ALMA
HARRIS I WANTED TO SPEAK BRIEFLY
ON THE SYSTEM TO SUPPORT.
VERY APPRECIATIVE OF THAT
APPRECIATED THE CONVERSATION AND
LOOK FORWARD TO SHARING MORE
INFORMATION WITH YOU ON THAT
MULTI TIERED SYSTEM OF SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
JOHN WINGER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHARTER SCHOOL
ASSOCIATION --
PREACH AT THE CONVERSATION
AROUND LC FF AND FULLY FUNDING
ALL OF OUR SCHOOLS WE THINK PROP
NINETY EIGHT IS THE FLOOR NOT
THIS.
PARTICULARLY APPRECIATE THE
CONVERSATION AROUND LOS
PERFORMING SEATED STUDENTS WE
THINK THAT'S AN ONGOING ISSUE
THE DESERVES ONGOING FUNDING.
WE DON'T BELIEVE THAT THE GRANT
LAST YEAR --
WAS TARGETED ENOUGH AND WE LOOK
FOR TO CONTINUE IN THOSE
CONVERSATIONS ON THE EL CAP WE
OUR SUPPORT.
AND ARE OKAY WITH --
PUBLIC MEETINGS AND ONLINE
TRANSPARENCY WE DO HAVE SOME
ISSUES ON THE STATE WIDE --
REQUIREMENTS THAT WE THINK COULD
IMPACT SOME OF OUR MISSION
DRIVEN CHARTER SCHOOLS --
AND SO WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING CONVERSATIONS.
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING EARLY
SKIN WITH PUBLIC ADVOCATES --
I PASSED OUT A LETTER FROM THE
EQUITY COALITION ANNUAL CFF --
I JOIN THE CHOIR IN A SUPPORTING
THE PROPOSALS.
FOR L. CFF FUNDING IN THE RELIEF
TO DISTRICTS ON CAL STIRS --
OBVIOUSLY ARE WE BUT WE WOULD
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT IF ANY
SUCH FUNDING IS PROVIDED THAT
ANY INCREASES TO THE BASE --
SUPPLEMENTAL AND CONCENTRATION
GRANTS ARE DETERMINED AT THE
STATE LEVEL IN A CLEAR AND
TRANSPARENT METHOD THAT CAN BE
PUBLICLY REPORTED.
IN OTHER WORDS WE DON'T WANT TO
GO BACK TO THE TO THE FUZZINESS
OF THE TRANSITION PHASE OF
FUNDING --
WE REALLY APPRECIATE THE HARD
WORK THAT YOU DID LAST YEAR ON
THE BUDGET TO IMPROVE
TRANSPARENCY --
WE DON'T THINK ALL OF THE WORK
WAS DONE AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO WORK ON IT WE'RE
STILL CONCERNED THAT THERE IS NO
TRANSPARENCY WHEN.
DISTRICTS DO NOT SPEND THEIR
SUPPLEMENTAL IN CONCENTRATION
GRANTS -- AS
THEY SAY THAT THEY ARE GOING --
TO WE ALSO SUPPORT --
THE THE WORK OF WELL I'M SORRY
THE LOW TRADE --
BEAR LANGUAGE AROUND CHARTER
SCHOOL.
GOOD AFTERNOON CERRILLOS TO
TEACH PLUS SOMEONE ASSOCIATE
MYSELF WITH THE COMMENTS OF THE
SFF COALITION WHEN IT COMES TO
THAT -- IDEA
OF TRANSIT CONTINUING TO FOCUS
ON TRANSPARENCY AS WE GROW WE
HOPE TO GROW THE BASEBALL CFF WE
ALSO WANT TO ASSOCIATE OURSELVES
WITH THE RECOMMENDATION FROM
CALIFORNIA'S TOGETHER IN COBB
NAY.
AS WE THINK ABOUT OUR SYSTEM OF
SUPPORT TO REALLY LOOK AT
EXPANDING THAT TO FOCUS ON THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE ENGLISH
LEARN A ROAD MAP.
IN BEING AND BEING EXPLICIT AND
AND INVESTING IN THAT
IMPLEMENTATION.
AND THE THIRD OUR TEACHERS ARE
REALLY FOCUSED ON WHAT THE ROLE
IS OF EDUCATOR GROWTH AND
LEARNING IN THIS CASE AND THE
STATE WHAT SYSTEM OF SUPPORT.
AND HOW WE CAN REALLY AS A STATE
MAKE IT CLEAR THAT TEACHER
SHOULD BE LEADING AND DRIVING
THE CONTINUOUS IMPROVEMENT
PROCESS AND HOW WE INVEST IN
THAT IN THEIR PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT.
THANKS.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBER STEVE
HENDERSON REPRESENTING THE
COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT OF
EDUCATION.
FIRST OF ALL AS A MEMBER OF THE
IT COAST EDUCATION COALITION I'D
LIKE TO ALIGN MYSELF WITH THE
COMMENTS OF THE PREVIOUS
SPEAKERS.
I'D ALSO LIKE TO TAKE THIS
MOMENT TO ENCOURAGE THE
LEGISLATURE OUGHT TO THANK THE
LEGISLATURE FOR THEIR SUPPORT OF
THE SYSTEM OF SUPPORT.
AND ALSO ENCOURAGE OUR PATIENTS --
AS WE'VE GONE THROUGH THE SYSTEM
OF THE SPORT OVER THE LAST
COUPLE OF YEARS WE ARE WORKING
DILIGENTLY TO HELP THOSE
DISTRICTS THAT HAVE BEEN
IDENTIFIED IT'S A COLLABORATIVE
RELATIONSHIP.
WE ARE WORKING IN COLLABORATION
WITH THOSE DISTRICTS TO HELP
THEM --
SUCCEED AND BE BETTER --
AS WE MOVE FORWARD IN THIS
ENDEAVOR THANK YOU.
EXCELLENT IS AT TWELVE O'CLOCK
ON THE DOT [inaudible]
WELL DONE.
THANK YOU WE ARE DURING. ONE OF
THE